good morning and welcome to uh today's
hearings in the health and human
services and elderly Affairs committee
uh this is going to start looking like
more of a typical day in the state house
uh back when we were running from
committee to committee so we'll have
committee members coming and going as
necessary introducing bills testifying
elsewhere and coming back fortunately we
now have the YouTube recording so nobody
will have to miss a testimony so this is
a huge benefit to what we're doing now
today um and with that I will open the
hearing on House Bill 1706 FN and I will
recognize rep representative Julius sodi
to speak first oh yes sorry we're going
to do the pledge first I forgot sorry
thank you Lisa I pledge allegiance to
the flag of the United States of America
and to the Republic for which it stands
one nation under God indivisible with li
and Jud for
all thank you representative Missour and
representative sodi thank
you good morning honorable committee
members um my name is Julius soti
representing uh the Rockingham 35 the
towns of London der and both
pronunciations of Windham and Windam
that's an inside joke over there um
uh my testimony here is going to be for
the informed consent bill which I am
co-sponsored but my testimony is also
relevant to the following bill so it'll
be covering both
topics um also want to make a point that
this is a
nonpartisan bill and I want to give a
overview of the topic here of what
circumcision is and where it came from
so the hisor
overview
um I'm going to be brief with it because
I'm sure there's going to be a lot of
other people to flesh it out so what is
circumcision circumcision is the cutting
off or amputation of the foreskin of the
penis where did this come
from it's a religious ceremony performed
by Jews and also observed by
Muslims it's a right of passage in a few
African tribes and it's performed in the
early teen years
and make no mistake it is meant to be
painful a test of
manhood that's a test um maybe I'd stay
a kid um I don't think knife and penis
should be uttered in the same
sentence very cringy
um so circumcision is not a thing in the
rest of the world and it wasn't a thing
back then either uh in in the
past but in the later half for the 1800s
in the english- speaking world it was uh
sold as a medical practice a Panacea for
anything that ails you we got your cure
right here hypersexuality check got you
covered uh can't not find time to bathe
check got you cover there too alcohol
problem yeah it'll do that too epilepsy
yep snake oil and quackery all rolled
into one thus the beginning of the
demonization of the forkin
well um oh which by the way does serve a
purpose but I'm sure I have a lot of
Heavy Hitters behind me they'll explain
that part
later uh fast forward to the day and The
Jig Is up it's on the way out infant
circumcision is no longer routinely
practiced in uh English-speaking Nations
like England gave it up Canada Australia
and it's also on the way out in a few
states in the
US but today we still have a these
bitter cling who
are uh clinging to the
practice uh circumcision is still a cure
in search of a disease an answer to a
problem that does not
exist it's in other words it is backward
science uh that and that's what you're
going to be hearing from the other side
what other body part do we do this with
none but let's play the game uh let's do
teeth let's pull out your teeth prevent
tooth decay tonsils and take that out
too or breast buds for both girls and
boys because it prevents breast cancer
and the cost benefits analysis each of
these would be far more meaningful
health impact and
circumcision I want to move to uh some
uh quotes from various public
figures on this issue first I'm going to
go with h i on her Lee she's uh from
Somalia uh she was um suffer or she
was uh she had the female genital
mutilation performed on her and um he
left Somalia became a politician in
Europe and is a human rights
activist here's the quote from
her the foreskin is cut off the penis
that's a form of
Mutilation you should leave the child as
he is as he came in out of the womb he's
finished he's complete
you shouldn't take things off especially
if there's no medical
reason and we have uh George Carlin the
comedian in his
Memoirs last words that's it is PG
rated quote from Carlin I also survived
circumcision the barbaric practice
designed to remind you that uh as early
as possible that your genitalia is not
your
own that's certainly a case for my body
my choice right there uh then I also
have some well Richard Dawkins the
biologist he has some
Twitter posts uh which I'll I'll pass
this around because and then the author
journalist pist Christopher Hitchens
that's also one I'd rather not
read um panette from his uh TV program
uh pen and tellers BS uh they did an
episode on
circumcision and the quote there is vast
majority of the world knows there's no
reason to circumcise someone should tell
the doctors the US doctors that is uh
put down the knife step away from the
baby uh Joe Rogan okay I'm not gonna
read his for the quotes if you can
circulate that because you said that you
went copies and then if you just want to
either speak to the content of the bill
um oh just one more quote well actually
two more quotes and I'm done okay thank
you um Howard Stern radio personality
never thought i' be quoting him he's of
Jewish origin and this is his view on it
I am circumcised and I tell you
something I despise it I despise it I
despise it I'm completely pissed off
that I'm
circumcised and uh
finally uh from the
psychiatrist uh and noted debunker many
science myths Thomas SAS also of uh
Jewish origin I believe that the time
has come to acknowledge that the
practice of routine circumcision rests
on the Absurd premise that the only male
in creation born in the condition that
requires surgical correction is the
human male so another words it's not a
birth effect in fact
um condition where you are born without
a poor skin and there is such condition
that is generally listed as a birth
defect so with that um I end my
testimony I don't think I answer any
questions quite yet I'll wait till the
end if necessary because I got have a
lot of Heavy Hitters who are on The
Cutting Edge of this issue thank you
very much representative sodi uh next
I'd like to call the call Representative
Emily
Phillips and after that it'll be
representative
burough I was just hoping Madam chair
that that people who testify can be
directed to turn very quickly to the
substance of the bill that's in front of
us because the point about the actual
surgery itself has been wellmade and and
I we have all taken the point very
clearly to heart so representative Weber
I believe that they were he was setting
the table for that so that everybody
else can speak to the content of the
bill and we will be going back to having
three minutes um then the committee may
ask questions as well so I will start
with that representative Phillips and
your microphone's off just so you
know thank you members of the committee
um thank you madam chair um my name is
Emily Phillips I represent Rockingham
District 7 Fremont New Hampshire I am
the prime sponsor of the informed
consent
Bill how do you write a wrong um
sometimes you can't so in my role as an
elected official I decided to put in
meaningful legislation to ensure parents
are educated to prevent future
wrongs I am a regret
mom you prepare for your firstborn child
and you go through lots of imaginary uh
scenarios and how you're going to be as
a parent how you're going to care for
your newborn baby what labor and
delivery will look like um nobody
prepares you for the wound care involved
when you choose circumcision for your
son that um was a startling process for
me um in my postpartum Haze uh I don't I
think most of you can agree that
nobody's in their right mind after
giving birth um we're sleep deprived
we're um healing from our own surgical
wounds or the birth process and um there
was no way for me to absorb any kind of
uh you know informed consent had it been
given to me about uh the choice of
circumcision my my son was born healthy
um and about 24 hours old they uh a
nurse came into my room and said from my
recollection you know it's time for his
newborn screen do you want him
circumcised my husband at the time and I
um chose yes we do we didn't know we
didn't even think it was an option to
not uh that was just normal in our
culture
um they took him uh he was returned to
us I don't remember signing anything I'm
sure I did I'm sure I S signed some sort
of uh invasive procedure General consent
form obviously this I delivered at
exitor hospital I'm sure they gave me
some sort of sign off for this um he was
returned to me uh he was all right uh a
couple hours later uh he became very
distressed uh he was um crying and 24
hours before he was just a normal like
healthy sleepy baby um
he the nurse came in and said we're
worried about his respiratory rate uh he
was having very fast uh rapid breathing
and we said we don't know what's going
on but something's wrong so they took
him from our room which at the time they
had a baby friendly policy so the baby
stays in the room with you and they took
him from us and they put him in the
Special Care
Nursery uh for 5 days um and they could
not figure out what was wrong with him
he was just upset um so uh they put a
um an IV in his head say as babies it's
hard to get an IV so they put an IV and
gave him sugar water trying to he he was
not breastfeeding so back then your new
mom trying to learn how to breastfeed so
they do a tummy to tummy uh when they
when you try to breastfeed and I I'm
assuming looking back on it now that his
wound hurt him after the hours after the
local anesthetic would have worn off and
he was distressed and it was hard for
him to breastfeed so they taught me how
to do what's called the football hold
which some of the moms will understand
but basically they lay behind you and
their belly is up to the ceiling so I
wasn't making contact with his wound um
and he was able to kind of breastfeed
and we eventually got out of there he
had ja us which may or may not be
related to uh the procedure um but again
the wound care I was not prepared for um
constant attention and cleaning him and
uh repairing uh what I chose to do him
lasted at least two years um I
never like had a healthy child uh when
it comes to his genitals after that and
um we were referred to a top pediatric
urologist in Manchester um sometime
before he turned one because he had
issues um I don't want to say
specifically but he had complications
and she said we could offer a repair
procedure like a new circumcision or
something or we could um wait and maybe
by the time he was walking or maybe when
he reaches puberty it would resolve um
so obviously after that trauma we chose
not to do anything and just wait because
um why put him through more uh two
nights ago in my research I found out
one of my son's conditions is listed as
a diagnosis code for revisions and
repairs in this state under the Medicaid
um Billings so I know now um he turns 11
next week and I know now that we're not
done so I have to go back um and find
somebody to help us um I will spend the
rest of my life uh in regret and um I
hope he forgives me and I have to have
this conversation with him because he
doesn't know what's going on but um I uh
went on to have two more children my
last son he's two and a half he's intact
and no health issues no special care no
trauma I'm wrapping up I promise um I
ask the committee to be
open um to this discussion um because
infant circumcision is the only routine
surgery performed on healthy infants
that is not medically necessary so
that's why a special form is required
according to Dr uh David Jones who
couldn't be here of University of
Vermont Medical Center uh Medicade and
other thirdparty payers um require
specific consent forms for other
elective procedur is like tual ligations
and vasectomies and that's why we need a
special form in closing I int I
introduced this bill for two mots that I
live uh live by and that's no better do
better encourage is contagious I am open
to all amendments I just want this
conversation to happen and I'd prefer
not to take any questions because I feel
like there's plenty of people and a lot
of people to get through I'm sure that
someone can answer if the committee is
okay with that thank you very much thank
you so much thank you and uh with that
I'll call Representative
burrow
thank you thank you committee members
for having me testify um state repita
burrow as I represent Carol too and I'm
testifying in opposition to this bill um
my assertion is that HB 1706 does not
provide the complete story about this
procedure and potential medical benefits
there is a directive in the bill for
DHHS to provide medical care experts
with an intact care guide with
information to inform parents on the
proper care of an intact penis my
question is since when does DHHS provide
medical experts and healthc Care
institutions with directives on what
information to give P patients are we
doing this with heart surgery tonsilitis
appendectomies the healthc care provider
must also furnish parents with a
comprehensive consent form with a
two-person signature required with it
the circumcision cannot be proceeded
again is such a consent form created by
a government since when is a government
is a consent form created by a
government agency to Health Care
Providers a requirement for any other
procedure the parents must be shown the
restraining board clamp and plastic all
used in the procedure do we require
parents to be shown the scalpel graspers
and needle drivers for an act
appendectomy the bill states that
circumcision is an unnecessary cosmetic
procedure however major healthc care
institutions including the CDC National
Institute of Health and American
Pediatric Association which asserts that
the benefits outweigh the risk state
that there's a decreased risk of urinary
tract infections decreased risk of
sexually transmitted diseases and
prevention of penile problems including
the inflammation of the fores skim
although we did hear opposing SE
testimony today from how Howard Stern
and George Carlin which I I appreciate
um there are disciplinary procedures
delineated if these procedures are not
carried out by the physi by The
Physician or medical professional
including referral to a licensing board
and potential monetary penalties is this
not the purview of the medical
institutions since when is this
something that the legislature regulates
now it's been mentioned Jews and Muslims
have been performing this right of
circumcision for thousands of year years
and many P parents opt to have this
procedure done in the hospital but this
bill would not allow this relig just
custom to be done in a medical office
and I ask could this be interfering with
our state Constitution Article 5 we're
the parental right stand in this bill
should parents be the Arbiters of
whether or not to have their babies
circumcised why do they need to hoop
jump through legislative Hoops in order
to have this procedure in closing to my
knowledge most of our 400 legislators do
not have medical degrees it's time for
the state house to get out of the
doctor's office and Healthcare
institutions and leave such is issues
such as in sent informed consent and
disciplinary procedures where they
belong and stop interference with the
doctor patient relationship thank
you um actually I have a question for
you representative burough um could you
point to me where it says that they are
not allowed to be done in a medical
provider's office I actually don't there
is a there is a sentence I don't have it
in front of me um can I can I look it up
and if you can follow up that would be
fantastic I will do that absolutely
there any other questions okay thank you
oh you have one okay
okay thank you very much
I'll next I'll call um representative
paage boam sorry if I said your name
wrong if I said it wrong please correct
me thank you for having me here today
and uh I'm Paige Bosman uh very close
it's it's French uh so I am paig bman
I'm a registered nurse and a New
Hampshire legislator in the House of
Representatives I'm here today as a
nurse with nearly 15 years of experience
in women's Maternal Child Health with
significant experience in mental health
specific to the reproductive years um I
am the nurse that gets consent I take
the baby to the board where they will be
strapped down and I sooe the babies
during the procceed procedure so I have
firsthand knowledge of this process from
the inside out how it would impact
clinicians and new parents with real
world
application sorry sometimes I need
glasses sometimes I don't getting to
that age um from the beginning 15 years
ago I noticed a significant Gap in
education um and I have some insight as
to why so while all of the and and the
fact is that all of the professional
organ ganizations such as the American
Academy of Pediatrics and the American
College of Obstetricians and
gynecologists all agree that
circumcision is medically unnecessary
it's a well-known and accepted standard
from the obes the nurses this is
something we all know to be true and
this is how we educate our patients and
this is how we are instructed in to
educate them that this is not medically
necessary but it is their choice and I
strongly believe in parent choice the
problem is that there's a gap in the
education one of the reasons being that
uh people do not have pediatricians
until after they have the baby so who's
going to educate them while the obes or
The Midwives and the nurses are very
very good and are well- intended they're
bogged down with so much and they
frankly don't have a good source of
Education this is well accepted in
society and a lot of people don't do
research before they come to the
hospital they don't even know really
that circumcision is an option so um
with that Gap I think this is a really
important opportunity to supply the
community with input um on this health
information um I feel uh strongly um I'm
concerned when I do this I don't think
that people are getting the right
information that I feel comfortable
they're making informed consent um
because it simply isn't there at the
same time I do agree with with the
representative who just came up um I
feel very strongly that it's not our
role as legislators to interfere with
medical practice I do think it's our job
to uh make sure that information gets
out there and I I don't have too much
longer so don't worry um I've been
thinking about this deeply over the last
few weeks and I do have a recommendation
I would recommend um that this bill be
simply ified to include a consent that
is specific to circumcision right now
most of the consent forms are uh consent
for a general invasive procedure they
don't have anything specific to
circumcision my recommendation would be
that we create a form that is um that
that is specific to that and on that
form would be a box where people can
check that they have received a brochure
with education and that they understand
it now um the other thing is that the
state and the federal government already
do regulate many of these there are
forms and education that are required
such as uh helping people know about
Shak and baby syndrome and sudden infant
death syndrome so there is required
education and forms and processes I
would recommend that we talk with DHHS
so that we can see if they would create
a brochure that is congruent in language
and sentiment for the brochures they
already create so would be congruent
with all the education people get in the
postpartum period that would be
consistent across the state everybody
gets that education and then the consent
form is processed the way all the forms
already are thank you thank you are
there any
questions representative
Shapiro thank you madam chair thank you
for taking the question
um you're a nurse who does this so you
know much more about it than myself um
but my question is
um while you've described this
essentially as an elective procedure um
which I would totally agree with you
about um is it not true that if one goes
looking through the research that one
would find
um conflicting research about the
medical benefits of of
circumcision not I'm not making an
argument one way or the other I'm just
saying wouldn't one find in the research
um that circumcision as a pro procedure
has medical benefits as well as a lot of
research that says it doesn't or it's
more harmful than beneficial sure so
there so again the the presiding um
professional organizations that dictate
most of my practice um agree that it is
medically unnecessary now in in previous
years when it was very culturally
accepted
um organizations would say something to
the effect and this is what you might
find um it's medically
unnecessary benefits May outweigh the
risks most organizations are moving away
from that type of statement um a lot of
the research I've been I've been
researching it for 15 years I'm a I'm a
newborn care educator um a lot of the
research that was done that indicates
that it decreases things like STI HIV um
and
UTI um were often done in populations
that don't have the same hygienic um
environments as us so they had increased
risk or they were in environments where
they were exposed to more of those
things that we talked about um so again
it's generally accepted by the
professionals that the best research out
there very much indicates that this is
not medically
necessary thank you
followup then representative mlan after
that and then King thank you madam chair
I have a a different question
so um I'll have representative mlan then
representative Seth King and then
representa Shapiro
again uh thank you uh Madam chair and
and thank you for taking my question so
yeah I mean I do have concerns about how
consent is often gained in my personal
experience it's often been a rubber
stamp and so I have enormous Sympathy
for the testimony of Representative
Phillips who she's under state of duress
almost and she's being asked to put
things forward so on the consent side
which is what this is focusing on you
talked about education um so this bill
as written it does create a special
unique consent form for circumcision but
would it do anything to address the
situation that representative Phillips
found herself in where yes I have a a
dedicated form but it's being put in
front of me again in the state of duress
so do do do you see anything in this
bill that would address that concern or
no uh I recommend um uh reworking the
bill a bit to um focus a little bit less
on the consent although I think it's
very important that it's a specific
circumcision consent but I think that to
even it out we've got to have a specific
brochure that is written that improves
the education unfortunately this whole
concept of educating people before the
postpartum time is a cultural problem we
we that is one of the major problems
it's one of the things that makes this
the most dangerous country to have a
baby um in the industrialized world so I
could say the exact same thing people
come in and want to breastfeed and they
haven't looked up how to breastfeed they
come in wanting a natural birth and they
haven't educated themselves on how to
manage pain so I think the best that we
can do when they're in that state is at
the very least give them a bro sure and
what we know is we repeat things over
and over so we mentioned something about
a Circ at the beginning and give a
little education we give the brochure we
give them time to look at it um rather
than somebody coming in you just woke up
the doctor's coming in at 6:00 a.m.
they're kind of throwing something in
front of you they need to know now
because they're doing the cirs now so if
we give it to them I think you know they
can take it and say okay wait let let us
look at this for a few more hours before
we decide and they can take that time of
the day um they can take the time they
need to really look at it and ask the
nurse questions I I actually think this
would be very well accepted and very
helpful for doctors and nurses and
midwives thank you representative King
thank you madam chair and thank you
for for um coming here today and giving
your testimony I hope you get lots of
questions because I really like the fact
that you've got both Real World
experience as a nurse and also uh
legislative experience and a parent and
and a parent um of two boys this is
probably something I could look up on
Google um I haven't done it yet but I'm
just really curious because in the Bible
it's clear that their per the um their
the circumcision is supposed to be
performed at 8 days after birth um and
it sounds like um a lot of circumcisions
nowadays are being done the day of birth
is that correct and and how did that
happen how did it go from clearly 8 days
of that baby being able to heal itself
from just being born and the the parents
being you know uh of right mind to all
of a sudden like birth circumcision sure
sure um a few and thank you for that
question I'm still getting used to the
decorum
um I don't know the whole history from
the Bible days to now in how
circumcision has developed but I do have
a few answers to your question um one is
um I mean we can't can't have a whole
debate on Healthcare right um but people
are in the hospital that that's where
they are they're there um I will tell
you um I know that some of the standards
of practice are that boys are allowed to
get the circumcision as long as they're
six hours old so that is pretty much the
earliest they could get the
circumcision um my my guess and again
this is a guess is that um you know
we're removed from from the Bible if I
could interrupt for just a moment uh we
have a lot of people testifying I I I
appreciate that you're providing more
than you know but if you can stick to
what you know I'd appreciate that we
have three more questions for you after
yeah I I will say this the people are in
the hospital at that time and if they
leave they're unlikely to come back it's
harder it's more
complicated representative Shapiro and
then representative Weber thank you
madam chair um so on page two
line8 it says um one of the requirements
of this of the process of um informed
consent would be um that the parents
have seen the circumcision devices to be
used and the parents still wish to
proceed with the circumcision of the
child so I have two questions for you
about that yes is that outside of the
norm of informed consent for most
procedures to actually view the tools of
the procedure that's the first question
and the second question is someone who
obviously
does this and is um very attuned to the
um emotional state of the people you're
dealing with um how would you feel about
actually doing that yeah so um when I
read the bill I I had a similar reaction
my recommendation is uh from the
logistical Point as well that would be
impossible for us to do in the hospital
we don't have time to be bringing that
to every patient sterilizing it again
doing the procedure um my recommendation
would be that if if if if people feel
strongly to include that that it would
just be a picture um on the on the
brochure I I can't speak to how many
other procedures do something like that
um but I do think that there's a lack of
understanding of what it is and that
could potentially um that could
potentially inform people um what I will
say is another reason I like the
brochure is because to speak to the
sensitivity and and emotional state
especially firsttime parents they are
very very um they want to be a good
parent and they're very sensitive and
when we go in with something
controversial such as to teach them
about breastfeeding and formula no
matter how neutral you go in they
usually have a defense mechanism and I
think if we're if we go too strong with
this I I I don't want to be the nurse
that has to talk to them about this um
so I want to be really careful because I
do think it can be a very emotional
state for them and just like our
representative you know in that fog and
with those emotional hormones I think we
should be very
careful representative sorry the
information needs to be said but very
carefully thank you representative Weber
and then representative
Murphy thank you very much Madam chair
and thank you for taking my question am
I really getting the sense from your
testimony that what might be more useful
than some of the prescriptive stuff
currently contained in the bill as
written that what we should be aiming at
for all parents is earlier education and
education significantly in advance of
the birth process so that it's one of
those things that they have had a
chance to consider to prepare for and to
be a able to make a decision that's not
that here I am you've got to make a
decision right
now is if if would that be in your
opinion a more effective
mechanism short answer yes real answer I
don't think that it's realistic this is
one this is one extremely small piece of
everything else that people don't get
right they they don't they don't get in
if you don't take a class you don't even
know what the stages and phases of Labor
are you don't know what pin is you don't
know what increases your risk of
cesarian you don't know what
breastfeeding is you don't know you know
this is this is everything um so this is
about that would be about fixing the
entire system I have lots of ideas on
that um but in the existing system with
the existing time that our clinicians
have I think this is the best option
okay thank you representative Murphy
thank you madam chairman and thank you
for taking my question um just simple
question you mentioned medically
unnecessary a couple times I just want
to make it clear you're you're not
equating that to medically
contraindicated are you no no it would
be more neutral meaning um it's not
necessary
follow so if you can look at a procedure
any elective procedure as quote
medically unkown necessary which I would
argue the majority of procedures are
elective procedures would you then be
based on what you were trying to how how
to amend this bill would you then
suggest that every procedure that is
done in an operating room the the
surgeon in or the people taking care of
him show the patient all the equipment
and um all of the other aspects of the
surgery that they may encounter during
the procedure um we're getting a little
far off from
thist the other areas I'm not an expert
in what should happen I know parents and
I am also I've been educating for 10
years I teach child birth Ed classes I
teach perinatal mental health I teach
newborn care I know what is good for
parents in that time period thank
you uh
thank yes you can make a suggestion um I
would suggest that perhaps we um
consider right now that that this might
be a bill that might go to subcommittee
because it sounds to me like there are
any number of real specifics with the
bill that might well be better off
discussed in a a forum with more time so
that people can be heard now um is that
helpful I recognize that however we have
a lot of members from the public who are
here to speak on this topic um and it's
great to have the input from one
legislator but we need to look at how
this committee as a whole will be
dealing with this bill as we move
forward but but obviously all
considerations remain on the table uh
but thank you very much representative
um thank you and we've already
recognized you for two questions
representative Shapiro sorry
representative Nagel you have a question
thank you Miss Madame chairman and
thanks for taking my question I this
question may be for a lot of different
people I really really really appreciate
everything you said about informed
consent I think it's a huge problem but
it's not unique to this procedure um
according to the national health
statistics report from the CDC in 2010
48.3
million procedures were formed in the
United States and this is where my
concern comes in um should we be writing
a separate statute for the tens and
thousands of procedures that are done
every year that we don't provide
informed consent for or is there a
better non you've already outlined a
non-legislative way of doing this is
there a better way in process now to
accomplish that goal without creating
statute I again I can't speak to all of
the other procedures I can speak to this
I can say we have specifics on things
that are extremely important for the
newborn such as the risks and benefits
of breastfeeding and formula sudden
infant death syndrome shaking baby
syndrome and
um this is something the one thing
that's difference between this and most
other elective procedures is this is a
newborn infant who is not doesn't have
the opportunity to give consent for
their body autonomy and I do think that
that is a good reason to
consider extra education on this
area thank you very much um see are we
done yes we're done thank you very much
for hearing me and of course I'm
available for any other questions at any
time
okay um thank you next I'll call Lauren
Sardi and uh I'll make sure that my
three minute timer is a little bit
louder I want to be respectful to every
single one of these every single person
in this room who has signed up to
speak hi can you hear me
hi okay um I'm going to try to shorten
this and really kind of speak to I think
some of the gaps um and inconsistencies
that have already um been brought up so
hopefully that's what you're could you
sorry could you say your name um my name
is
Lauren and also speak a little closer to
the microphone so we can make sure that
we have you thank
you my name is Lauren Sardi I'm a
professor of sociology and women's and
gender studies at quak University in
Hampton Connecticut I'm speaking to you
first as a scholar and a researcher I've
spent the last 17 years of my academic
career beginning in graduate school at
the University of Connecticut studying
the ethics and human rights implications
of neonato penile circumcision and the
ways in which this procedure has been
maintained and upheld in our society
this is done even though all national
and international health and medical
organizations note that the procedure
above all else is cosmetic which we have
already established um um and secondly
I'm speaking to you all as a parent um I
support both um bills that are in front
of legislator this morning um and I'd
like to sort of briefly explain
why obviously as we've covered before
penal circumcision has commonly been
described as a routine procedure
performed shortly after birth at least
in the United States in my previous
research on medical providers and
parents I asked what the most common
reasons were for parents to approve a
circumcision on their child um I'm going
to list some of these reasons below
briefly and also kind of talk about sort
of like why these are a little bit off
um and then explain sort of why this is
all kind of a moot point anyways because
we're talking about the concept of
informed consent um this is actually a
misnomer as it applies to neonatal
circumcision um but I'll get into that
in a little bit um we talk about things
like basic hygiene um it is much less
invasive on a person to just simply be
able to bathe themselves use mild soap
when appropriate we talk about uh you
know this common um uh phrase that gets
tossed around um that circumcision um
prevents UTI um what we actually find is
that you'd have to perform 100
circumcisions to prevent one case of a
UTI um and certainly if a child with a
vula has a UTI what do we do we
prescribe antibiotics we do not
circumcise them um again we talk talk
about these lowered risks of um HPV and
STI other types of STI preventions um
even if you're circumcised you still
need to use barrier protection that is
actually the only um true way to
actually fully um you know attempt to
prevent these kinds of um infections and
and diseases as they later may occur um
from a public health perspective uh
these are easy to obtain easy to use
cost-effective and does not result in
the permanent removal of a part of a
person's body
we also get into other things like
aesthetic preferences uh matching the
father uh things like that which are all
culturally um uh cultural considerations
um parents actually should not allow
their own preferences of genital
appearance to be literally circumscribed
on their infant children as a society I
think we would feel disgusted if we
heard uh parents discussing aesthetic
preferences of infants born with vulvas
and so I will admit it's a bit
perplexing that we do not have the same
response for those parents who have
children born with
penises um so there's a lot of other
reasons here that I could list but what
I really want to talk about is that you
know people also give this argument of
well what if they just have to get it
done later on in life um and what I
would say is that based on the the best
estimates that we have um only one out
of roughly 16,000 adults with a penis
need to be circumcised as an adult and I
say need like there's medical necessity
simply put neonatal circumcision is not
ever an appropriate prophylactic
procedure to be done on neonates or
frankly anyone who is too young to give
direct consent in fact circumcision is
literally the only procedure in the
world in which parents are able to
provide proxy consent to an elective
procedure no less one that permanently
Alters one one's body forever so truly
informed consent as described in medical
ethics the kind of informed consent we
all get as adults for both medically
necessary and cosmetic procedures at
least in theory is not able to be
carried out in the case of neonatal
circumcision right so the the issue here
is that what we actually have is that
parents can provide proxy consent right
so in my research in hospital settings
on circumcision in all cases verbal and
written proxy consent which again is
incorrectly referred to as informed
consent was wholly inadequate and did
not fully include a comprehensive list
of all the important long-term side
effects and risks of the procedure in
fact I was truly taken AB by the number
of parents I talked to who told me that
they not only wish they had more
information about circumcision before
they agreed to it but that one was
brought up earlier but that it was
brought up earlier on in a person's
pregnancy so that they would have had
adequate time to consider the complexity
and permanence of the decision on behalf
of their neonate which frankly we
shouldn't have that choice to begin with
it is not our choice we are not giving
informed consent we are giving proxy
consent which we cannot give technically
in a cosmetic procedure so when we talk
about sort of like well what about this
um situation what about that situation
those are wholly different they're
totally different procedures one is
where you're an adult making a choice
for yourself and the other is where
you're an adult making a choice on
behalf of a child that's not medically
necessary and if you could wrap up I'm
sure we'll have some more questions for
you okay uh I will just say in my own
experience with child birth in 2012
although my Healthcare Providers knew
that I would be having a boy I was not
given any information or even asked
about it until 5 minutes after my son
was already born I was literally being
put back together together after what
felt like the most physically grueling
experience of my life while I already
knew based on my previous academic
research what my decision would be I
could believe there was no discussion at
all about it beforehand the entire time
that I was pregnant um and that I
received no prior consent forms to view
upon viewing information about
circumcision a few hours later I was
still shocked by the blatant
misinformation and lack of any detail on
what the procedure actually entailed or
would have been in store for myself
Son thank you very much for that
testimony uh representative
Merchant thank you madam chair I also
wanted to uh voice my um lightness and
tardiness to this committee this morning
unfortunately had a situation at home I
had to take care of so I was late to the
committee so I want to let you know why
I was
late if I
may I understand the issue of what
you're saying about informed consent and
parents' rights but where do we draw the
line because we always talk about
parents having the rights on behalf of
their children is this not a situation
here where the parents by Def fact still
have the legal right to make decisions
for the children because that's one of
the things we've been talking about is
the rights of parents and the state
should not be infringing upon those
rights so can you speak that please yeah
sure um I guess I would just counter
argue uh that can't argue that question
which is what other um procedure do
parents have a right to take
a part of their own child's body off of
them I I don't know an
appendectomy uh that would be done for a
a a medical
reason thanks follow okay representative
sorry um I have a question for you um I
know that some other practices um post
child birth offering formula and other
choices have um sort of had a paradigm
shift where instead of saying would you
like formula there is a wait for the
parent to request it do you think that a
shift in policy to meeting a parent's
request for circumcision as opposed to a
default assumption that all children
will want to be circumcised would have a
more appropriate conversation on those
desires given that there's no medical
reason that it needs to be done
immediately yeah I certainly think that
that the Paradigm Shift has to occur and
that the Assumption should not be um
that the default should not be at all um
that this is what parents want um and I
think it honestly puts medical providers
in a very tough situation um where
they're forced to kind of you know I
think many medical providers aren't
really interested in this um but but
parents are asking for it um and they're
also asking for information and it's
such a touchy subject that that there's
just not a lot of communication going on
um but I would also argue that again
something like formula is is and I'm not
I'm not suggesting it you know um it's
just not an equal comparison at all in
any way shape or form we talked vaccines
not in equal comparison earpiercing not
an equal comparison and so I truly mean
when we talk about this is the only
procedure in which someone's body part
that is important is permanently removed
it it stands alone it really does it's
tough to
compare thank you representative kushman
thank you madam chair and thank you for
taking my question um you had said that
there were about 1 in
16,000
um uh medically necessary circumcisions
in adults um do you know what the rates
are for um dealing with complications of
circumcision um the best estimates that
we probably have and I certainly I've
seen these actually in some on some
consent forms are anywhere between two
and 5% potentially more um and which I
didn't actually say um out loud but what
I believe is actually much more commonly
the case is that we get revisions done
because a circumcision is is done um and
because we're moving we're removing very
small parts on a very small body um as a
a person is growing into their bodies uh
things change um so revisions might be
necessary um but what also equally is
going on is that when we talk about
circumcisions that are performed um
after the the neonatal period we're
talking about often times issues that
occur from lack of knowledge and lack of
information on how an intact penis
actually works which is that the forkin
at Birth is fused to the head of the
penis so when I hear things like oh
somebody told me that I need to retract
to clean under it no you don't that's
actually causing um harm it's causing
damage it would be um the physiological
equivalent if you will of trying to
clean under your nail into the nail bed
you cannot do that because your nails
are fused um to your fingers right um so
that is what causes significant damage
and that is what leads to circumcisions
um in the you know in the post neonatal
period can I followup thank you um I was
actually asking and and you did touch on
it at the beginning about um revision
rates for circumcision and and
complications from that do you know um
what some of those potential
complications are following
circumcision um there is yeah yes there
is significant um research done on what
those complications are in the short
term um you know usually what we see are
things like adhesions um where the
forkin attempts to um heal itself and um
uh sort of connect back onto the head of
the penis um there are also other kinds
of issues dealing with um uh too much
skin that's removed um so skin that's
actually sliced off or removed from um
the head of the penis too um things that
have to do with uh uneven or Jagged
kinds of um forkin cuts um things like
things like that um you can also see
things like forkin Bridges um that could
occur um they're they're incredibly
graphic I I think you You' probably want
to search them thank
you seeing no other questions thank you
very much for bringing oh sorry
representative Murphy my apologies no no
thank you very much J thank you for
taking my question um are you aware of
how circumcision is Le listed in the CPT
codes uh for most medical
insurers um I think it depends on the uh
Insurance are you are you aware that
this listed as a cp2 code under cosmetic
surgery or as an elective
procedure um what I have seen in the
past is that they it's sort of listed
under its own category of of just
circumcision not not as even underneath
either one of those but I again those
codes change so I'm not quite sure just
to be clear so you're not aware of it
being listed as a cosmetic procedure um
for insurance purposes no but it should
be thank
you um thank you very much and uh
perhaps there's somebody who knows uh
knows coding who can get into those
answers thank you very much for your
testimony um and representative
santonastaso I apologize that I did not
see you listed as a representative when
I was handling the C so it was not an
intentional oversight since we
recognized Representatives
first thank you uh good morning Health
Human Services and elies Affairs
committee I'm representative Santa naso
representing the towns of ringe Jaffrey
and Dublin I'm in support of House Bill
1706 this bill provides notice to
parents prior to circumcision of an
infant as you all know by now um in the
bill Roman numeral 10d says your son may
want an intact penis and a decision to
have a circumcision denies him his
bodily integrity and autonomy which he
may resent when he
matures my relationship with my mother
suffers today and this is in part
because I resent the circumcision that I
received as an infant um I do believe
she was just going through the motions
we I'm not from a religious family
there's no reason that she would have
had the circumcision except that that's
just what you do um if she was informed
she might have made a better decision
and uh it could be possible that our
relationship wouldn't have this
contention point that it has today an
adult can always undergo a circumcision
later if he so desires um for for 10 C
uh circumcision is associated with
between 20 and 47 known complications
including heavy bleeding infection
disinf scarring uh mental sceris uh skin
Bridges loss of sexual function poor
cosmetic appearance follow-up correction
surgery and in rare cases death
uh the long-term impact of newborn
circumcision on the physical sexual
emotional and physiological
psychological Health self-esteem and
wellbeing of boys and adult men has
never been followed is only being
explored and publicized in response to
increasing complaints from circumcision
suffers and those pursuing Force skin
restoration uh my own circumcision was
botched and mine like most other people
I believe wasn't counting the stats
because it wasn't until I was 17 years
old old at actually at a physical where
someone had the courage to mention to me
that uh there's surgery available to
correct this sort of thing um before
that nobody would even dare talk about
such a thing even though uh it must my
parents must have uh been aware of it uh
because it's it's obvious uh all
circumcisions where the person doesn't
desire it is a botch circumcision uh one
of the outcomes of a botch circumcision
is death uh so it's important for
parents to be aware that this procedure
may actually kill baby um it may be
directly from hemorrhaging or indirectly
uh like in the uh known very known case
of Bruce rier who at 8 months old had a
botch circumcision so bad that it led to
the result of him losing his penis the
parents under guidance of a psychologist
attempted to raise the Bruce as a girl
and this ultimately failed as Bruce took
his own life at the age of 38 um
circumcision for convenience and
hygienic reasons is not necessary even
if it was true that circumcision is more
hygienic it would be similar to
believing that if we remove a baby's
arms it would be easier to put his shirt
on it off uh because you know it's
really hard to put their shirt on they
like move their arms a lot um removing
body parts to make it easier to keep a
baby clean is inappropriate all three of
uh my boys are uncircumcised and we have
a three-year-old and two 7-month old uh
twin babies um and there's zero
additional tasks that we perform to to
take care of him uh so in the United
States on the very first day of a baby
boy's life uh in these moments when a
newborn should be experiencing the Gent
care and bonding with his mother he is
instead subjected to an act that can
only be described as a brutal assault
this procedure introduces the innocent
newborn to experiences of pain and
Trauma it makes it so that at one time
in that person's life the only thing he
understood was brutality it's a
perfectly crafted evil a practice that
embodies the very essence of Injustice
and violence against the most innocent
thank you and I'll will take questions
if necessary thank you very much are
there any questions from the committee
representative kushman thank you madam
chair do you know what the um the risk
of death is following circumcision the
statistical risk uh well we can't even
understand the psychological damage so
for people taking their own life and
things like this uh we don't know uh but
I know that death from hemorrhaging and
stuff like this is one of the more it's
uh more rare than the other uh
conditions representative Merchant thank
you madam chair and thank you taking the
question do you support parents rights
uh sorry do I support what do you
support parental rights uh of course um
but this is making a decision on behalf
of someone else that is UN irreversible
and medically
unnecessary thank you representative
thank you
uh next I'll call Dr David
Conway and uh three minutes I'll make
sure my timer is close to the microphone
so you can wrap up at that
point Madam chairman members of the
committee thank you for letting me
testify today uh my name is Dr David
Conway I
can is that better okay I'm a retired uh
board certified OBGYN I practiced for
about 33 years about 16 years here in
conquer uh at the uh residency over at
conquer hospital where I in fact trained
residents how to do circumcisions I've
done probably 500 to a th000
circumcisions I never really kept track
of those numbers I kept track of the
number of kids I delivered which is
about 2500 so half of those were boys
and half girls pretty much um I'm here
to testify in opposition to this bill
um the it's an incredible intrusion in
the practice of
medicine dictating the specific
information on the informed consent
requiring submission of that form for
approval requiring parents or patients
to inspect the surgical instruments and
that parents be shown a restraining
board I can think of no other surgical
procedure that re requires that degree
of legislative intrusion which is no
news to since you've heard testimony to
that fact already uh I'm not going to
read the whole uh statement I um
provided to you
um I certainly agree that it is not a
medically indicated um procedure it's an
elective procedure there are a variety
of elective procedures that don't get
this kind of scrutiny uh one that I'm
particularly familiar with is tubal
liation um during prenatal care one of
my my jobs as the provider was to talk
about circumcision and also about tub
liation not so much to liation as
contraception after delivery um whether
that those are recommendations from the
American College of OBGYN and that was
certainly part of my practice and part
of my uh job as training residents um
it's a painful procedure when I was a
resident in the late 1980s local
anesthesia was not used and kids scream
a whole bunch and I thought it was
barbaric and I chose I don't know if
you're familiar with the type of
instruments that are used um to do
circumcisions there's um a Mogan clamp
that is kind of like a uh a pincer that
kind of uh clamps across the the
foreskin there's a gamco clamp there's a
plastibell and there advantages to both
I used a in in residency I used the the
Mogan uh because it was quick and it got
got it over with as quickly as possible
for the infant uh because it was very
clear to me that it hurt
um I don't have anything really more to
add to my statement I will certainly
take
questions representative kushman and
then representative Shapiro thank you
madam chair and thank you for being here
um to
testify um so
we are you do you understand that the
practice of medicine and lure to
practice medicine was created by the
legislature and therefore the
legislature creates the rules that one
agrees to operate under for that license
I am well aware of that I was a member
of the medical review subcommittee for
six years uh of the Board of Medicine um
I was uh a member of the Board of
Medicine itself for 7 years and
eventually president of the board so I'm
well aware of that thank you follow up
yes follow up um um understanding that
and I I just want to kind of um contrast
that or show that there's precedent
for us having a form and would you agree
that we have Protections in place for um
the human rights of subjects in medical
research and we have increased um
consent requirements for when that's
going to be done on children um are you
aware that we have consent forms for um
vaginal births after cesarians section
and that that's in our statute also so
that this isn't creating a new um a new
idea or a new method of ensuring
protection for patients I'm not aware of
those specific requirements um informed
consent is Central to doing surgical
procedures or any kind of procedure and
it's something that's very clear clearly
taught during medical school and very
clearly taught during
residency representative shap and then
representative Weber thank you madam
chair thank you for taking this question
we've we've heard terms like um
cosmetic elective
unnecessary um we've also heard from at
least one person about some of the
health benefits of
circumcision um but we've heard these
terms as if they were um one and not the
other and um isn't it true that there's
some overlap between elective surgery
and medically necessary surgery for
example um when I had terrible sciatica
problem I was given the option of a
medically necessary back surgery um it
was still elective I mean I chose not to
do it um
because you know I made the decision
based on my research so isn't there some
overlap between what's
medically I don't maybe there's another
term s it's medically necessary but um
medically legitimate and
elective hard question to answer because
i' I've sat in your shoes with exactly
that same decision and uh the outcomes
after this is not going to be news to
you but the outcomes after back
surgery don't Norm don't typically last
for a very long time and there's
certainly complications involved so I
don't have a great answer for
you r representative Weber and then
representative poos
off thank you madam chair and I my
apologies I had to step out for
another trying to be in two places at
the same time so you may not be the
appropriate person to ask this question
and if it's not your field uh just feel
free not to answer I was just wondering
I know that certain other states have
regulations in this space do you know if
there are other states that have adopted
this particular bill in its compl
complete form as it has been presented
to us because from what I heard from
many people prior to this meeting it
sounds like this is a a form that and a
movement that is National in scope so I
wondered if it has been adopted in its
entirety elsewhere I don't know I I've
been retired for about seven years uh is
that something that could be going
around it could be but I have no
knowledge of it I'll hold it for later
thank you I think it's a little bit over
the top uh representative p then a
representative Merchant and then na
thank you Madame chair and thank you for
taking my question so if we modify this
bill in in your opinion what's the best
procedure or what's the best time to
discuss this issue with a parent uh we
heard testimonies that sometimes it's
discussed uh minutes after delivering uh
so that's probably not the best uh peace
of mind for mother to make decision so
when when it should be discussed with Ma
and like in what form like should it be
like some additional opportunities to
opt out or opt in uh could you uh give
your thoughts I don't think it's a
specific time it's uh recommended
sometime during the prenatal period
during prenatal care um one one topic
that comes up is contraception
specifically around tubal liation and
for Medicaid patients there's a
requirement that that could be performed
Med and the consent be signed 30 days
prior to delivery so somewhere
between uh seven months and eight months
or I'm sorry five months and eight
months kind of a flip of the
coin I representative
Merchant thank you madam chair and thank
you for taking a question Dr Conway uh
first of all congratulations on your
retirement in regards to the incent form
form of
consent as a practice physician who's
delivered to 2 200 people into this
world was that something was a verbal
consent was it written consent um
because it really kind of elected
procedure surgical can you comment on
whether it's more of a verbal consent or
was this a written consent any kind of
invasive procedure has got to be a
written consent written consent so in
saying
that where do you stand on an a formed
consent it sounds like we already have
one because it's a surgical
procedure the question I think I'm
wrestling with is how does prescriptive
that form has to be dictated by the
state I don't have a good answer for you
um if I listed every single possible
complication for every single procedure
that I was trained to
do I would spend hours which I talked to
I've talked to patients about what are
the most common things that happen
certainly with uh circumcision there's a
risk of bleeding that's kind of is a
no-brainer um there's a risk of I'm not
sure if you really understand what
happens with a circumcision that any of
the instruments really
crush the um foreskin and uh the extra
foreskin that is uh being taken off is
then ex sized above that Crush line uh
whether it's the the Mogan clamp that
kind of comes together like this or
whether it's the um gamco which comes in
three different sizes which really gives
people the best control over uh how much
force skin to take off um one of the
possibilities is that that Crush line
can separate so the foreskin then kind
of slides up the the shaft of the penis
um I'm not sure if that answers your
question you um representative Nagel and
then representative
shapir
thank you um Madam shair thanks for
taking my question I had two different
questions I decided to go with a
different one because you answered mine
um I've been a doctor for 40 years it's
actually my 40th anniversary of my first
circumcision that I did so um it's
ironic that we're here today to
celebrate that event but
um one of the things that's really hard
about becoming a young doctor and you as
a teacher would know this is learning
how how to inflict pain because it's
part of the job
MH Am I Wrong um is it unusual for us to
ever inflict pain on a patient when we
do a procedure of any
kind if somebody is under general
anesthesia then there's really you would
be inflicting pain if they were not
having general anesthesia right so um
you inflict pain when you inject local
anesthetic um having had several
Misadventures with um kitchen knives um
and visits to the the emergency room
local anesthetic hurts like hell um and
the amount of local anesthetics that's
injected for doing a dorsal P block is
four 3 to four1 of a CC on each side of
the uh dorsal penis at the the base of
it um so uh I will tell you that the
difference between doing a circumcision
without anesthesia compared to doing it
with the dorsal penar block
and um a kind of a sucrose Solution on a
pacifier is like night and day as far as
the experience of perceived pain of the
infant
thanks thank you uh representative
Shapiro thank you madam chair um if we
were to um am end up amending this bill
to create an a form consent form um that
you know listed pros and cons cons um or
if we amended it to create a br an
educational brochure to do the same
which I think people should be fully
educated who would be in your opinion
who would be
the experts and maybe non-experts who
would come together to create a that
kind of form or that kind of brochure to
um to have you know people with
different ideas represented who would be
who would the experts who would be the
in best position to
create um that kind of informed consent
or bro education brochure um I don't
have a perfect answer I would include
people who do the circum do
circumcisions as an OBGYN it's something
I was trained to do it's something I did
throughout my career um pediatricians in
different areas of the country where
I've practiced um were more likely to do
circumcisions I never fought for them
they it's not something I go out of my
way to try and talk people into period
um Family Physicians those are the
people who are doing most of these
circumcisions um so certainly one of
those uh members of the public who have
uh some say in the matter uh nursing uh
I would I didn't put it in my statement
but I used to be a labor and delivery
nurse before I went to medical school um
so I've seen it from a couple of
different
sides thank you very much okay thank you
still have a representative mlan thank
you madam chair and thank you for taking
my question um based on some of of the
prior testimony and your experience um
do you feel that uh the informed consent
that we have right now is adequate um
you know based on your experience and
and what they've testified to and do you
think that there might be some Merit you
know in non-emergency cases to maybe
altering the Paradigm a little bit to
frontload some of that consent so it's
not coming at the last minute or would
that not be practical that's an
excellent idea um that's certainly what
we do uh prior to doing a um tuation as
far as getting that consent signed um
and the conversation about contraceptive
options goes into that whole process so
I think that would be reasonable uh I
think having uh putting in every
possible complication uh is really over
the
top thank you
yep um seeing no further questions thank
you very much for your time doctor uh
next I'd like to call Adrianne
sodi push can you push the button so the
red light comes on and then give us your
name thank you thank you hello esteemed
Representatives I am uh State Rep julus
so's wife from wiam New Hampshire I come
here today to support this bill as a
resident of wiam and a mother of three
children this this issue is very dear to
my heart because it concerns child
welfare I'm grateful that representative
Phillips brought this forward and we
have an opportunity to discuss it and at
the very least raise awareness you see I
moved here as a teen from Hungary where
just like in the entire European
continent or most of the world in fact
circumcision is not performed
prophylactically for disease prevention
it didn't even cross my mind until after
the birth of my first son in 2005 after
an exhausting day of giving birth upon
leaving the hospital my husband warned
me to make sure his son does not get cut
or else something really bad is going to
happen to the doctor's
genitals I didn't understand why he
would be worried about this at all you
see in my in my mind circumcision was
strictly a religious ritual of a faith
we didn't belong to but lo and behold
when I was by myself recuperating from
giving birth and after a sleepless night
trying to nurse my newborn I was in fact
presented with a form where I needed to
check off if I wanted to have my son
circumcised there was nothing to explain
what that meant why it was an option it
was simply listed like one of the
choices on a restaurant menu
I was surprised but not wanting to hurt
either my babies nor the doctor's
genitals I checked no my son's polish
pediatrician did not try to pressure me
at all he's the one who came to the
hospital to check out the baby so we
were smooth sailing until the time I
inquired if there was anything special I
needed to do to keep my little boy clean
that was the time he demonstrated how I
needed to push back my baby's foreskin
to wash under it at bathtime to my
surprise my son started screaming and
once we got home I found a drop of blood
in his diaper and in the next few days I
noticed a tiny scar on his
foreskin this is what prompted me to
start researching for myself sure enough
I found out that I was given the wrong
advice by my pediatrician I learned that
at Birth the foreskin is attached to the
head of the penis and the tip is like a
tight sphincter that keeps dirt out
there is nothing that needs to be done
besides rinsing it with water in fact it
was easier to keep clean than my girl's
private parts and definitely much easier
than caring for a circumcision wound R
for infection in a dirty diaper which we
know many parents don't even realize had
the hospital included a brochure about
intact care like they do about
breastfeeding umbilical cord care car
seat use which is regulated by the New
Hampshire Department of Justice this
could have been avoided
even at my pedian office this type of
written instruction was lacking despite
an entire wall covered with brochures
the American Family Physicians website
has a list of postpartum discharge
instruction that includes genital care
wouldn't it be nice to print that for
parents on a website from 2006 it says
parents should gently cleanse
uncircumcised genitals with warm water
the foreskin should never be forcibly
retracted because this makes cause fosis
well I can thank my intuition and
inquisitive mind that I did not cause my
child a true fosis but we can certainly
use a little help in ensuring that
proper information is provided to new
parents by those who are entrusted with
their children's care this is what I'm
hoping you will assist with in order to
make sure that doctors honor their
promise to First Do no harm thank thank
you very much for your
testimony seeing no questions from the
committee thank you very much um next
I'll call Andrew schaer um and Zoe
Fowler up to speak together I'll give
you three
minutes sorry I can hand that over to
you actually want to take
it CH I can keep doing fine okay
okay so is is this on yes that's on okay
thank you um so firstly I'd like to
thank you all for
uh allowing us the the the chance to uh
speak about this today and um I'd also
like to apologize in advance I do have a
mild to moderate stutter that I've had
from a very young age um so I come to
you today to support the bill um to
include informed incent to inform
parents of you know sort of the risks
and dangers and you know of
circumcision I've been circumcised
myself as has my father and
unfortunately as has my son I was not
informed I was not educated nowhere in
my um my sex ed classes in school um my
pediatricians or doctor's office um or
even prenatal um training or uh
educational materials when I was taking
fatherhood classes they taught us you
know don't shake a baby the no-brainer
stuff don't hurt your kid but they also
didn't teach us what really hurts our
kid they they missed one big
thing and it's something that I you know
I didn't know
about I didn't remember being
circumcised as a child and many of the
issues I had I just thought it was part
of puberty just part of growing up you
know
just and um but the worst part was what
happened to my
son I didn't think it was really all
that bad when it was happening he didn't
scream he just made kind of a little
whimper noise like you know you pinch a
person a little too hard but it was a
week later when he started getting
infections after we were cleaning him as
we normally would we followed the
doctor's instructions to the tea we went
to and before that we went to every
class we went to every course we did
everything that we thought we were doing
was right and he still ended up with an
infection and a fever of 102 and we
nearly lost my son we had to take him to
the
ER I nearly lost my boy that
day and I I I I I'm terrible with names
here so I don't remember who it was who
said that they were a regret mom and
that they hope that their son can
forgive them one day as someone who's
going through that myself
something that absolutely breaks my
heart is I don't know what I'm going to
say to Michael
when when he's old enough to ask me hey
Dad what happened to my foreskin why'd
you put me through a procedure that can
kill people that gave me an
infection what happened to my
sensitivity down there maybe he has some
other issues that come about in life
later that I don't know psychiatrically
physically I'm not a doctor I'm not a
medical professional I'm just a
concerned parent and a person who is
also you know grieving over my own body
now that I've as a foreskin restorer
over the last three
years
um I it really taught me a lot about
what I had lost and what I had taken
from my
son I I if someone had issued me a
brochure or any of the things that we've
been mentioning here some sort sort of
you know sheath of
papers maybe about this size with this
amount of information on it I would have
turned back and said no you're not
cutting my son I would have said no
you're not going to risk my
son his life his well-being I wouldn't
let you and I wish and my ex-wife wishes
and my father wishes and I wish that we
had the information available to us
I uh thank you that's been very powerful
thank you if there's anything else to
wrap up but that's been incredibly
powerful thank you so much for sharing
what's such an emotional emotional and
important thing to you so thank you for
being here thank you you have a
wonderful wonderful day were there any
questions furthermore I will say that in
my opinion an procedure such as this is
not only unnecessary it is frankly an
abomination against the ideas of freedom
and Justice that it be done with so
little information given to the parent
and uh that it is allowed to occur to
someone who is completely unable to even
speak on their
behalf thank you thank you both both
very much thank you I'm going to turn
the chair back over to Chairman
McDonald thank you representative Lon um
good morning everyone um I apologize for
my voice this morning I've been crowds
straining my voice talking loudly the
last several days so it's not uh it's
not a cold it's just trying to get my
voice back so apologize for that uh next
uh signed up to testify is Ben Bradley
from the New Hampshire Hospital
Association uh Mr Bradley you've
indicated uh five minutes if you could
keep it to three we'd really appreciate
it yes of course I'm happy to do that Mr
chairman it's honor would be in front of
the committee for the first time in my
new role as the vice president of state
government relation for the New
Hampshire Hospital Association we
represent all 26 hospitals in the state
including um our 15 birthing hospitals
um the New Hampshire Hospital
Association I'll keep it brief uh is
opposed to HB
1706 uh and I'd just like to share a
quick concern uh that has been um
mentioned before but I'd like to
reiterate uh we believe informed consent
is a critical process that ensures
patients or their representative
participate in the development of plan
their plan of care
however this bill puts into statute very
specific language to be used for
informed consent of a circumcision
procedure we're not aware of any other
statute that prescribes this kind of
specific language for informed consent
or any other medical
procedure uh treatment or care uh by
doing so our concern as a legislature
would enact language that becomes
outdated or insufficient to keep up with
modern medicine I'll leave it with that
and I'll take your questions thank you
representative Leon uh thank you Mr
chairman and thank you and welcome to
Health Human Services looking forward to
getting to know you uh my question is
about the way that some of the policies
and hospitals have changed that some of
the things that were just presumptive
before became an on request service and
my question which you may need to go
back and get answers for would be if the
hospital associations would be opposed
to moving to having circumcisions on
request as opposed to saying here's the
form yes or no because I remember even
though I was very aware of this the
forms that I had were did not have all
the information that I needed understood
yeah I think that's something the
legislature should contemplate is
whether it would be appropriate to
legislate that kind of um consideration
for a for for what you just described um
as far as I know I think it would also
be important to bring together medical
experts to understand what would be most
appropriate um happy to work with you
I'm sorry I don't have a concrete answer
uh for your exact question um but that's
my respon
response other
questions representative
Palmer thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question represent so you
brought up the can you get the
microphone
closer I want to hear what you have to
say can I get taller no sorry um thank
you for taking my question um you
brought up the concern I have which is
that the language in here is sort of the
consent form and I'm my question is
would the hospital Association support a
a bill that just said a consent form
will be created with um you
know a a group of experts and and
concerned
citizens doing that so that it's that
now a document that could be changed
over time yeah I think I think I
appreciate the consideration of allowing
those mechanisms that may already exist
to support how to inform
informed the informed consent process
right um I will say that you know the
centers for Medicare and Medicaid
services does have uh guidelines and
standards rules requirements for
informed consent as does the Joint
Commission DMV uh with their
accreditation so um you know I can't
commit to uh you know something before
seeing it I'm happy to take a look but
our big concern is really just
legislating the specific language that
you see before you thank you sentive
Weber thank you Mr chairman thank you
for taking my question um as a followup
to the earlier discussion um and
with understanding of concern about
intruding ourselves into the practice of
medicine I wonder if there would be a
willingness on the part of the hospital
Association in connection with medical
providers to undertake a rigorous
examination of both the informed consent
process and the
um question of whether this is something
that you you have a yes or no whether
you have to ask for it and say gee I'd
like to talk about this procedure as
opposed to having it in
legislation well and that's try what I
tried to allude to with representative
Palmer is to use the body that exist
today to help with informed discussion
with experts who can make determinations
and help help with the
process followup
sure I guess my concern is trying to
make sure that somewhere along the line
in this discussion there would be a real
um representation that that would happen
rather than that it ought to happen I I
think these are I can't speak for as a
medical profession
but what I would say is I think that the
expectations of an informed consent are
routinely reviewed on an ongoing basis
in a moment in time I think that would
be continually important this is an
important discussion for the committee's
consideration on the importance of
informed consent and um I'm not opposed
to to working with anybody on um on this
issue representative
Merchant thank you Mr chair
could you speak too how long a form has
to be retained by a facility um if
you're a minor because in here it says
specifically 25 years if you're an
infant that probably makes a lot of
sense but if you're not if you turn it
into someone who does it at 10 or 11
year ages of year that's a long time so
is 25 years consistent with what
hospitals today have to do with consent
forms for
minors I do not know the answer to that
question precisely um I will say in what
I've heard previous previously is
statute has recognized a 7-year hold um
of medical information seven
years seven years from thank you Mr
chair sorry seven years from what time
is it seven years from age of maturity
or is it seven years from the time it's
done I don't have a I don't have an
answer for
you want to
speak and uh representative
Nagel thank you Mr chairman thank you
for taking my question I'm assuming that
your voice is gone because you were at
the Bills game with me I was not no okay
I would had more fun probably than where
I
was um I I I really appreciate the
discussion here today especially about
informed consent because I agree that
it's a more Global problem that we
really seriously need to think about
more globally with that
said I do have concerns about this bill
that I wish you could answer for me and
I will reiterate what I said earlier
um there in 2010 when I assume the
number may be increased I don't know but
48.3 million Surgical and non-surgical
procedures that would have required an
informed consent of some sort this is
just one small element to that and do
you as your organization see this bill
as a potential slippery slope that we're
going to start facing not just this but
another legislation next year another
next year another next year for back
pain obviously we should do it for back
pain too right um do you see that as
potential problem with bills like this I
think that's a reasonable consideration
that the committee should think about
yes other
questions I'm seeing none thank
you also signed up to speak is Rob Barry
from the Department of Health and Human
Services good morning Mr chairman and
members of the committee I will be brief
um so um we are just here to provide
information we don't have a position on
the bill uh but I did want to direct the
committee's attention to a couple things
um on page two of the bill line
25 it gives the department the ability
to Institute disciplinary procedures for
violations of the section uh in talking
with our licensing certification unit
here at the department or at the
department um we're a little concerned
about how we could enforce that there is
some overlap with um with patient files
that we might be able to look into with
this kind of um this kind of issue but
it's not something we anticipate that
would be an easy enforcement mechanism
for the Department with that being said
to the extent that there's any uh
suspected misconduct on the part of a
medical provider we do refer those to
oplc so that would some be something we
could do uh but we just wanted to raise
that with the committee the last thing
is on page
four um line 20 this is the consent form
that we've been speaking about um
currently the bill reads as the
department is the final Arbiter of what
these consent forms should look like and
how they should be presented um it's a
bit outside the scope of what the
department does um we've heard some I've
heard some recommendations from um many
individuals around the table here uh
that this should be a an effort uh by
medical professionals members the
community things like that the
department would wholeheartedly support
that as it doesn't feel like it's
equipped to deal with um such a task and
with that I'll take any questions okay
thank you representative
Merchant thank you Mr chair and thank
you Mr Barry for taking the
question would you look at line all of
us line 27 on page
two my concern is that in here is a
monetary penalty for medical procedure
as medical
facilities uh can you comment the fact
that they're not the ones doing the
procedure but the healthcare provider
why would the medical facility be
penalized well when we have licensing
rules that we put in place we do have
the ability to issue civil monetary
penalties uh this may be something that
falls under that but to your point
representative Merchant this was
something when I was speaking with the
uh the bureau chief of Licensing
certification we were not really sure
how we could Institute proceedings based
on this section uh against the facility
we'd have to look into that but it's not
immediately clear how this would fit
into our ongoing uh licensing
scheme thank you other
questions representative kushman thank
you Mr chairman and thank you for taking
my question um hopefully I can remember
what it was
now um oh would you find that
um you were saying that you don't want
the department or it's kind of tricky
for the Department to be the final
Arbiter of what the form says um would
you agree that perhaps a better way
would be to find a form that already
exists from an organization that um has
created one like the Midwifery um
consent form for vaginal births after
cesarian I mean that's a potential
option but I I think the more
appropriate or at least the Department's
perspective is the more appropriate
course of action is to
involve as many stakeholders who have
knowledge of the situation as possible
thank
you Al representative
Shapiro thank you Mr chairman I I see on
the back of the spill that there's no
Financial note um as of yet um but is it
safe to say that if the department
actually had to provide copies of such
forms at no cost to a variety of um
groups that there would be some
significant cost potentially um with um
with printing when especially when
you're not able uh to charge the
receiving entity for it it can cost a
lot in uh ink toner um and in particular
staff time um you know I I deal with
right to no requests a lot um and they
can take a significant period of time to
um to get out there so um it's it's a
substantial amount of time to put the
stuff together sometimes thank
you
other
questions seeing none thank
you also signed up to speak is Richard
Arthur
Angel um from bodily autonomy and equal
rights so you've indicated you want 10
minutes I'm afraid we can't give you
that much time um we said everybody to
keep it right around three minutes
please good uh also uh you've you've
filled out this card for both this bill
and the next bill we need separate cards
for each bill uh so if you could do a
separate card for HB 1683 I'd appreciate
that oh sure sure no problem the good
news is uh most of what I was going to
say has already been
addressed um but but um there are
certain things that I would like
to to uh to address uh for one thing one
common theme that I'm here we've got
medical professionals who oppose the
bill we had a doctor we had well anyway
um the problem is that medical
professionals think they know more than
they do and uh Studies have been shown
uh I actually sent links to such studies
two of them um studying medical
textbooks in the US which uh do not
adequately educate about the foreskin
and its
functions and uh surveying doctors and
finding out that they don't know
anything about what they're cutting off
so appealing to
doctors is is
uh it's not a good idea it's called a
argumentum vacunan or uh appeal to
Authority but when the authority are
mistra or uninformed themselves that
does nobody any
good this is not a medical issue it's a
human rights issue any and all argument
about the pros and cons or medical
benefits versus
not benefits it's all bunk when it comes
down to bodily
autonomy uh which by the way is a
concept not any particular
organization uh the first
Speaker representative buroughs uh cited
the AAP but the aap's statement which
was made in 2012 and which was heavily
criticized and torn apart by all the
medical organizations of the world
basically uh expired uh several years
ago and is null and void and the
CDC they themselves refer to it so it's
all
bunk there is no valid medical reason
for uh amputating baby boys for skins
and
uh as men who are who are uh victims of
this we do not appreciate it um there
are hundreds of thousands of men that we
know of based on sales and inquiries and
so on that are undergoing forkin
restoration as for me I have to say this
because people have to know that um it's
not a good idea people have to know the
truth but I keep a an O-ring or other uh
device in place on my penis to hold
vestigal skin and scrotal tissue over
the
glands to keep it
protected the glands whether male or
female is an internal organ that is
supposed to be covered and
protected if that ever slips off and I
lose
it then within a short time I start
feeling very uncomfortable as the glands
painfully rubs on my clothing just like
before I started the foreskin
restoration uh when I was 25 years old
and within a few hours my
meatus uh that is the uh urinary opening
burns with pain from being exposed and
rubbing on my clothing you could please
St please St wrapping up your testimony
one of the questions was the rate of
complications the answer is we don't
know because such complications are are
hidden it's a criminal operation and the
truth would put circumcisers behind bars
uh and so of course the complications
are being hidden but meatal
stenosis that is hardening of the UR uh
the opening there the the meatus is
diagnosed in about 20% of cases I sent a
link to representative Phillips to to
back that up that that 20% diagnosed I
maintain that there's a 100% rate of
meatal stenosis sir but it's only
diagnosed as such once it uh it starts
obstructing the urinary flow thank thank
you sir thank you I support the bills to
to defund circumcision from Medicaid it
is not a medical procedure it is a
medical fraud and to uh inform parents
so uh so as to slow down their eagerness
to have it done to their children thank
you are there any
questions represent Kush representative
kushman thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for being here and taking my
question um you had mentioned that
um you had alleged that it's a criminal
operation and I just kind of wanted to
explore that a little bit is there some
way of making money off of poor skin oh
absolutely oh absolutely look it up look
up um uh forkin uh regenerative uh cream
there's facial cream that's being made
with foreskins that are basically taken
from hospitals uh you can look at up uh
Candace Williams uh Candace Owens excuse
me did quite an expose on that it's a
huge business that's not to mention
foreskin
restoration um one study found that uh
well there's a potential for billions of
dollars if men had the money to do it
they would get their forkin back not
that it can be done
really other
questions saying none thank you
sir and again please don't forget that
card for the next bill
um also signed up to speak and I hope I
pronounced this correctly Yakov
abuhav am I
close yes my name is yob abav um I was
born and raised uh Jewish Orthodox where
the practice of circumcision is
routinely done um with no anesthesia um
the baby gets a a tip of of uh a finger
is dipped in the wine that's made a
blessing and they put in the baby's
mouth and and there you go um it is not
a uh a joyful s at all
um any anyway
um the circumcision comes you know as
far as you go from the Bible when uh it
is done as part of a contract between
God and the Jewish people and uh it goes
from there even my Mones um thousand
years ago is a Jewish scholar a
philosopher and a and uh and
um and a doctor um wrote that it was
mainly done um for the benefit as it
would kept uh U men for from uh
masturbating and uh this is nothing but
a uh a
religious ritual that got carried on
into the modern times where most people
around the world would not do it when it
comes to circumcising uh females
everybody's oh it's a big deal and um I
would uh it would be funny to see people
uh playing the parental rights card on
that one uh in this country um it only
works if when it's for uh
male
um that's pretty much the gist of it but
uh at the very least if uh as long as
it's legal people should be afforded at
least a good acknowledgement to what the
procedure is and what it is not thank
you uh any
questions seeing none thank
you also signed up to speak is David
lellan and Mr lellan again uh you've
indicated five minutes if you could keep
it to three I'd appreciate it I'll do my
best
good morning and I appreciate the
opportunity to speak about this very
important issue my name is David lellan
it's good to be back in New Hampshire my
grandmother was from Pike I am somewhat
unusual in that I am the uh
non-circumcised intact male from uh with
a circumcised father and circumcised
brother I was born over in Salem Mass
and I was a premature infant and had a
doctor who decided not to circumcise me
because he thought it would kill me I
was premature and I am an attorney at
law and practice in Atlanta Georgia I
have been a a 1979 graduate of the
University of Virginia school of law
I've been a litigator for 44 years and
have been studying this entire issue
since
1980 uh just before uh we had
children um since 1995 I've actually
been litigating circumcision issues I've
been admitted proac V in 28 States I've
lectured at Pace University uh lawol
school on this issue and at Jefferson
Medical College in Philadelphia and
several International symposia I have
handled about 72 genital injury cases
arising out of circumcision including
such things as shaft stripping buried
penis part of the glands being cut off
or rotting off uh forc forkin retraction
and other uh injuries I have handled
over about 22 wrongful circumcision
cases where a parent where a child was
circumcised without permission I've
handled about handled or advised on
about seven cases where parents were
arguing over
circumcision um I will go into this more
with the other bill but there are a lot
of risks and the risks are really
unknown the last statement the American
Academy of Pediatrics the folks on that
committee admitted that they didn't know
the risks even though they were willing
to say the benefits they thought
outweighed the risk but they really
didn't know the risk submitted to the
committee is has been um a uh uh a a
pamphlet that cites an 11 or a a study
that was uh put on at the society for
Pediatric Urology that showed an 11.5%
complication rate uh I believe it is
greater than that 20% of the average
pediatric urologist time is spent
repairing
circumcisions uh I think probably 30% of
men who've been circumcised have had too
much shaft skin removed um what I do
want to say is this is not a Rel
religious issue none of the bills that
neither of the bills that you'll
consider today have anything to do with
uh religion uh my family is somewhat
unique one of my brothers-in-law is
Jewish uh and his sons are Jewish
although I don't know if they practiced
uh one of my nieces uh has is a uh PhD
in Arabic studies Married An Egyptian
and converted to Islam I do not see the
bill of informed consent for a medical
place having anything to do with
religious circumcision and certainly
does not prohibit it or even require
that parents in religious ceremonies be
uh uh informed of these things although
I must say that even there having
represented about five Jewish children
uh who suffered serious injuries uh that
it would not be a bad idea but that
certainly isn't What U is required if
you could please stop wrapping up let me
say this circumcision is unique okay it
is the only so-called medical procedure
that removes a normal body part from a
normal infant that is why the consent
form needs to be there it is also the
only surgical procedure that is
solicited unrequired surgical procedure
that is solicited doctors ethically are
not supposed to solicit medical
procedures and yet they do on a daily
basis in fact when my first son was born
the first thing that happened after he
was born as a nurses waving consent for
him going do you want to have him
circumcised that is why the
non-solicitation part of this statute is
so important uh I realized I I should
say this I have brought a book here I've
passed out some things on the function
of the foreskin as well as other things
you can look at I do want to say one
thing doctors will say and Dr Nagel I I
appreciate you very much and the other
doctors on the committee doctors
honestly are not informed by the things
I'm handing out which are what I handed
out at Jefferson Medical College to the
students when I lectured there they
would be the worst persons in my opinion
to be on a committee
this is unfortunately a very political
and as you can tell from the testimony
here to a highly um emotional topic I
think though if you look at it seriously
sir why don't we see if there's any
questions at this point are there any
questions representative kushman thank
you Mr chairman um I you had mentioned
that you are an attorney and uh I just
wanted to clarify something um just for
the record um it's according to the
lawyer code of professional
responsibility whenever a lawyer seeks
legislative administrative changes he
should identify the capacity in which he
appears whether on behalf of himself a
client or the public and so are you
acting on behalf of yourself your client
or the public today I I I'm here just as
an individual acting on behalf of myself
in an issue that I think is important
and no no one has uh uh I'm not
appearing here on behalf of any
organization whatsoever thank you
representative
palazov thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question you mentioned uh
parents arguing about circumcision so is
father have any say uh in whether this
procedure will be done and like in your
opinion is there any change needed in
this
situation when parents don't agree well
I do I do believe this our law allows
parents to make this decision one can
argue whether or not it ought to do I
think two parents uh if both are
involved as this statute requires should
have to agree on it absolutely I have I
have seen spite circumcisions I have
seen people fighting over this uh I have
seen uh instances where parents uh you
know the parent the boy won't be
circumcised and then a parent later
marries somebody who wants the boy
circumcised and they have custody we
fought over that in Chicago uh yes I
think it's absolutely essential that
both parents have to consent not just
one parent not just the mom who is was
under anesthesia uh and may not even
know what she's signing I represented a
a boy uh who when he turned 18 wanted to
sue his circumciser we found out that
the mother really didn't even know she'd
signed a consent form she had just been
given demoral a few hours before and she
said she didn't even want her son
circumcised so yes I think both parents
absolutely should have to consent thank
you representative wber then
representative Merchant thank you I I
may finally have found the more
appropriate person to ask my question um
do you know uh if this uh legislation
which appears to me to be sort of
national in its submission has been
adopted unchanged in any other states uh
I I do not know I do not believe it has
been okay thank you okay I this isn't
like uh the American legislative
exchange Council who's sitting around uh
lobbying uh legislatures okay I I in
fact I didn't even know about the
existence of this bill until somebody
alerted me to it about two weeks ago and
asked if I and representative Phillips
asked if I would come up and offer my
testimony thank you
Merchant thank you Mr chair and thank
you for taking the question following up
on the question from representative
kushman I understand you're not here
representing anyone except
yourself again for full disclosure and
transparency are you here on your own
dime um I
I years ago okay when I was asked to do
a case in Chicago uh where parents had
agreed not to circumcise the boy they
were both from Europe the mother then uh
divorced uh married a circumcised man
who had a circumcised son who wanted to
push the circumcision on the boy uh a
number of people donated money uh
essentially for my travel expenses I
think I don't think I charged any fee in
that case I thought it was important
enough to do it pro bono but I had to
pay a co-counsel and and I had to have
travel expenses uh and as a result of
that an amount of money has remained in
my trust account that we did not expend
and that is I'm using that to be here
today if that weren't available either
friends would donate it or I'd be here
on my own
dime representative Shapero thank you Mr
chairman um you just spoke um about both
parents consenting yes sir and I'm
wondering um I know you're not a
physician you're but you are lawyer so I
wonder if that is like significantly
different than any other kind of medical
consent um where my understanding at
least as a parent and as a mental health
professional that um it takes a parent
you know in good standing a parent who
actually has guardianship to consent to
medical treatment um and that um you
know people wouldn't typically be asked
to have if a mother takes their child
for for treatment to have the father
come in also to give their consent so
would this be a departure from the norm
yes it would but I think it's an
important one and I'll give you an
example I was involved in advising in a
case in Missouri where the child had not
been circumcised the dad had always
wanted it done and actually managed to
get custody of the child took the child
and had it done while he had custody and
had the doctor call and laugh at the
mother so do I think both parents should
have to consent absolutely I'm very
passionate about that I I think it it
it's not fair to the child remember this
is unique this is the removal of a
normal body part on a child who cannot
consent proxy consent for for non for
reasons everyone agrees is not medically
necessary under the ama's there the AAP
I'm sorry the American Academy of
Pediatrics own guidelines that is
unethical all right but we allow it but
if we're going to allow it certainly
both parents should have to consent it
should never be done over the objection
of one parent followup followup
um I don't think in whatever we do with
this bill um I don't think we're going
to solve the problem of contentious
divorces or contentious parenting so I I
I wouldn't use this personally I
wouldn't want to use this as an
opportunity to try to solve that problem
oh oh I I'm certainly not think having
done an amount of divorce work I've done
a wide variety of cases in my time not
just the cases uh I agree we aren't
going to end that contention but it can
requiring both parents to agree would
end the bickering about it in many
respects because it would just be the
law and parents would have to respect
that and you would not have the coercion
that often happens there was a terrible
case down in Florida where a uh couple
had agreed the mother had agreed at when
the kid was one to have him circumcised
the parents never were married uh she
had custody eventually he got custody
one of the doctors testified well I I
would do it but it's really not
necessary on a four-year-old okay and
the mother ran with the child hid out
got arrested and literally was forced to
get out of jail to sign a consent form
in Chains It's theonomous case and you
can look it up on YouTube it's
absolutely it's one of the worst things
I've ever think I've ever seen filmed in
a courtroom here in this country if both
parents had had to agree this wouldn't
have happened thank you other questions
representative Merchant
thank you Mr chairman it's not often we
have a knowledgeable attorney before us
so I w't take advantage of it um so bear
with me in regards to this procedure if
I understand it
correctly have had the time for a child
basically at that point in time a parent
makes a decision and therefore causes a
complication and therefore you're
basically saying the child has some
legal ramifications to the parent
and this is one of situations where the
parent makes a choice on behalf of a
child and therefore as an attorney
you're representing the child if you
will against the parent can you tell me
how this different than a parent elects
not to have a child receive polio
vaccine and subsequently becomes victim
of polio and how the parent at that
point in time is now going to be subject
to ramifications of making that choice
on behalf of the parent Char I have
never represented a child against a
parent in which hesitate to do so uh
I've I've only
represented um I guess it was one young
man against a doctor who circumcised him
okay uh be because with the consent was
invalid I would I do think that the
circumcision is quite different than
vaccination vaccination can actually and
I don't want to participate in this
because I don't particip I believe in
vaccines I understand there are people
who do not they're out they're in front
here this morning uh I respect that but
I think that vaccines have a I remember
I'm old enough I'm 73 years old I I
remember Polio I have a couple of
friends who still have metal braces okay
I don't for one minute think that
vaccines don't work effectively are
there risks yes I'm allergic to
polyethylene glycol when I had to get a
covid vaccine I had to discuss with my
physician is it worth the risk because
peeg is in the thing and we decided it
was luckily I didn't have a reaction to
it so I think vaccination is an entirely
different issue here you were removing
normal healthy tissue from a normal
infant now this statute doesn't prohibit
that okay and I and I'm not here to
argue that it should be
prohibited I socially I might argue that
it should be but that's not what this
bill does this bill merely says parents
are going to be told these risks I want
you to know I have seen a dead baby who
bled out I'm representing a child right
now who came very close to dying and had
two units of blood from a normally
performed circumcision except they took
off all the shaft skin on the ventral
side of the penis the wound open because
of pressure the doctor earlier said
something about wounds opening they only
open if you've taken off too much skin
the child starts to bleed the parents if
if they're lucky get to the hospital in
time and it's not just poor parents it's
Rich parents too I had a pediatric
urologist guy head of Pediatric Urology
Georgetown told me they had a situation
where very wealthy parents right next to
the hospital Hospital uh had a wound
separation the child almost died I have
seen a child that I believe died from
circumcision from bleeding but I didn't
take the case because the autopsy was
blown and the body was was uh cremated
so I couldn't take the case because I
couldn't prove negligence on the part of
the doctor I'll get to it this afternoon
but one of the problems with Medicaid is
here in Atlanta is that what the doctors
are doing is because Medicaid takes a
couple of days to be approved they
aren't doing the circumcisions of the
hospital they're running and doing them
the office and then believe we've gone
Way Beyond the scope of the question or
the bill and I know there are other
people waiting if it's related to
another bill sir yeah I I'll take that
up this afternoon I'll sign up for
representative Nagel did you have a
question or you kind of had your hand up
but I wasn't sure okay do yes thank you
Mr chairman thanks for taking my
question I just wanted to ask you a
question you you in the last can you
hear me sir you in the last um um um um
what you call it witness both implied
that doctors really shouldn't be
considered the experts on this and I
want to ask I want to delve into that a
little bit more so I want to make it
clear I did my first circumcision 40
years ago I did my last circumcision 40
years ago it's not something I do and
it's not something I'm an expert on nor
what I even profess that but there are
people who are Dr Conway who was here
early uh pediatricians things like that
are you implying that they're not
shouldn't be considered experts or
doctors in
general I think it depends upon the
doctor and depends upon what he has
studied for example I asked Dr Conway if
he could name for me the five layers of
tissue in the forkin he could not I
asked him to take the the items that
I've just given to you he refused them
okay medical Campbell's Urology 10th
edition does has a diagram in it that
does not correctly show the layers of
tissue in the foreskin there has been
such a prejudice against the foreskin
which actually in this country arose as
a result of masturb anti-masturbation
Hysteria just asking you your opinion
well the reason I think that doctors are
it depends upon the doctor Dr vanau
whose uh articles I have cited has
studied the issue in detail I think he's
an expert but I don't think everybody is
and I think a lot of those who claim to
be experts really don't know what
they're talking about when you get an
AAP committee who says well the benefits
outweigh the risk but we don't know what
the risks are when I can tell you what
the risks are then I think there's a
problem and that's that's thank you sir
any other questions
seeing none thank you thank
you also signed up to speak is Shane
Brewster and again Mr Boer you've
indicated five minutes please try to
keep it to three I will thank you uh
thank you all for your time today I
appreciate it uh hello my name is Shane
Brewster I am a neighbor from the north
I am a mayor born and shortly thereafter
circumcised in Portland
um I a part of an Ever growing
discontentment among those circumcised
young uh those who have had this
procedure without medical necessity and
without being able to give their own
informed consent I do not speak for
everyone uh we all have different
relationships with our bodies but I am
not alone in wishing my body was left
intact I head up the main chapter of the
National Organization of restoring men
Norm for short a network of men who
provide information and support to those
concerned about being circumcised are
considering for skin restoration or are
in the process of restoring their
foreskins foreskin restoration is
mentioned in section 10 C of the bill um
to elaborate quickly as it's kind of a
niche subject uh forkin restoration is
the non-surgical regrowth of penile skin
via tension induced mitosis in other
words by tugging on the remaining tissue
over time consistently usually with the
device someone can trick their body into
growing a functional fact simile of a
foreskin uh This Is Not A New Concept
it's not a fad forkin restoration has
been traced back to Roman times when the
pondis judeus a weight typically of
bronze or copper was AIX to the penis
for men wishing to undo what was then a
less extreme version of circumcision
compared to what we practice today um in
modern times we are now following
similar principles to those used in
Antiquity but with devices made of nylon
and silicone the materials have changed
but the wish to undo a choice forced
upon oneself
lingers uh the process of forkin
restoration can take months to decades
uh depending on an array of factors it
can be immensely beneficial both
physically and mentally but takes a
level of time and commitment that a lot
of men struggle with at top that there
are specialized tissues excised during
circumcision which cannot be regrown in
this process forkin restoration is in no
way ideal but nods to Roosevelt with a
do what you can with what you've got
where you are kind of attitude uh I've
helped a handful of men locally over the
years but as we are more trees than
people up in Maine I am also well
connected on the internet uh the online
platform Reddit has a forkin restoration
Forum which alone has around 33,000
users currently roughly growing about a
thousand users a month I'm also a member
of 15 square a United kingdom-based
organization formerly known as Norm UK
their website traffic is upwards of
60,000 visitors a year as I said I don't
speak for
everyone um but there are a fair amount
of folks around the world who like
myself have been robbed of the chance to
experience life in an unaltered Natural
Body men who like me struggle with the
physical and mental impacts of a
procedure they did not consent to where
a bill like this the circumcision
transparency act as it's called in place
when I was born my life would be much
different from
discuss please stop to wrap up your
testimony we do U for family discussions
um I was circumcised with the prompting
of the Doctor Who delivered me um he
offered a slew of proposed health
benefits that we know now are not
grounds for the preemptive removal of
healthy tissue um parents should be
fully educated about circumcision should
they ask and not be erroneously coerced
into a decision that has lifelong
impacts for someone other than
themselves thank you thank you
questions representative Paz off thank
you Mr chair and thank you for taking my
question uh about uh
restoration uh do you have any estimate
uh in terms of like financial burden on
a person who tries to restore uh his
Forest skin and also is this process ass
associated with any known further
complications
okay um as far as
financials um restoration can be as
cheap as you want it to be or as
expensive as you want it to be so some
people can do it by manual means by only
using their hands um some people use
medical tape and devices they make on
their own um other devices cost several
hundred dollars a piece um and it just
kind of depends those devices need kind
of Maintenance over time and when we're
talking about someone who might be
restoring for 5 to 15 maybe 20 years
those things have to be updated and
changed with
time uh pardon could you remind me the
other portion complications from
restoration uh some medical side effects
um nothing that I can speak to of
specifically this is an issue which
often isn't understood by doctors I've
brought it to all of my Physicians that
I've spoken to including my chiropractor
for fun um all of them had no experience
in this and I was the first person to
bring it to them so um my apologies I do
not have any firm answers
there thank you other
questions I'm seeing none thank you
thank
you also signed up to speak is
representative Ellen
Reed thank you so much Mr chair and
honorable members for the record my name
is Ellen Reed I represent Rockingham 10
new market and new new Fields um I think
it sounds from what I've heard that
pretty much everyone is in agreement
that parents as you've heard multiple
testimony are not getting proper
education before this you may remember
me sitting before you um last year that
I am an advocate for patients being
informed um so it should be no surprise
that I am here today I did want to point
out a couple of
things that haven't been mentioned and I
wanted to address a few things that I
heard so the first thing is that um some
of the opposition has come from women
and I've not to say that because they're
women but I personally am hurt by that
because as a woman there is a ban on
female circumcision in this country and
in our state that protected me as a
child as an infant right and yet we
don't have those Protections in place
for men now this does not ban
that procedure but I find it hard to
benefit from protection while we're not
protecting male
infants um on the hospital guidance I
wanted to to point out an example of a
hospital guidance that I was given on
circumcision because I think it kind of
tells the story it gives the care for
both a circumcised penis and an intact
penis at the bottom of the care for the
intact penis Which is far more simple
it's simply just making sure it's rinsed
it says in all bold never forcibly pull
the foreskin back because it could cause
pain bleeding or tears in the skin
that's literally what you're doing when
you circumcise the infant so the care
guide is saying don't do the thing that
um that so many people kind of do just
culturally um on the issue of medical
necessity and the idea that for some
reason it's believed culturally believed
to be medically necessary when in fact
80% of the world it is not considered
medically necessary if you ask the
Physicians Association in England or
France or Germany or Japan or any of
these countries they will all tell you
across the board it is not medically
necessary which is why 80% of men across
the C across the world excuse me are not
automatically circumcised but the idea
that well there may be some one in
16,000 people need to be uh circumcised
as an adult um
by comparison things that we don't
remove from infants like uh appendix
appendices I should say and gallbladders
and winstom teeth while one in 16,000
adults may need adult circumcision one
in 20 need anend appendectomy one in 10
need gallbladder surgery and 85% of
people need their wisdom teeth removed
as adults we do not take those from
infants so why would we do something
when only one in 16,000 people need it
as an adult on the question of if you
could please start wrapping up I will do
my best Mr chair I understand that this
is um has been a long uh hearing on the
question of the duress state of the uh
of the mother I do think that the
recommendation for showing the tools
that are going to be used can help
because that is a state where they're
not able to process maybe things like
facts and figures but are able to see
the tools and kind of emotionally
process what they would be doing to
their child on the question of why did
it become like an 8-day thing in
religion and an a same day thing
culturally I think that speaks to the
fact that this is a cultural thing um
PRI predominantly cultural thing for
some people a religious thing in our
culture but it's just something we've
become accustom and used to and I think
our job as legislators is to be willing
to question what we're comfortable and
used to and weigh things logically
objectively on the basis of
merits um on the issue of parents rights
the thing is that parents we we have
laws we have laws it's not parents have
all rights we have laws protecting
children from their parents Ming them um
and then finally the paradigm shift I do
personally agree that an opin probably
would be more in line with um the the
facts of the matter being that it's not
medically necessary I am glad to hear
the suggestion that this will go to
subcommittee I do agree that bill could
uh use amending to streamline and soften
the language uh to make it more
consistent with Hospital documentation
that currently exists um but we do have
Hospital documentation that's required
to be given to parents and other uh
people other patients as well so uh
having said that I don't think I have
technical ability to answer a lot of
questions that you have had before you
already but I will happily answer
whatever questions you any
questions seeing none thank you
also signed up to speak is Dr
PM good morning and good morning and
again uh you've indicated five minutes
as close to three as you can possibly be
we'd appreciate I'm going to set my
timer and try to stick to what I have
not heard already here I am representing
for myself I'm a family practice
physician I came all the way from
Vermont here to speak to you because
I've been worried and concerned about
these issues for the 40 years that I've
watched medicine uh I've heard doctors
speak I did circumcisions on my own
patients I also delivered my own
patients because I was a family doctor
in the midwest in Ohio and in Cambridge
Massachusetts the problem with all of
this is that it is a bipartisan issue
and right now you're not understanding
as I'm he hearing it that this is very
unique as the attorney said there's only
one other thing that looks like that and
that's female genital mutilation yes I'm
using very harsh language I did not say
cutting I did not say circumcision I
said female genital mutilation you've
already heard that there's a double
standard I want to say that I'm a mom
who got caught in this and I would love
to have had the kind of informed consent
that you're talking about here despite
being a doctor despite having my son
intact till the age of 11 my divorced
husband managed to take him in for a
circumcision when I was out of town all
right so that's one reason you want to
have both parents I'll also say that
since I was in Massachusetts I helped
write the laws that said that only one
parent should consent to surgery and
that was about abortion issues all right
because often it was the father or the
uncle or the brother that was the
perpetrator so I was hoisted on my own
patard I know that you do not have the
same attitude towards abortion that I
have in Vermont but I want you to know
that there are two issues here one is
who's paying for this one is whether
anybody is a regret parent physician or
patient you've heard from the regret
patients I'm a regret parent I'm also a
regret physician I was different from
what that other doctor did I did not
lean into it and try to do this fast I
tried to know what to do do that door
side penile block from the very
beginning what happens nurses were
telling the doctor telling the P ask for
Dr param your baby will sleep through
the procedure if you have Dr parm okay
so I started saying okay this is
religious if you're Jewish go and get it
done as a bris and in time I understand
that there's a political issue here this
is not anti-semitic okay to be saying
that this is not something that we want
the state of Nash of uh New Hampshire to
be covering all right and it's also
bipartisan because I know some
Republicans are like hahaha the the
neoliberals are hoisted on their own
pitard because that other bill that
you're going to discuss later is going
to take away the coverage from Medicaid
patients right I don't think it should
be covered for any medical insurance not
in a newborn genital autonomy is a very
real issue and it it haunts people I
took care of Somali women all right they
resented what had happened to them all
right right it's not that different you
heard it's not that different and I will
wrap up it's not that different for the
men I say it three times a peaceful
Earth begins at Birth thank
you oh so
sorry my name is op Yi that's a Nigerian
name but I'm an African-American who's
been here since before
what am I doing
now that was a question and I sat back
down to answer the
question no thank
you thank
you
good
morning one day several years ago I
found myself in a hospital spending time
with a family member who had recently
given birth this was my first time in a
Maternity Ward and I didn't quite know
what to
expect suddenly someone entered the room
overpowered me restrained me and cut off
part of my penis while I screamed in
protest remarkably this happens in
hospitals around the country every day
perfectly healthy people are strapped
down and have their genitals probed
clamped sliced and partially amputated
while they are too vulnerable to resist
or fight back the hospitals obtain
consent not from the affected person but
from that person's
parents putting aside the fact that
proxy consent in which a family member
speaks on behalf of a person who is
temporarily unable to speak for himself
is not valid for the amputation of
normal healthy body parts we are here
today to discuss the issue of informed
consent are the parents on Whose legally
dubious consent the hospitals rely to
avoid accountability being properly
informed about the trauma and harm of
this unnecessary body
modification in almost every case they
are not the head of the penis is an
internal organ it should be warm and
moist and protected like your eyeball or
your tongue in addition to serving this
protective purpose the foreskin contains
muscle tissue blood vessels and
erogenous nerve endings similar to those
found in the lips fingertips and
cliteral
Hood the forkin also facilitates sexual
activity by gliding back and forth
across the head of the penis during
intercourse sealing the lubrication
inside and reducing the likelihood of
painful dry
chafing these and many other functions
are documented throughout the medical
literature but until recently they were
absent from most Anatomy textbooks in
American Medical
Schools the more one learns about
foreskin the more disturbing it is that
this fascinating body part is being
destroyed by a medical industry that
does not fully understand the damage it
is
causing we live in a nation of with
Wounded genitals many of whom allow that
injury to be passed to their sons
without even realizing that anything is
wrong parents love their children and
want what's best for them when they
learn the reality of this unnecessary
genital trauma they protect their
children from it if my parents had known
about the structure and function of the
human foreskin they would certainly
never have allowed such a barbaric thing
to happen to
me HB
1706 will result in a better educated
population fewer human rights violations
and less suffering for baby boys and for
the men they will become thank
you also signed up to speak is
georgeanne chapen from intact
America
good morning good morning that still is
morning is it you're thank you thank you
I want to thank the uh have three
minutes ma'am thank you I want to thank
the honorable members of the New
Hampshire house Health Human Services
and elderly Affairs committee for
allowing me to speak today and I want to
thank the bill
sponsors um for bringing this extremely
important issue uh to the attention of
the people of New Hampshire this is a
really unique uh opportunity for people
to learn about such an important subject
my name is George an shapen I am the I'm
an attorney of bioethics authority and
former uh Chief Executive Officer of
Hudson Health Plan a Medicaid Managed
Care Organization that operated in New
York for 25 years I was the CEO the
entire time it was acquired in 2014 by a
larger insurer
I currently head the Hudson center a not
for-profit technology organization and I
am the founding executive director of
intact America which I'm here to
represent today intact America is the
largest professional anti-circumcision
advocacy group in the country and I'm
speaking here on behalf of the
organization and our approximately 375
supporters we represent in New
Hampshire today as we've heard a mother
who gives birth to a son will be set
upon by doctors nurses and Hospital
staff who will encourage her to
circumcise her baby um some of the
things that mothers will be told is that
it's cleaner that it's healthier and
that everybody does it you've already
heard about the condition of the mothers
when they're approached and asked to
sign a consent form so I won't go over
that again but I know this because in
the 15 years I've been leading intact
America I've heard from
hundreds um no thousands of mothers with
similar stories on the delivery table or
the morning after giving him birth a
doctor or nurse approached them and said
you're going to circumcise him right or
it's time for his circumcision or it's
just a snip it won't hurt or when I said
I wasn't sure they told me he'll thank
you for it later other organizations
committed to protect protecting babies
from painful penis reduction surgery
non-medically necessary surgery that's
what it is receive the same kinds of
complaints in 2020 to verif ver ify the
extent of such overt solicitation intact
America conducted a national survey we
found that new mothers were asked an
average of eight times if they wanted to
have their boy circumcised even if the
mother said no the first time the rate
was higher for women of color who
disproportionately are enrolled in
Medicaid I believe these women were
targeted because doctors know Medicaid
will pay for the procedure despite the
fact that circumcision is medically
unnecessary among the known
complications of circumcision are
Hemorrhage closure of the urinary
opening mangling partial or total
amputation of the penis and even in rare
instances death why would any parent if
fully informed put their child at risk
from these events if circumcision were a
baby product a swing a cradle a toy the
consumer product safety commission would
prohibit its
sale please stop please start wrapping
up ma'am sorry please start wrapping up
your testimony the circumcision
transparency act will ensure that
parents are fully informed before a
doctor takes a knife to the baby's
genitals the ACT will stop healthc Care
Professionals from aggressively
soliciting parents to say yes to
circumcision finally the ACT will ensure
that parents not be automatically
compelled to consent to donate in quotes
their son's foreskin to pharmaceutical
and cosmetic manufacturers who pay
hospitals handsomely for the same tissue
that parents have been told is useless
and unimportant if not pathological a
child's body belongs to himself a penis
with its forkin intact is as easy to
clean as a finger or toe the forkin
keeps pathogens from entering the
urinary tract during babyhood protects
the head of his penis from chafing
drying out and losing sensitivity over
time and ensures that when the child
reaches adulthood he and his partner
will experience sex the way nature
intended I urge you to approve and
submit this bill to the New Hampshire
House of Representatives thank you for
your time and attention thank you any
questions
I'm seeing none thank
you well representative kosman I'm sorry
she does you Mr chairman it's just a
point of clarity um you did say that
you're acting you're here on behalf of
the organization so is that that's at a
as a private person as the executive
director not as an attorney representing
the organization no as as the executive
director I am an attorney but I am here
representing intact America for which I
am the CEO thank you thank you thank
you
also signed up to speak is Matthew
Goodwin uh and again uh you have three
minutes
sir my name is Matthew Goodwin I'm here
today to speak as the primary author on
a pending publication that broadly
assess the quality of circumcision
consent forms issued by Major Hospital
syst systems in New England of which new
H New Hampshire is included our current
data set which encompasses information
collected from more than 40 hospitals
represents the largest assembly of
consent forms related to
circumcision ever
compiled these forms were reviewed for
their
content the findings are deeply
concerning we observe a striking
variation from hospital to hospital
about what risks are being disclosed on
these forms while some forms list more
than 10 risks associated with
circumcision others only list three to
four some forms do not list any risks at
all but simply State my doctor has
explained all the risks to me leaving us
to wonder what was actually
stated is it right that some parents
know only of a few risks While others
know many
more is it fair that some parents see
this in writing While others only hear
it I would also argue a consent form
that lists death as a distinct
possibility is very different for one
that does
not most concerning is the observation
that some hospitals include terms and
conditions on their forms to enable
harvesting of the amputated forkin
tissue for research and or commercial
use there is no means to op out of this
as it is a term of the procedure
itself does a hospital that receives
financial compensation by selling
neonatal foreskin tissue represent a
conflict of
interest shouldn't parents have the
option to decline participation in
tissue
donation overall the data from this
study clearly shows that parents are not
getting the information they need from
their hospital to make a truly informed
decision and it calls for immediate
corrective
action this bill would strengthen
parental rights to informed consent by
providing them with the necessary
information and safeguards so that they
can make a reasonable thoughtful
decision this bill would also serve to
protect hospitals doctors and nurses by
reducing legal liabilities related to
improper informed consent
lawsuits with the uh suggested
improvements propos osed in the bill
there is less ambiguity about what
information is being presented and who
has agreed to the
procedure based on the large discrepancy
and risk documented and presented to
parents we anticipate the standard of
care being questioned at some of these
hospitals New Hampshire hospitals can
Shield themselves from the scrutiny by
elevating the current practices to a
higher level of care most importantly
this bill gives many more children the
opportunity to make a decision about
their own body by slowing the decision
process one that does not need to be
rushed and determined at Birth thank you
for your time thank you any
questions I'm seeing not representative
Lon uh thank you if that paper is
published or if you have a pre-draft
publication that you can share with the
committee um that would be greatly
appreciated I will see if I could do
that yes thank you other
questions representative kushman
thank you um thank you Mr chairman
um so I'm looking at the um American
medical association's ethical guidelines
and uh part of it under patient rights
says that uh the doctors shall advise
their patients of any conflicts of
interest that they may have in respect
to care um would you say that they are
not upholding that part of their um
ethical code if they're not informing
patients that the hospital is getting
money from the harvesting of forkins
yeah they are not revealing their
conflict of
interest other
questions seeing none thank
you also signed up to speak and again
it's a tough one Anthony Los quers
Quadro Los Quadro okay Health equality
campaign uh and again welcome sir you've
indicated five to six minutes again I'll
have to ask you to keep it close to
three just want to give you some
documents that'll you can refer to as
I'm
speaking I'll try to keep my comments
brief because a lot of it is I Don't
Want To Tread over old territory already
but uh my name is Anthony L Squad I'm
the director of the health equality
campaign
uh I represent the growing chorus Across
America that advocate for higher
standards for bodily autonomy of
children specifically when it comes to
routine infant circumcision which I call
uh cosmetic but specifically I just cut
down to
um the uh the consent
bill uh HB 1706 is an important bill
that's needed to reform the informed
consent process because routine infant
circumcision needs to be held to a
higher standard since it's a proxy
decision that's not medically necessary
it's a decision that's essentially
forced on another person with potential
lifelong consequences to his physical
being his future sexuality his
psychology and one that violates his
body autonomy or right to choose for
himself hospitals often use inadequate
consent forms typically generic
fill-in-the blank forms that rely on an
oral discussion between the parents and
whomever health care worker is on duty
at the time in maternity the discussions
are often brief and they can be biased
based on the provider's uh Viewpoint new
parents also have a lot of
misconceptions about what circumcision
is if it's necessary and how it's done
I've attached several consent forms used
for circum incision from New Hampshire
hospitals that we obtained some
hospitals refuse to disclose their
consent forms like the birth center at
Dartmouth even to expecting parents
citing Hospital
policy why don't they want people to
know what their consent forms say in
advance since the decision to circumcise
is a proxy decision we need to hold the
consent form to a higher standard than
general surgery based on our research in
conversations with parents a
circumcision decision is usually rushed
and the mother is in a vulnerable
condition after birth and maybe under
the influence of
anesthesia now for instance when an
adult undergoes general surgery it
typically involves multiple doctor
visits testing diagnosing discussions on
the issue maybe second opinions and the
patient has time to research and make
the best decision for himself so it's a
very different scenario between routine
infant circumcision and adult general
surgery so why don't we have different
consent forms now I know doctors really
care about their patients and they want
the best outcome for them 1706 will help
doctors provide better care for their
patients by giving parents the
information they need it will reinforce
the doctor patient relationship because
parents will appreciate getting more
information to help them to make this
decision that likely never came up
before it'll help avoid regret parents
and it'll help avoid disgruntled young
men who feel their autonomy was violated
with very few options after the fact
please start wrapping up
sure uh in my uh handout uh on page
three it highlights a real life case in
Florida where aom Heather heronimus who
in a dispute with the father of her
child was placed in jail over her
refusal to sign a circumcision consent
form she ultimately signed the consent
form in court in handcuffs in tears and
if she didn't she would have been
remanded back to jail by the
judge um I'm just going to skip over
some parts also on the issue of tissue
forkin donation many Hospital consent
forms based on our research and Exhibits
require tissue donation there are
for-profit public companies that
essentially purchased this tissue from
hospitals for use in cosmetic and
biotech products in fact there's one in
Massachusetts called organogenesis that
has contracts with area hospitals just
to do that I know because I did the
research and I wrote an article on it
and I based My article based on uh
internal company documents it's a big
business and they even sell it on Amazon
if you look up human neonatal forkin
fiberblast it's
$427 51 with prime shipping please wrap
up tissue donation opt out should be the
default you all
set are there are there any
questions my representative mlan thank
you Mr chair and thank you for taking my
question I'm a little bit concerned by
one of the comments that you made that
that Dartmouth would not release their
consent forms in advance um was that a
communication that you had with them is
that hearsay um and do you know the
reasoning behind that um I called that's
that is concerning yes sir I called
Dartmouth hospital myself the birth
center and I said uh can I get a
circumcision consent form and the nurse
checked with her supervisor ER her name
was Judy and she refused to release the
form to
me follow and was any reason cited
Hospital
policy other questions representative
Nagel this is just a pragmatic question
how many handouts did you have so I only
got one uh one hand out three pages okay
all right thank
you other
questions I'm seeing none okay thank you
sir thank you
okay in addition to those who had signed
up and completed pink cards uh five
people assigned the blue sheet
indicating they were in favor of this
bill and two signed the blue sheet
indicating they were opposed to this
bill I have no other one no one else
signed up to testify on HB 1706 so I am
going to close the public hearing on
this bill and uh before I go on to the
next hearing u a couple of of
announcements one um 16 69 uh we haven't
U detected a lot of interest in that uh
not too many people have signed up to
testify Prime sponsors indicated there
is requested that be moved to this
afternoon which it will be anyway at
this point but more like 3:00
representative did you want to comment
um 3 o'clock would be perfect that way
we can continue with this and maybe have
a chance for lunch before we get in at
one any objections to moving it um okay
and as far as lunch is concerned
committee members will we will do what
we did last week in the interests of
time obviously we have some really
important bills with a lot of public uh
interest and we want to make maximum
time for that so take lunch at your
leisure uh we'll we'll continue to go
throughout the day so we don't have to
keep staff uh into the evening and uh
it'll be more convenient for those wish
to testify as as well as uh for the
staff and everyone else uh any questions
or comments before we proceed okay
all right uh with with that I will open
the public hearing on HB
1683 okay uh the prime sponsor is
approaching with her pink card she knows
the rules and the and the and the and
the ropes representative
Phillips thank you again I'm going to be
super quick because we're going to move
along get back on schedule um this bill
uh moves infant circumcision from a
covered Medicaid expense in New
Hampshire this law has passed in
similarity in 17 States I'm going to
pass around a bunch of information
specifically on the cost reductions and
some other testimony um provided to me
um the cost reductions to the state is
estimated at $90,000 if we no longer
covered it I would estimate it's a lot
larger than that based on that is just
for the billing codes it does not
include the facility charge uh provider
charges supplies that sort of thing in
addition there's about a 10% revision
rate reported so I got the billing codes
for that for children in New Hampshire
over the past five years and it's
$177,000 in billing codes just to repair
circumcisions for New Hampshire the past
five
years that's it any questions any
questions representative
Parmer so I in that last part so so
let's say somebody has a circum their
child is circumcised they went through
the whole thing they really read up
about it they knew exactly what they're
doing that's what they wanted to do they
have Medicaid they paid for it out of
pocket to have the circumcision now they
have a complication are they not going
to be able to get medical coverage for
repair no I suggest we do cover it
because that is an injury what I suggest
is that it would be reduced there
wouldn't be follow-up care if we stop
covering or encourage them to not happen
through coverage so that's what I trying
to paint yes yes please help the
children yes oh yeah representative
kushman thank you Mr chairman um you
mentioned um some of the fiscal note
analysis on how much this will reduce
costs um but are you aware of how um
taking away a benefit um being covered
by Medicaid um affects the market cost
across the board of of a procedure or
intervention yes um thank you so if you
reduce the demand on something um you
know the price the market price is going
to come down I believe in other states
um when people pay a cash price for this
procedure it's very simple as the um my
representative friend said they kind of
go Corral all the male babies and they
line them up and they do it all at the
same time so it's actually relatively
inexpensive um when Medicaid is not
paying for it driving the costs up
because there's so much demand thank you
thank you other
questions representative Shapiro
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking the question so just to be clear
I think I am clear but just to be clear
uh a a lowincome Jewish or Muslim family
that has a child and chooses to have a
circumcision that's kind of dictated by
religious observance but choose to have
it in a medical facility
because maybe because of some of the
risks that you've been talking about um
so a medical facility would allow for
more hygiene um more medical backup um
so those Services currently are covered
by Medicaid but they will not be if this
bill passes correct in a medical
facility I don't see it as a benefit to
poor children I think that we're saving
them by doing this because thank you
okay other
questions see none thank
you
also signed up to speak is
representative
santonastaso again you have three
minutes
sir thank you uh thanks again to the
committee uh representative s naso
representing ringe Jaffrey and Dublin
this bill stops the coverage of the
Cosmetic circumcision for infants under
the State Medicaid plan uh infant uh
circumcision is a serious humans rights
violation uh a German Court held um any
benefit to circumcision can be obtained
by delaying the procedure until the male
is old enough to give his own fully
informed consent with the option of
delaying circumcision providing all the
purported benefits circumcising an
infant is an unnecessarily unnecessary
violation of his bodily Integrity as
well as ethically invalid form of
medical violence parental proxy consent
for newborn circumcision is invalid male
circumcision also violates four uh core
human right documents the universal
Declaration of Human Rights the
convention on the rights of the child
the international Convent on civil and
political rights and the convention
Against torture uh once circumcision
rates fall below a critical value the
social norms that currently distort our
perception of the practice will dissolve
and rates will fall so the growing
awareness in the United States about the
brutal nature of the circumcision is
becoming more prant when
circumcision uh will be legally
recognized as inhumane the state will be
exposed to considerable Financial
liabilities uh this will necessitate
compensating individuals who underwent
the procedure funded by Medicaid or even
uh something like a mass Tor lawsuit uh
basically uh we're going to be looking
at a tsunami of lawsuits in the future
um if the state continues to fund this
so uh and given the profound widespread
impact of circum decision on individuals
the ramifications of such a
re-evaluation are substantial and
far-reaching um so any questions from
the committee are there any
questions I'm seeing none thank you
thank
you also signed up to speak as robod
Barry from the Department of Health and
Human
Services good morning again members of
the committee um Mr chair uh for the
record my name is uh Rob Barry I'm the
general counsel to the division of
Medicaid um we are again here to provide
information uh we are not taking a
position on the bill this bill would
alter current practice in terms of what
covered services are offered under the
Medicaid Program and it would also
require uh the department to engage in
Prior authorizations for any
circumcision procedure which we don't
currently do uh the only suggestion we
have for the bill is
in the medically necessary
criteria on page one beginning on line
13 uh through lines
27 um it's a very prescriptive um number
of um conditions that would qualify for
this we would suggest having a little
bit more flexibility that if there are
no conditions covered there uh that we
would have the ability to cover
circumcisions under um other medically
necessary circumstances and I'm happy to
take any questions at this
point Thank you any
questions representative kushman thank
you Mr chairman this is just my attorney
clarification question um so you here
acting on behalf of the public I'm here
acting on behalf of the division of
Medicaid for the Department of Health
and Human Services as your client yes
thank
you other question
questions I'm seeing none thank you
representative Leon um thank you um
since you had that potential
clarification of the medically necessary
conditions if you could send an email
with what specifically you would um what
specifically you're stating around those
requirements that would be helpful sure
thank you thank
you representative Weber could I just
ask you for
clarification um I believe the the
question about whether you were acting
as an attorney and I am I correct in
understanding that it is not the
practice of law when you are
representing when you are an employe who
is
representing the general
position of an
employer now you're getting into
professional responsibility uh
representative Weber um my view of it
has always been that I'm here in my
capacity as a representative of the
department I am an attorney uh I try to
abide by my professional responsibility
obligations while I'm doing so um so I
view myself as having a high standard of
cander to this committee and I do think
I forgot to introduce myself in the
previous hearing so I do apologize for
that um but um yes I am here as a
representative of the department and I
am an
attorney but but if I may be to Dead
Horse you are not here specifically or
offering legal advice to us that's
correct representative
Weber other
questions okay thank
you also signed up to speak is Paige
bman from national award
4 I'm sorry oh I'm
sorry good morning thank you good
morning it no no good afternoon um thank
you again for those of you who are left
um I this may be a little bit surprising
I am in the previous hearing very very
strongly in favor of additional
education and consent I think it's very
important for all the reasons we've
already
heard on the flip side I am here to
speak against the Medicaid bill and the
reason is I don't think we're ready for
it yet right now
nationally uh circumcision has moved
from a few decades ago being about 85%
of Americans C of boys were circumcised
that has shifted in the last decade or
so to about 50% but that is regional um
certain States tend more towards 10 to
20% here in New Hampshire
76% of people currently circumcise their
sons I'm coming at this from a a Health
Equity and socioeconomic status
perspective as well as mental health
this bill which would impact something
that is a deeply held belief for people
right now for all the reasons we've said
because there's not enough education
right now it is a cultural norm and what
we will be doing is this will
disproportionately affect people who are
lower income and of course people of
color it then becomes a phys physical
permanent marker of
poverty will that change yes am I in
support of people staying intact yes but
is that the case now no and so I see
this as a as many of the things in
health that have become markers of
socioeconomic status previously the
biggest example I can think of is
Formula feeding versus breastfeeding
where how you fed your baby was a marker
of your income I see the potential for
that happen happening and as such it has
the potential to have a significant
impact on the mental health of parents
of which I am an expert the
conversations that people have in their
first few days postpartum stay with
women for ever they remember these
conversations and if we passed this and
I had to do this and I had to have this
conversation next week with people I
have to go into somebody's room
currently we're not opt out I have to
ask them required or my job I have to
ask them so when I go in and say are you
planning on a
circumcision I don't know who has
Medicaid yet so that adds work but the
point is I go in and they say I want a
circumcision I am the person that has to
essentially say to them you don't get
one because you're poor and for people
that still believe because of the lack
of Education that this is something that
is best for their baby on day one
there's the potential for them to
already feel like a failure as a parent
and unable to provide what they see as
something very important for their
sons again I am hoping that we can
provide the education do I think that
this might be the right move in two
years three years five years if we can
shift our culture and we can bring that
percentage down wrapping up yeah if we
can bring that percentage down I think
this bill makes a lot of sense fiscally
right now I have concerns about mental
health and about our marginalized
communities thank you very much for
hearing me and again I'm Paige bman
representative uh from Nash award 4
thank you any questions uh yes sorry um
thank you Mr chairman and thank you
representative to for coming up again
today um I believe that our Medicaid
births are about half of births in the
state of New Hampshire do you have data
on what percentage of Medica of children
Bor boys born with Medicaid are
circumcised because I think that would
be very interesting to know because with
that 75% rate if if it's almost 100% in
the Medicaid population yet it's 5050 in
the non-medicaid population perhaps this
actually might be reversed about an
equity issue what do you think about
that you actually need you to repeat the
question I'm a little confused I'm sorry
um so I guess first question question do
you have data on what the uh what the
rate is in the Medicaid population I I
would guess it exists but I don't have
it I just have the total population
percentage okay and then uh secondly uh
my question would be that if it's either
already evenly distributed or if there's
a higher rate of circumcision in the
Medicaid population do you think that
maybe this issue is different than
you're first perceiving
it if it's 100% of the Medicaid
population I if I'm understanding
correctly would feel more strongly in
this way because then this that shows
that the people who are in that
population see this as something that is
very important and
essential one more follow one more
followup um thank you I'm just trying to
square that with your testimony before
about making sure that we're providing
adequate education and that we're having
informed consent so I'm I'm getting
having a hard trouble on comparing I
absolutely understand that my my main
point here is that we're not ready for
it right now I think right now step one
is to provide education and to shift the
cultural
norms and so I am I I would advocate for
this but when
when when we have made that shift when
it doesn't have such a social and
emotional impact on
people which I think we can get to but
not right now representative kushman
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question um just to kind of
leap off of where um my colleague um
just left us is it possible that if it's
disincentivized um by being reimbursable
under
Medicaid um because in other states
where where Medicaid covers circumcision
the overall rates of the procedure are
twice as high as states where Medicaid
doesn't cover it so um is it possible
that um that if that is removed that
incentive is no longer there that it it
that the culture will follow and maybe
that that's one of the reasons why the
rates are higher
here if I may clarify you're you're
asking um your your assumption is that
doctors or clinicians are incentivized
to offer circumcision
is that what you're saying they
essentially are if it's a reimbursable
event under Medicaid so there is a
reason that the hospital policy would be
to counsel every
parent um on circumcision and recommend
it versus letting it be just an elective
thing that is only discussed if it's
brought up by the patient I I have
experience in three different hospitals
and a birth center facility and that's
this is
anecdotal I I'm almost uh you know
trying to stay non- emotional I I'm
almost offended at the presumption that
people who have gone into a clinical
field to take care of people are are
pushing procedures on people to make
money I have never experienced that with
the people I work with it's not the
attitude I have ever heard other people
being exposed to I know there are cases
where people have seen that happen I
have not experienced that I don't
personally believe in practice that that
is why we ask people for the same
reasons that I am not in favor of this
bill I would not be in favor of an optin
versus an opt
out just right now because people expect
it they wait for us to come in and ask
them they're not going to ask us even
if even if they want it they are going
to wait for us to offer it to them so I
um I've lost track of where we were with
that um but no I do not think it's
incentivized and when you give me that
statistic and say Well when it's not
covered there are half the circumcisions
doesn't that make sense because half of
them are not being paid for so of course
there would be fewer because fewer
people have the fewer people have the
option to choose that that's one way to
look at it yeah I I'm I'm talking about
being able to choose what's right for
your children and the way to do that is
by educating people we educate people to
make the informed consent for themselves
instead of forcing them into something
because they're poor if we are not going
to make this if we are not going to ban
this outright for everybody we have no
place to be putting this on poor people
and as a person that comes from poverty
I can tell you that this would be
painful and it is not okay to do this to
people other questions to penalize them
for being poor other any other
questions thank you
representative thank
you also signed up to speak is Peter S
s good afternoon yeah good
afternoon good afternoon good afternoon
okay good
afternoon uh and thank you uh Mr
chairman and committee members for this
opportunity to speak to you in support
of HB
1683 although I'd like to suggest a
small
amendment I can certainly understand
that you are attempting to ensure that
the money that the state of New
Hampshire as investing in the state
Medicare Plan is used for appropriate
purposes however reading this bill I
noticed one area that was not included
in coverage this is when a documented
family history indicates that a serious
health condition will likely arise
unless a circumcision is performed
previously for my family and me this was
not just a theoretical but in fact
resulted in severe Health emergencies
for my family
members within my immediate family I
know for certain of five males who
required emergency cir circumcisions in
their lives as early as a teen and as
late as in their
50s all of them hoped that they would
not encounter this medical condition
known as fosis which is a condition
where the foreskin cannot be pulled back
from the head of the penis but when the
pain was too severe or when
circumstances forced the issue they all
had to undergo adult circumcisions in
situations that were not optimal for
health care and certainly were not were
much more costly than the cost of
circumcision of a
newborn if you are wondering why this
type of condition has not been mentioned
much in public I would suggest that this
is because men are not willing to share
this kind of story with others and will
often suffer in silence hoping that the
condition will resolve itself it usually
does not and that is why I I'm asking
you to consider an amendment in the list
of allowable conditions for the
circumcision in your I think was
paragraph three adding a a new section k
for documented family history that
suggests a high likelihood that a
serious health condition will arise in
the future looking at the bill before
you I ask you to consider how much pain
and suffering can be mitigated when
newborns with a family history of fosis
are provided with this covered
circumcision but covering adults who who
um who um have fosis will need who need
this operation later in life will almost
certainly save money for the state as
well allow me to tell you a little bit
about my family's relevant experiences
my father like me was born in Hungary
and during World War II he was a drafted
into the Hungarian Army and served as an
officer for 2 years he was only 22 years
old when during his military deployment
he encountered such severe pain due to
fosis that he asked to be circumcised in
a military hospital this was very
dangerous at the time because
circumcised men if captured by German
Allied Forces would be suspected of
being Jewish and could be sent to
concentration
camps um
he realized the danger but had the
operation performed nonetheless my son
had a very similar encounter he was
attending his second year at West Point
when he too found himself suffering from
fosis and decided to have a circumcision
in a hospital near West Point my brother
was only in his teens when he too
experienced severe pain and required his
circumcision one of my brother's sons
had the same experience when he was in
his 20s
finally when I was in my 50s it was my
turn at that time in my life I thought
that I had beaten the odds but my luck
had just run out I started to suffer
increasing increasingly uh um increasing
pain due to fosis which included tears
in my foreskin as well as bleeding be
could please stop wrapping up yes having
intimate relations with my wife kept uh
kept getting more and more painful fin I
too had to have a
circumcision all five of us recovered
quickly and had no further health
problems after the operation uh and
either from the operation or
subsequently so thank you Mr chairman
and I'm willing to answer any questions
if they they are asked I also have a
handout I can give to everyone okay yeah
if you can pass that around and
representative Shapiro has a question
thank you Mr chairman um other than your
very compelling personal story about
this have you done any Research into
whether um the occurrence of fosis fosis
which i' never heard before to be
perfectly honest do you have you done
any research to see if there is a
genetic um component to that if there is
if it is if it is frequently like
evidently in your family is if is there
if it's frequently involves a family
history um I I can't say that I have a
very extensive research on that uh
obviously in my family it was pretty
obvious and uh I have found many sources
that impl impl implicate the the idea
that this does carry through the family
in the male component uh and I've had
conversations with a number of doctors
about this uh for example the the doctor
that performed my circumcision he too
said that it is known that this is a
this can be a family thing that is
passed down from one to another and um
so I I do think that this is this is one
of those conditions that I think
sometimes gets neglected because more
often we we hear about this as a
religious issue uh my father was
Catholic and not Jewish so it was not a
religious issue for him or a cosmetic
issue and uh but when it gets to a point
when you can't bear it anymore as an
adult it's a much more serious operation
than as a as a newborn so that's why I'm
asking you incidentally in this bill it
does mention fimosis after puberty as a
condition that's covered and I would
suggest that if there was a real family
history this happening we shouldn't be
waiting that long thank you for your
testimony uh representative fedus yes
thank you Mr chair um and thank you for
taking this my question is um the
Factor about Medicaid you don't object
in any way the Medicaid would reject
this here we're asking to not
include so is Medicaid a factor in your
testimony this
morning my my my suggestion for my
amendment is that under the uh areas
that are covered under the state
Medicare Pro program that family history
demonstrated fam documented family
history should be included okay followup
follow um I understood that part my just
basic question is do you object to the
Medicaid being included or circumcision
being included in Medicaid it sounds
like they want to not have that covered
by Medicaid and I don't think that
should be the case well I think if I
understand your in the question
direction of your question is whether I
think that should be covered by Medicaid
or not and it seems to me uh that in my
situation if I was a recipient of
Medicaid and I had a demonstrated uh uh
history family history of this happening
I think it should be covered because
it's almost like uh well I'm pretty sure
I'm going to get it at some point and
this is a much more cost effective and
it it avoids many painful years later
on Mr chair Al set thank you that was
the answer I was looking for thank you
glad to do it thank you thank you any
other questions I'm seeing none thank
you very much thank
you also signed up to speak is
representative Ellen
Reed thank you again Mr chair and
honorable members um once again my name
is Ellen Reed representing Rockingham 10
new market and new fields and I am happy
to see my former colleague The Honorable
uh Peter somuch in the room who is in
favor of the underlying bill with the
amendment that I would also agree to to
um exempt or allow for Medicaid coverage
of people with a a family history um the
reason I am a co-sponsor on this bill is
because I believe in the separation of
church and state and to the extent that
this is predominantly a religious and
cultural and not a medical uh procedure
when it's done automatically um it
really has NOS business being paid for
by by the taxpayers there's no other no
other I I kind of challenge anybody to
find another strictly cultural
non-medically necessary procedure that
we cover with with public taxpayer money
I don't think that we do in fact there
are many medically necessary things that
we don't cover with taxpayer money so
again to the extent that it is not
medically necessary the only issue
there's been talk about well infections
or whatever and this of course is except
for all the exemptions in the bill and
the one that The Honorable samsic has
has mentioned um the only studies that
have given kind of mixed results was the
potential for the prevention of future
STI and as was previously testified to
those predominantly fell on what the
hygiene of that culture was in general
but um not only has every physician
organization in the western world or I
say actually the almost the entire world
including our own say that automatic
circumcision is not medically necessary
I just want to read from NIH which is of
course our federal National Institutes
of Health um this is from their sexually
transmitted infections and male
circumcision a systematic review and the
quote is consequently the prevention of
sexually transmitted infections cannot
rationally be interpreted as a benefit
of
circumcision there you go so it's not
medically necessary I do want to address
comments that were made earlier by my
friend who's the new uh member in the
house uh about um The Mark of poverty I
myself grew up in South Memphis we were
always on public assistance um we I
lived in a condemned house for a long
time without plumbing and heat so I
understand when she talks about marks of
poverty I take that really really
seriously and it did actually I
considered that deeply when we were
talking about that before this hearing
um however that same representative
testified on the previous bill that she
herself has left her three sons intact
so one can now say why if this is such a
terrible Mark of poverty that gives
long-term psychological problems in our
society because it's such a cultural
norm why then did you Mark or rather not
Mark uh your own Sons with that Mark of
poverty so in terms of Mark of poverty
and and is this really a problem 17
States already prohibit Medicaid funds
from being being used for circumcision
medically non-necessary
circumcision rather than it hurting poor
children I would say that and I
understand that as a nurse or as
somebody having to tell a person that
this isn't covered by Medicaid that that
might be difficult and uncomfortable but
the question is what is right so rather
than saving poor rather than hurting
poor children or marking them with
poverty I think it's saving poor kids
from being hurt for no good reason and
please St wrapping up I am thank you and
the $200,000 that we spend on
circumcision and then the revisions from
bot circumcision in this state from by
Medicaid I think that that F those funds
could better be used to help poor
children by providing pediatric eye care
or dental care I think that better
serves lowincome families and uh
marginalized communities and finally
back to the medical necessity again one
in 16,000 people who are intact men who
are intact fact uh experience a later
need for adult circumcision that is far
fewer than what Boston Children's
Hospital says is the rate of
complication of circumcision which is
3% three out of 100 one out of
33 so anyway with that I will end my
testimony Mr chair thank you any
questions representative kushman thank
you Mr chairman representative read
sorry I'm so used to getting off the
hook
representative um I I'll give you an
easy one um are you aware of so just let
me know if you follow here that if we
take away the funding then um we've seen
like in other states there will probably
be a decrease demand um and are you
aware of what happens to the prices in
the private Market of of things when the
demand decreases so this is a kind of
common pra uh common problem rather not
just in medicine with Medicaid but also
in education uh where if you if you do
nothing else to control the market
forces which I would say we should fund
these things not circumcision but fund
Healthcare in general and fund education
but that then you have to put
restrictions in exchange for the public
funds and the public trust being given
towards that you have to put
restrictions on what those private
forces will do because what they will do
is Rin seeking behavior and they will up
the price if it's being paid for by the
government they're going to take as much
government money as they want so when
you re unfortunately when you remove
those that the benefit of removing the
funding is that the price comes down I
would like to see everybody have medical
care but automatic circumcisions is not
medical care so
that so that could potentially be a
benefit for those people maybe who don't
qualify for Medicaid or even the people
who do qualify for Medicaid but they're
having trouble maybe affording that that
the price will come down it'll be
probably more easily accessible for I I
do believe that eventually the market
forces would come down if this wasn't
being covered by med Medicaid so that it
would be more accessible I can't say it
would be accessible to everybody but I
don't know that I want automatic maming
of babies to be
accessible other questions okay s on
thank
you also signed up to speak is
representative Kelly
Penza I don't know if I can follow up
that so I'm just here in strong support
of the bill um for a multitude of
reasons but I think we have to be clear
not medically necessary elective
procedure so that's why would we all be
forced to pay for something and if
there's
education if someone still wants it
after being provide the informed consent
and the necessary education that's
needed then fi I I think finding the
funding or finding the funds to do so
won't be very difficult so that's pretty
much all I have to say it's elective not
medically
necessary so we shouldn't have it
shouldn't be paid for it it just like
anything else that you're you're going
to decide to do that is um not you know
plastic surgery anything like that those
are things that have to come out of your
own pocket unless and there's lots of
exceptions in here which I think the
might be some other ones um that are
added in here that are amended in here
um and from what the previous speaker
talked about too
um the gentleman uh I think that I think
that it's pretty clear that this bill U
makes sense uh 17 States is another
thing too um we can look at all of that
that's been
implemented uh and yeah education is key
people need to be that needs to be
informed to consent in education and
it's just just really important that I
think um we move forward with these
thank you any
questions saying on thank
you also signed up to speak are Andrew
Sheffer and Zoe
Fowler um I can give you each three
minutes you've asked for 10 to 1550 and
I can't do that that's understandable
sir three minutes a piece oh we're up to
three minutes a
piece so again I would like to apologize
in case there's any new faces here I do
have a bit of a stutter and a twitch
it's something I've had for a long time
might take me a couple seconds longer
than three minutes do my best to keep
concise um so I'm here I'm sorry
representative
Weber you got put little could you just
speak a little closer into your
microphone because as you can see it it
really does change the volume and it it
helps not only for us here in the room
but for anybody who's following along at
home of so thank you of course um so
again I would like to apologize I have a
stutter uh boiler play
disclaimer um so one of the reasons I'm
here to support uh House Bill uh
1683 is because again like with
the the giving education I I feel this
is another side of of a coin here
providing education
and you know not using public resources
that should be going towards treating
sick people that should be going going
towards you know people who have you
know medical emergencies we're wasting
resources on circumcising people when
most of the time unless for the you know
for certain medical issues if if they
have a medical reason understandable
that's completely you know that that's
reasonable but otherwise I don't feel
it's appropriate to be spending American
taxpayers
dollars um on a unnecessary and very
damaging uh
procedure I also feel
that I
apologize I also I also feel sorry I
also feel that having Medicaid as a as a
method of obtaining a circumcision
encourages people I feel I'm someone who
lives in poverty right now I've heard
that it's a mark of poverty I'm not
making much money right now I'm on
disability and I still have no desire or
anything
to to go get circumcised I feel that
objectively it is a harmful medical
procedure that is a drain on our
resources
um and I I apologize my stutter is kind
of of acting up right now so I'm going
to um resign myself at this point unless
you have any questions for me sure does
the other gentleman wish to speak
or the idea that uh State medical
insurance should pay for circumcision to
me would seem uh at best fanciful
because any benefit to the procedure
could just as easily be rendered as an
adult as it could as a baby it is not a
mark of poverty to have a forkin any
more than it is a mark of poverty to
have any health condition that is later
fixed we do not perform open heart
surgery on babies even if we uh or
rather we do only in the instance that
we can prove beyond a shadow of a doubt
that they cannot
wait okay thank you are there any
questions from committee
members I'm seeing none thank you very
much all right thank you so much thank
you you all have a good night good good
day also signed up to speak is Shane
Brewster hello thank you again I'm Shane
Brewster um I will keep this short as to
not completely be a dead horse um I
would like to speak in favor of this
bill um for everything that has been
said prior and more um I would like this
bill to be passed to help reduce adverse
outcomes of unnecessary circumcisions
ideally in doing so reserving funds for
medically necessitated
procedures that is really all I
have thank you any
questions thank you sir thank you very
much also signed up to speak is Anthony
Ladro from Health equality from the
health equality campaign
and you again you indicated six minutes
please keep it to three yes sir I just
have some handouts that are pertinent to
my my discussion sure approach I won't I
won't count that time against
you
TR
okay on HB 1683 I ask for your support
on this bill because we should not use
public resources to encourage medically
unnecessary surgery that also violates a
child's bodily autonomy we shouldn't
give Health Care Systems Financial
incentives that can lead them to
pressure parents for a needless surgery
just being born male is not a
diagnosis I'm also concerned with the
surge of Latino immigration because
foreign born Latinos are almost
universally intact and their cultural
practices may come under pressure to do
things the American
way and they may be coerced to
circumcise the children which may be
presented to them is a free service and
when I hear you know talk about that
circumcision or being intact is is a
stigma or Mark of poverty well Latinos
not that they're in poverty but but uh
immigrants are almost universally intact
and they don't seem to have a problem
with it so why do we have a problem with
it someone brought up what if there's a
history of family fimosis I've never
read anything in the medical literature
about familial fosis or being used to
justify circumcision of birth to preempt
an adult condition fimosis can be caused
by improper care as a baby such as by
force retraction which we've heard about
and there are minimally invasive
treatments such which as steroid creams
that can address this if it's diagnosed
as an adult when I reviewed the fiscal
note I noticed it did not take into
account the cost of circumcision
complications or the additional savings
that would be realized if this bill
passes referencing a study I supplied to
you on page three the complication rate
for circumcision was placed at
11% okay so these complications will
require the services of pediatric
urologist surgeon in a hospital setting
which is very ly so the fiscal note and
per my exhibit page four should really
include these course savings passed on
all this pain suffering and Trauma being
inflicted on babies and taxpayers for no
reason why would we want to do
this public fund should be used should
not be used to promote violating bodily
autonomy the public sector should set
the standard for placing autonomy
first I I think we should all live up to
the motto of New Hampshire to live free
let's have the next generation of
children live free as natural normal and
healthy intact people because that's
what they are they're people I urge you
to think about the future and how we
treat our
children any questions thank you uh yeah
any
questions I'm seeing onone thank you
sir also signed up to speak is Dr
param welcome back thank you very much
and I only ask for a minute I wanted to
basically say that I was very confused
by previous testimony on how uh it's
going to be so difficult to explain to
poor people what's happening to them um
I represent for 3% of doctors look like
me black and female and consequently
when you talk about poverty I want you
to also think about bipac issues here
because there's a whole issue of how
unfair our medical system is for all of
us and it's across the class ladder so
right now I would like no coverage not
from the Republican fiscal
responsibility end but from the
complications and the fact that when the
mom goes back maybe she won't have
people listen to her because she's poor
because that is a piece of this and then
the last thing I wanted to say was there
are incentives for doctors to do things
I lived with them all the time so I
understand some people didn't feel that
but under Managed Care yes there are
incentives to do things that may not be
uh exactly 100% of what you want to do
morally thank you thank you any
questions thank
you also signed up to speak is David
Atkinson
and again you you asked for four minutes
please keep it to
three good
morning I also was puzzled by the
earlier testimony uh about poverty uh
because I have spent the the past 10
years uh spreading foreskin awareness
around the US and speaking with people
on the street in many different
neighborhoods rich people and poor
people and
for people are intelligent and they
understand the structure and function of
the human foreskin and they understand
human
rights I will now read my prepared
statement should be your choice how much
of your genitals you get to
keep the question before us now is
whether New Hampshire Medicaid dollars
should be used to fund human rights
violations last time New Hampshire
considered this issue in 2015 opponents
argued the passage of such a bill would
result in fewer services to low-income
residents providing services to low in
Residence is certainly a worthy goal
therefore let me be clear getting part
of your penis cut off without your
consent is not a service it is an act of
theft and violence despite the good
intentions of the people who carry out
this act the newborn child experiences
trauma and betrayal when he only wants
to bond peacefully with his
mother it makes no difference whether
the person who cut my penis intended to
hurt or to help the result is the same
part of my penis is gone forever
also parenthetically I heard people
talking about pain and I would say that
even if foreskin amputation could be
accomplished without torturing the child
it would still be a human rights
violation the children of Medicaid
recipients like all children deserve the
opportunity to reach adulthood with
intact genitals the best way to serve
them is to leave their genitals alone to
develop
normally we also heard uh briefly about
the American Academy of Pediatrics whose
2012 statement expired in
2017 more recently in December 2022 the
AAP published a patient education
document regarding care of the intact
penis which includes the text quote at
Birth the forkin is is attached to the
head of the penis until the forkin fully
separates it shouldn't be pulled back
forcing the force skin to retract before
it is ready can cause severe pain
bleeding and tears in the skin end quote
since premature forcible forkin
retraction such as that is the first
step of neonatal foreskin amputation it
seems clear that the a has quietly
retreated from prior support of this
practice the state should not condone
let alone reimburse an activity that
harms children particularly low-income
children and that is contrary to Modern
medical evidence and advice passage of
this bill HB
1683 will curtail wasteful government
spending prevent numerous human rights
violations and reduce the suffering of
baby boys and the men they will become
thank you thank you any questions
thank
you also signed up to speak is Matthew
Goodwin I think he's going okay Mr
Goodwin's not here okay well moving on
also signed up to speak is David
lellan and again sir you put found five
minutes please keep it to three thank
you very much David lwell and as I
previously done ify myself I'm a lawyer
who's spent the last 28 29 years dealing
with circumcision issues I support this
um uh this house bill
1683 first Medicaid by federal statute
is only allowed to pay for medical
medically necessary procedures now that
is often the determination of that's
often left to the state but it is clear
that circum neonatal circum decision is
not medically necessary therefore abono
this bill should be a no-brainer it
should not be permitted to be done
unless there is a medical diagnosis that
is that is uh that requires it I will
address very briefly
fimosis uh the the former representative
who testified about his unfortunate
family history unfortunately what I
heard was burning cracking difficulty
retracting the foreskin in an adult or
at least in a teenager almost always and
his dad during the war almost always
that's caused by yeast infections I've
represented several adults who had
circumcisions or re circumcisions who
actually had a yeast infection never
diagnosed by the urologist and diagnosed
afterwards either pathologically or
otherwise I even had a Rec circumcision
in South Carolina where the guy still
the the gentleman still had the yeast
infection I had to send him to a
urologist who knew what he was doing
you have to be careful about ever
including fimosis as a reason for
circumcision unless it is after puberty
because otherwise they will just say
congenital fimosis I see that diagnosis
all the time and that is essentially a
medical fraud all children generally
have fimosis at Birth um it also can be
corrected by other than circumcision
there are other surgeries that can be
done Z plasties Bier flaps and the like
I won't bore you with it but it's really
not necessary to include that um as far
as the uh uh the the state really should
not be providing an opportunity for
cosmetic surgery and unnecessary surgery
what they which they do by um uh by
funding this uh in regard to economic
considerations is actually in the
literature that a doctor has said every
baby boy is born with a coupon for
$125 on his penis so is this is this uh
uh actually encourag because it's
reimbursed absolutely uh I would address
the whole question of of equity I
believe in Medicaid I believe that we
ought to be providing things we don't
provide eyeglasses for example I think
in this state you do provide uh dental
care we don't in Georgia we ought to be
but we ought not to be wasting the
Public's money so I approach this not
from a Republican or Democratic
perspective but from a perspective that
yes the poor should be covered but we
should only be doing necessary things
with public funds in regard to being
marked with poverty my foreskin is never
marked me as being poor and I'm not
exactly the richest lawyer in the world
but I'm not poor and nobody's ever said
I was because I have a forkin Hispanics
generally don't circumcise and they make
up a large percentage in Most states of
the population uh on Medicaid so I think
you would find if it weren't encouraged
you could please start wrapping up Sir
yeah anyway I think that it's very clear
in in essence that it is not medically
necessary that therefore it should not
be covered I would change the bill a
little bit I would add some things to me
for medically necessary circumcisions
such as penal tortion hypospadius
epispadias other congenital malformation
of the penis that um or foreskin that
requires uh removal of all of the part
of the foreskin for correction I would
add those and I would add to under uh on
line three uh item three or line 13
rather I would add uh in place of
recurrent urinary tract infection which
you really aren't going to be able to
determine under the age of one I would
change that to congenital cord D which
is a congenital Bend of the penis which
may require correction early uh those
are changes that I would make to the
bill if I had um a choice in the matter
if anybody has any questions I'll be
happy to answer them any
questions okay thank you sir thank you
very much I I do want to say I am
impressed by the fact that their public
hearings and the attentiveness of
everyone here in New hampsh Hampshire
makes me proud to be what a grandchild
of New Hampshire I guess but it makes me
very proud thank you very much thank you
very much for that
comment also signed up to speak is
George an chapen from intact
America
and and again you asked for four minutes
try to keep it to three please I will do
that thank you uh again my credentials
are on record uh both in writing and for
my prior testimony but I will emphasize
that I ran a nonprofit Medicaid managed
care plan in New York state for 25 years
Medicaid I support um House Bill 1683 FN
um Medicaid's a lifesaver for low-income
families Working Families the elderly
and the disabled but Medicaid resources
are finite that's why Medicaid's
standard for coverage is medical
necessity some who oppose discontinuing
Medicaid coverage of circumcisions argue
that doing so deprives poor children of
a benefit that wealthier children that
wealthier families are able to afford
the opposite is
true circumcision covers circumcision
confers no benefit on any boy or the man
he will become it only benefits the
medical professionals and Facilities who
can bill and collect for the procedure
and those who make their livings from
prep from repairing the damage that's
why the American Academy of Pediatrics
continues to push for Medicaid coverage
of
circumcision I'm going to depart from
some of the prior testimony the tone of
it and talk about my son my son is 43
years old he was born in 1980 when he
asked his dad and me um he got into
school only a couple of boys look like
me how come I'm not circumcised and we
told him you're one of the lucky ones
you have the body parts that you were
born with that God or nature intended
you to have and you should while not
holding that over other boys you should
be happy you should be proud and indeed
when he was 18 he thanked us he said you
know I never thanked you and Dad I asked
you a question I never thanked you and
Dad for not having me circumcised but I
really want to thank you I can only
imagine um what pleasure his foreskin
was giving him at that time that came
that brought him to that point but most
boys all boys should be able to have
what my son has which is his entire body
um I'd like to just briefly go through
the bioethics of circumcision because
other people have I've mentioned it
it'll take a
moment neonatal circumcision violates
every basic principle of medical
ethics autonomy means that individuals
have the right to choose for themselves
what to do with their own bodies doesn't
mean the parents it doesn't mean the
doctors it doesn't mean state taxpayers
or State Medicaid individuals have the
right to choose what they do with their
own bodies benevolence is the principle
that doctors should add act in their
patients best interests and treat them
with kindness and compassion permanently
removing healthy normal genitalia from a
baby often with inadequate or even no
pain relief clearly violates the
principle of benevolence non-maleficence
you're all familiar with it it is best
expressed with a hypocritic oath with
which you're all familiar first Do no
harm removing a healthy body part
creates harm finally Justice is a
particularly important principle to
apply in the context of routine male
circumcision in the US girls are rightly
protected from Force surgery on their
genitals boys are entitled to the same
protection to do otherwise violates the
bio bioethical principle of Justice in
some again infant circumcision violates
all of the principles of bioethical all
the bioethical principles of Justice
autonomy non-maleficence and beneficence
by calling for an antim medically
unnecessary penis surgery this committee
is doing a service to all New Hampshire
residents and to the Future boys born in
this state and the men they will become
thank you thank you any
questions sing on thank
you also signed up to speak is Adrienne
so
sodi
again you have three minutes ma'am
welcome
back yes so I'm Adrienne soti and I'm
here to support um eliminating Medicaid
funding of circumcision as uh you had
heard me before I had described how I
was given improper advice in um how to
care for my intact son
uh which uh the American Medical
Association describes is exactly what
you're not supposed to do because you
will cause fosis many parents do not
know that and therefore um falsely
believe that that is a condition that
may run in their families when in fact
perhaps they're not getting proper
Medical Care um there are alternative
treatments as described earlier and
number one there is um there are are
steroid creams just like we women uh
often for weeks or months have issues
with yeast infection men can have that
issue as well um the solution is not to
remove their genital tissues just like
we women do not have the coverage of our
clitorises removed to eliminate that or
any other uh genital tissues removed we
always revert to the most conservative
treatment which is what should be done
uh should be afforded to men as well um
so that I would definitely not use as a
um an amendment to this bill and um one
of the reasons why circumcision should
not be um covered by Medicaid also is
the need for repeat corrective surgeries
I have earlier handed out uh some uh
some papers um there was a study in M
Massachusetts General Hospital um that
said 7.4% of all visits to a pediatric
urologist were for circumcision
complications this translated to an
average total cost per patient for redo
procedures of
$1,617 and an estimate annual cost of $1
137 to that Institution for a single
Urologic provider at the hospital so
that should be taken into consideration
as well as uh what a Utah study shows um
that there the
complications of circumcision about
11% um doctors opposing circumcision
Vision um state that the approximately
the funds of uh saved would be 2,000 per
child which include the original
procedure and include later costs for
follow-up and surgical botch repairs and
it could be put to better use for actual
pediatric medical needs in New Hampshire
I also want to mention a very good uh
Jewish friend of mine who is a lady in
New York who I contacted originally when
I first was looking for information
about uh intac care and uh just
understanding circumcision circumcision
she run runs a an organization used to
run no Circ New York uh National
Organization of circumcision information
Resource Centers and she's been
educating people about this issue for 40
years she is a Jewish lady who
um does not believe in circumcision she
lives by The Motto first Do no harm and
the Golden Rule she teaches her par uh
her parents to M M Massage their babies
and ensure nurturing beginnings and does
not procedure not not support procedure
that inflicts pain and causes lifelong
psychological and physical harm which is
exactly what another representative uh
suggested we would be saving those um
Medicaid or poor Medicaid patients who
are uh subjected to the Sur surgery so
that cannot be further from the truth um
remaining intact is the default State
and uh it should be um normalized many
insurance companies besides
Medicaid also uh do not cover it so it
might be a good idea to look into that
as well thank you thank
you also signed up to speak is jakov
abov uh I uh simply don't think that
there's any place uh for taxpayer money
to be used for child mutilation
under these For No Good Reason um also
the idea that doctors are just angels
that do always uh always good is not
true either they have a lot lot of
incentives and uh money is obviously one
of
them thank
you
okay and I have two cards here I believe
they're from the same individual uh Rich
angel from Grafton from genital
autonomy uh sir you've got should be one
card I've actually got two um one says
10 minutes one says 3 minutes 3 minutes
is the one I'm going to choose
okay well somebody brought up uh mental
health um of parents and I just like to
point out that the mental health of
children is what should come first and
I'd like to tell you a little a little
story about that I the first Symposium I
attended on the subject was a second
International Symposium on circumcision
in San Francisco the second speaker was
Dr David Chamberlain who went on to um
lead um birth psychology uh if you look
up birth psychology.com I think it is
or.org uh he wrote uh babies remember
their birth and uh and other birth uh
books on that subject and so anyway uh
after he spoke I uh I did the questions
and answers thing I I asked him Dr uh
Chamberlain I found your book in the
bookstore uh called babies remember
their birth and I looked all the way
through it and I didn't find anything on
circumcision uh how did you overlook
that or or am I missing something he
said well thank you very much um
actually I wrote a burning chapter on
circumcision and other procedures that
are done routinely on infants without
anesthesia and the publisher refused to
uh publish the book with that chapter
intact so I had to uh omit it and uh if
you want to know more about the
psychological impact of infant
circumcision uh look up uh doctors
opposing circumcision.
org4 professionals you'll you'll find it
uh just look for psychological impact
and in case you think that doctor's
opposing circumcision is
biased you are correct and their bias is
Do no harm to two bodily autonomy for
all three education and preventative
care and
four conservative treatment for the rare
problems that do come up now and then
usually because of uh iatrogenic uh care
that is to say they um most of the
complications are iatrogenic in nature
in the first
place and with that I would like to
yield the balance of my time to the next
speaker okay thank you any questions
seeing done okay thank
you actually there's no one else signed
up to speak uh on hb1
1683 um the blue sheet in the back
indicates six people did sign up in
favor of it and pleas signed up opposed
to
it uh so with that I'm going to close
the public hearing on HB
1683 as previously announced we're going
to continue 1669 until later the
afternoon till 300 p.m. uh it is after
1:00 so we can move on to HB
1194 and this time I will recognize the
prime sponsor who once again is
representative
Phillips is actually is representative
Phillips here oh okay
okay good afternoon everybody I hope
everyone got their lunch in um I'll be
very quick this um Bill 1194 um just as
a definition
correction to align with the idea that
vaccines protect people from uh diseases
that
are uh pass personto person so the RSA
should match that and that's
all well that's quick representative
Palmer so looking at the schedule that
sort of leaves out
tetus and I'm not quite sure why we
would want to leave out tetus since it's
not communicable person to person but if
you get it I've seen somebody with
tetnus and I never want to see that
again just a definition change what do
you mean by leaving it
out you mean on what what things can be
mandated people can still choose tness
yeah right but I'm not I'm just not
quite sure then why we would change the
language why we would have ail to change
the language
if there's no other thing than it
changes the language uh representative
Parmer we're having trouble hearing you
up here is this not working uh just move
it move it closer even closer sorry I I
guess so since all of the most of the
other diseases in there pneumonia is a
little iffy but are infectious and
transmitted person to person and I guess
technically tetanus is really infectious
as well but it's not transmitted person
to person but it's kind of a really key
thing to have
vaccinated I'm not quite sure maybe you
can explain to me better than I'm
understanding the reason that we need a
a language change if it doesn't really
change
anything I mean we're trying to I guess
the vaccine is supposed to protect you
from Catching something from someone
else right and tetanus cannot you cannot
catch tetanus from another human
being right but I wouldn't want somebody
to opt out of of the tetus for some
reason and then get tetanus but if I'm
just not understanding the the rationale
for the bill I guess that's my I believe
people can opt out of whatever they
want yes but why do we need to get rid
of the word
infectious it's not transmissible I
don't know I
just representative kushman thank you Mr
chairman um thank you representative
isn't it true that the idea for
mandating
vaccinations is that you are preventing
something that can be transmissible
between people and that is the only
scenario where the
government asserts some kind of ability
to do that um and that matters of
diseases that are not transmissible are
personal decisions where government has
no authority to step
in yes thank you follow up um are you
aware of any tetanus vaccin vaccines
available in the United States that
don't also include antigens for
communicable diseases such as D theia
and uh protesis I'm not a medical
professional but I'm not familiar I
think they're all combos thank
you other questions
I'm seeing no other questions okay thank
you thank
you also signed up to speak is Ryan
tanan and Dr Benjamin Chan from the
Department of Health and Human
Services good morning want to make sure
people can hear me yes great um Mr chair
members of the committee thank you for
um hearing Our Testimony um my name is
uh Benjamin Shan I am uh the New
Hampshire State epidemiologist and an
infectious disease physician and with me
today is Dr Ryan tanan who is a
registered pharmacist and the chief of
our Bureau of Infectious Disease Control
and we are here to speak in opposition
to House Bill
1194 um relative to this definition
change which removes the word infectious
from the current definition of non-c
communic non-communicable disease in RSA
141c uh as is already started to be
discussed uh we believe this proposed
legislation is intended to prevent the
department uh specifically from
requiring um certain immunizations that
are currently required under RSA 141c
for entry into child care in schools
specifically the tetanus vaccine um and
combination vaccines which include
tetanus um all of the infectious
diseases currently listed um under RSA
141c for which the department current
currently requires vaccination for
children in child care and schools are
spread personto person with the
exception of
tetanus however um there is a conflict
because the tetanus vaccine is not a
standalone vaccine rather it's a vaccine
that um is formulated in combination for
other diseases like diptheria um and
pertusus which are also required
immunizations under RCA
141c um therefore a child must receive a
tetanus containing vaccine to be
immunized against dip theia and pressus
which sets up a um conflict and a contra
indication within the legislation said
should um House Bill one uh House Bill
1194 pass um so we believe that um this
legislation if adopted would prevent the
department from requiring any vaccine
that contains tetanus including
combination vaccines uh for some of
these other important um communicable
diseases so for that reason we oppose um
any attempt to remove uh the
Department's authority to require tetnus
vaccine uh particularly if it
jeopardizes requirements for other
communicable diseases uh based on the
currently available vaccine
formulations um we also want to make the
committee aware that during the 2018
legislative session House Bill
1367 was proposed relative to removing
tetanus from the law requiring certain
immunization and that proposed
legislation at that time was determined
by this uh committee to be inexpedient
to legislate so in summary well it's
true that tetanus is not transmitted
personto person we still recommend for
um the reasons already highlighted uh
that all all children and adults be
appropriately immunized against this
potentially deadly disease and we oppose
legislation that would limit um the
Department's authority to require
certain vaccines that are safe and
highly effective at preventing the
spread of disease and outbreaks in
childcare in school settings um and with
that I will'll end our testimony and
take any questions thank you I think
that's exactly three minutes that's
excellent um you indicated on your pink
card that you had written testimony you
were going to submit is that correct yes
and uh I thought we had already
submitted that oh okay I think it has
been submitted and I'll just I'll just
also point out that there's actually
more information in that testimony
specific to tetanus um it's an uncommon
disease uh we certainly highly recommend
that people um get vaccinated against it
because even with modern medical care
when people get tetanus it can be
there's like a 10 to 20% fatality rate
um because of how severe the infection
can be okay thank you Dr tanan did you
want to say anything or uh are you just
here for backup so to speak or just here
to assist if there's any questions thank
you okay are there any questions
representative
Weber so I'm wondering about about the
effect of the language of removing that
one word and being left only with the
personto person
designation um when it's is am I correct
in thinking that there are that that
might be a problem because there are
issues of transmission from um uh
animals to people or from um Less Direct
contacts than personto person uh through
F food or something like that or hot
tubs or other things I mean I know
there's no vac for that but yeah
representative Weber thank you for that
question um and and you're absolutely
right tetanus is a disease that's
transmitted through the environment you
know this is a it's a toxin mediated
disease where um somebody can get
infected from the environment with
spores at this bacteria the spores start
germinating and reproducing in their
body it releases a toxin that causes um
the disease tetanus so it's not
transmitted personto person uh it's an
environmentally acquired disease it's
still an infectious disease right it's
not transmitted person to person but it
is an infectious disease and hence
removing the word infectious disease or
infectious from the definition would
specifically Target That
vaccine followup sure and are there
other roots of transmission like um
through contact with an object or or
other other ways of transmission that
are not strictly speaking personto
person but through an intermediary of
some kind um so so tetanus is not a
disease that somebody gets and then
passes along to somebody else through um
the environment as through an
intermediate mechanism right this is a
bacteria that's s in the soil um you
know the classic example is somebody
steps on a rusty nail for example and
that Rusty Nails Bend in the environment
it you know punctures the skin you know
contaminating somebody's you know body
with the bacteria and the spores that
then release the toxin uh into the body
but it's not like somebody has it and
then passes it through the environment
to somebody else it's just a bacteria
that's everywhere currently in our
environment and hence the need for a
routine and uh periodic boosting uh with
a tetanus
vaccine repr Murphy thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for taking the
question um this a simple question I
guess and I should know this but the
mortality rate for unvaccinated patient
uh from
tetnus
um I'm trying to think uh so so the
vaccine is probably near 100% effective
right so if somebody gets tetanus
it's almost always I don't you know
nothing's ever 100% it's almost always
in somebody that's unvaccinated or is
not up to date on their
vaccination and so when tetanus does
occur you know obviously there's
supportive care that you can provide um
but even with you know that supportive
care 10 to 20% of people will still die
from the disease okay um and it's a
toxin mediated disease meaning somebody
gets it it causes convulsions paralysis
the the the lay person's term is lock
jaw because it causes such severe muscle
spasms and convulsions that people can
break their bones from the the dis from
the Sy uh symptoms um so it's it's not a
it's not a pretty disease um I'm I'm
impressed that you've seen a case of
tetanus it's not common anymore because
of the vaccine um but it's not
transmitted personto person thank you
representative Palmer thank you Mr Jaren
thank thank you for doing this one the
other things that come to mind would be
this would get in the way of any kind of
um issues around vectorborne disease
later on because that's not personto
person but it might I mean now that
there's a malaria vaccine not that we
have it here yet but who knows yeah no
that's a that's a great Point thank you
for that question you know um we
certainly can't predict the future of
what's coming with
vaccines um but there are a number of
other vaccines uh potentially out there
in development um you know I think that
the question is going to be and again
just going back to the VAC you know we
only require a subset of vaccines um for
children entering school and child care
and you know there's a number of
criteria that we often talk about you
know one is that the vaccine has to be
highly effective um you know and second
it needs to be effective at preventing
infection and preventing you know
outbreaks um and so you know whether a
vaccine would sort of meet that criteria
I I think remains to be seen what the
what the vaccine is um you know we've
also talked in the past about how we
don't require and don't plan to require
vaccines like influenza vaccine or
covid-19 vaccine because these are
recurring vaccines where you see
efficacy drop off over time and so what
we're really looking for um when we um
add a vaccine to the required list which
we haven't done in many years um it's
really high efficacy preventing um
outbreaks and spread of disease and
child care and school settings um it
just so happens that with tetanus uh you
can't get the tetanus vaccine without
also getting vaccinated for some of
these other highly communicable diseases
um and that poses a problem with this
current
legislation okay uh representative
kushman thank you Mr chairman um I just
want to raise a question of uh the
appropriateness of an employee of the um
executive
branch um coming here in His official
capacity and supporting or opposing a
bill and not just providing technical
information um I believe that
instructing the agents is a right for
the people in part one it's reserved to
them it's not a right given to um
government agents in place of um the
people so I I just see a little bit of a
conflict here I feel that they either
should only be offering the technical
advice without supporting or opposing if
they're here on behalf of the state and
um or be here as a private person and
then they can support or
oppose all right uh any reaction
gentlemen or for that comment or I I I
guess I'll just say that you know I I
think we've oftentimes taken so there's
a number of options uh certainly
providing information is one option but
we have certainly the the department has
you know opposed and supported bills uh
even that that also you know impact our
authorities so that's uh I I think
opposing this bill is not outside of the
realm of uh the the positions and uh the
processes of the department in the past
okay thank you other
questions seeing none okay thank you
thank
you last person I have signed up to
testify on HB
1194 is laa Condon from
Bedford good afternoon my name is Laura
Condon I'm from Bedford New Hampshire
and I um I support I support this change
in the definition because this is an era
in the definition of non-communicable
and it warrants correction in
statute the committee should be aware
that over 76% of the vaccines purchased
and sold by the Department of Health and
Human Services are on a voluntary use
basis this demonstrates that parents
will actively choose vaccination for
their children even if it's not required
by State Statute there is no expectation
that people won't use the tetanus um
vaccine for for their children so that
is a
unsubstantiated um
concern there the requirements of
vaccines are are are for products that
contain risk they are not risk-free
products and so because of that they
must only apply to diseases that can
actually be spread from child to child
the attent of vaccination requirements
are to prevent the spread of disease in
the community not specifically to
protect one
individual um if we were protecting one
individual we would be mandating um that
they wouldn't be allowed to eat the junk
cereal and the donuts they're eating for
breakfast there are now over 70 doses of
vaccines recommended for children from
birth to age 18 now that is not a
misstatement over 70 doses of vaccines
recommended for children from birth to
age 18 by the CDC there are dozens of
more vaccines in the pipeline there
could be vaccines against obesity and if
we didn't have a proper definition um in
statute those sort of vaccines could be
required for
children to speak because the tetnus was
raised I wanted to add some comments
about this because I was involved in
Prior legislation with regard to
vaccination um against tetanus tetanus
is a bacteria that's ubiquitous it's
everywhere it's probably here it's
probably on you it's
everywhere it's extremely rare that
anybody who comes in contact with
tetanus because we all do may have an
adverse illness uh outcome in fact if
somebody is experienced symptoms of
tetanus you actually can't test for
tetanus it's not like you can do you
know a bacterial culture and test for
tetanus because tetanus is ubiquitous
it's everywhere so it's actually a
diagnosis of elimination so they test
the person could it be this could it be
that could it be this could it be that
it's not so they said well must be tetus
in fact if you look at the cases of
tetanus in this country um it is only in
the very elderly those over age 60 they
are chronically ill with severe
illnesses often in um already um in some
sort of Medical Institution in spite of
that and there might be two dozen cases
a year in spite of that the Mortal
mortality rate is extremely low um 99%
of those chronically individuals survive
their diagnoses of tetanus and you'd
think that you know there would be much
more outbreaks because the the majority
of adults actually are not current with
um tetanus recommendations so for those
reasons I do believe that this this bill
is a necessary bill at this time and I
would be happy to take any questions
thank you any questions
representative kushman thank you Mr
chairman so in your view is this just a
correction of of an incorrect definition
because the definition of
communicable I
non-communicable ab ab absolutely it it
is you know just an error that was made
um when you know the the definition of
non-communicable was put in place and um
it's a technical area that that needs to
be corrected um
to protect our children from vaccines
that don't address a communic
problem representative paza thank you Mr
chair and thank you for taking my
question in in your research uh uh and
your data uh do you see any
contradiction uh uh to the statement
that uh it's this uh tetanus vaccine is
close to 100% effective Could It Be
Still true that it's 100% % effective
that the vaccination is 100% effective
forus forus I have not found evidence of
that other
questions representative Nel you acting
like
you well we prefer
questions
okay any other questions I'm saying n
thank you thank
you I have no one else that signed up
for to uh speak to HB 11194 does anyone
else wish to speak to HB
11194 uh on the blue sheet in the back
in terms of people expressing their
position on this bill um seven people
signed up in favor and two people signed
up
against Mr chairman uh yes
representative kushman do we know what
the numbers on the um online Portal sign
in I I do not know that no that might be
helpful for us to understand where you
know what the public opinion if most
have been the number of and that that
may be continuing even Beyond Today
certainly especially for executive
session that might be something to be
made for us to be made aware of thank
you yeah there you
go representative Palmer I think that
might be because the online testimony
overwhelmingly did not the people did
not list where they're from and I'd like
to know on on the online will'll see how
many people in New Hampshire actually
have an opinion one way or the other so
that
sure anything else on HB
1194 saying none I'm going to close the
public hearing on HB
1194 next public hearing scheduled is
not until 2:00 for hb1 1213 FN so we
will be in recess for the next 20
minutes and reconvene at
2:00
good afternoon and welcome back to the
house committee on Health and Human
Services and elderly Affairs the next
bill we have uh to be considered today
is House Bill 1213 FN and I will
recognize representative Emily Phillips
once again we're seeing a lot of
Representative Phillips
today we could have canceled today if it
wasn't for you you know it's a i very
much appreciate having everything
scheduled on one day thank you um
everyone good afternoon again um so I am
on the child care the special committee
for child care and we have heard a ton
of testimony that uh there is not enough
supply of child care providers in New
Hampshire that there plenty of demand
and that they are overworked
underappreciated and they have a lot of
Burden uh as far as paperwork so this
bill was written in a way to allow um
daycare workers to opt out of collecting
vaccines information uh we threw in the
private schools too um there's just
we've heard overwhelmingly in the online
portal you'll see uh from daycare
workers who support this bill because
they're not trained to handle um
confidential medical information and
they feel like they're constantly
chasing down parents who children are
due for vaccination um or updated
paperwork um as you know our state has a
um uh great exemption program so
sometimes they're just getting the
initial exemption from the child but
other times they're chasing people down
um so it's not really a public health
issue because some people have
exemptions some people are are following
the schedule so we're just trying to
relieve um the paperwork burden for
daycares in private schools because who
are we to tell private businesses what
to do so that's the gist of it um
questions any
questions seeing none okay oh
representative HB
1213 I do have a question okay sure um
thank you Mr chairman thanks for taking
my question I I I I become a stickler on
definitions um so this is going to sound
like a really weird question but is
there I I was looking to see if there's
any definition of Public School versus
private school anywhere in statute and I
went through I couldn't find one and I'm
just curious given the complexity of
Education these days is that's Germain
or
a very good question I don't know the
answer to that maybe someone behind me
can Define it thank you thank
you
okay also signed up to speak are Dr
tanan and Dr Chan from from the
Department of Health and Human
Services good afternoon again um I'm Dr
Ryan Tan and I'm joined with Dr Benjamin
Chan and uh we're here to speak about
hb1
12113 and uh the department at this time
we do oppose um the bill as written so
this bill actually does more than um
minimize or reduce the reporting
requirements uh which I can talk to in a
moment but um hb1 1213 would also um
remove the requirement of the vaccines
that are currently required in childcare
agencies and private schools and it
would be limited only to children who
are attending Public Schools so the
department uh believes that this would
unnecessarily Place children teachers
School staff uh both at schools and
child care agencies uh public or private
at risk for infectious disease outbreaks
uh we believe it would also negatively
impact the effect of the surrounding
Community um you know for example I can
share with you right now uh Philadelphia
recently identified a measles outbreak
break in a child care center and uh this
was in December of 2013 and the
Department of Public Health in
Philadelphia is working with three Area
Children's Hospitals where patients may
have been exposed as well as other
hospitals and an urgent care center to
identify individuals who may be at
risk um additionally there's just a
growing number of meil outbreaks
reported globally as well as uh here in
the United States and these outbreaks
not only put the health and safety all
children regardless of what type of
school or educational model they may be
uh pursuing but it puts everyone at risk
uh and when we do go to investigate and
bring these investigations under control
they actually are quite costly there was
a study in 2020 that reviewed measles
outbreaks from 2001 to 2018 and was
estimated one outbreak uh cost
$12,383
18,000 and these costs were Associated
to the public health response
hospitalizations
investigations um and other things that
go into bringing those outbreaks under
control and also facilities would
possibly have to voluntarily close if
there's health risks due to uh their
staff it may also affect um Staffing
ratios and other reasons for why a child
care facility may need to
close so the dment also believes that we
already have a process in place that's
it's important to protect all children
across New Hampshire and also allows for
medical exemptions and religious
exemptions as far as the documentation
and Reporting requirements the
department does not collect or retain
any individual student or patient
information that is managed at the
school level what the department does do
is look at aggregate raw data about the
number of students in child care and
school settings who are considered
upto-date or may be exempt from a
vaccine ination and it also helps our uh
Folks at Public Health work with school
programs to work on any sort of process
Improvement or quality initiatives and I
can share a recent example where there
was a school that had a um had reported
a odd-looking number of exemptions we
had a conversation with the school nurse
and it was a new school nurse it was
their first year working um and they
were actually reporting the information
incorrectly so we were able to work with
them after reviewing some of the
information and make sure that what
they're reporting is
accurate and then lastly uh you know we
believe that the all New Hampshire
children should have an equal
opportunity to attend school or child
care in a healthy and safe environment
and we believe that there's already
proper measures in place to protect
against these
diseases I want to thank you for the
opportunity today and we're happy to
answer any questions you may have thank
any
questions yeah representative Murphy
thank you Mr chairman just a tech um it
says on the card that you have submitted
testimony and I believe you did that um
yes that's correct I I I trying to find
it I was just wondering when you get
back could you send a that out again
perhaps that testimony is if you're
going to do that even 1194 because I i'
just like to get both copies if I could
absolutely thank you so
much representative Nagel thank you Mr
chairman thanks for taking my question I
want to make sure I'm understanding this
bill properly um as I read
it the children are still required to
have the these immunizations what no
longer would exist if this bill takes
place is that the Child Care Agency or
the private school would have to
maintain the records and and demonstrate
that they've had those so in other words
if I start there I don't have to bring a
record that I have had this immunization
am I reading that bill
wrong so so what I what I will say the
interpretation that the department had
on this bill there's three three pieces
to this where one it is now removing the
requirement for children who are
attending child child care or private
schools would no longer be required to
have vaccinations the second point is
the department would not have the
ability to review any sort of
immunization records at the school and
um lastly only Public Schools would be
required to report the aggregate data to
the
state can I follow up follow up as as I
see it is the the the requirement to
have the immunization is line one of the
statute um but that doesn't seem to be
removed it's only the changes in line
two so according to what I'm reading
they still have to get the immunization
the the agency or the school doesn't
have
to right
correct right so thank you again for for
this question but as the we reviewed at
the department we interpret this as the
immunization requirements in 141 c20a
would no longer be required for children
in child care or private
schools you all
set okay representative kosman thank you
Mr chairman and thank you for um making
that statement um if that's your reading
that the documentation requirement of
this law it requires either than
immunization records or an exemption is
that
correct I'm sorry could you state the
question again so the Department's
interpretation of the law is that if
this bill were to pass that there would
no longer be a
requirement um for private um schools
and daycare
agencies uh to ensure that children have
been vaccinated according to the
RSA correct correct so then does it also
follow that it's the position of the
department that agencies also must
accept exemptions since the statute says
that they have to take
either have to keep either the record or
the record of an
exemption so the exemptions whether it's
a record of immunization or an exemption
the department does not collect that
information that's maintained at the
school or the Child Care Agency
right but you're saying that the statute
requires the kids to be vaccinated to go
to the daycare or the private school it
Al it also it says immunization or
exemption or posal immunization so all
three of those one of those three is
required for a child to go to a daycare
or a school in New Hampshire per this
RSA that's how the department is uh
reading it
as currently written or what's being
proposed as currently written yeah so as
currently written RSA 141
c20a children attending Child Care
public or private schools either require
documentation of the immunization or an
exemption thank you can I ask one more
followup one followup one more okay so
if if this bill passed then it would
remove a requirement for children to be
either vaccinated and show proof of that
and it would also remove the requirement
for daycares then to accept
exemptions I would have to look into
this in more detail to answer the
question about accepting the exemptions
but our initial interpretation is the
immunization requirements would only
apply to children attending Public
Schools thank so there yes does that
answer your question thank you yes
representative
palazov uh thank you Mr chair and thank
you for taking my question uh is my
understanding correct that state and
specifically DHHS uh uh in uh business
of providing uh selling some of those
vaccines and if so like uh let's say the
case scenarios that all public private
schools and daycare centers would
stop uh those kids stop uh purchasing
and using those vaccines uh what would
what would be financial
implications for DHHS and
otherwise uh can you
elaborate yes thank you for the question
so the the state does not sell vaccines
um and vaccinations are actually
conducted at the the child's
pediatrician's office or or family care
provider um is any clinics that may be
conducted at a school particularly the
school-based influenza clinics are uh
you know conducted through uh either
Partnerships with healthc Care Systems
or the regional public health networks
so uh aside from a
transactional uh aspect to purchase and
selling vaccines there would be no
impact but we believe that there would
be a financial impact potentially to
child carees or private schools that may
have to close due to disease outbreak or
increased health care costs due to
increased um um children Contracting
infectious diseases that are prevented
by
vaccines any other
questions seeing none okay thank you
gentlemen
also signed up to speak is
representative Ros
Barry thank you Mr chairman um my name
is uh representative Ross Barry I'm also
the uh chair of the house special
committee on Child Care um so this was
one of the things that came forward as
you guys know we've been working on ways
to uh increase access to child care and
decrease the cost of child care um while
maintaining quality Child Care um so
this was one of the things that has come
up um in our time is child care centers
have a lot of paperwork burden a ton of
paperwork burden um I believe three
other childcare centers have written
into the committee supporting this bill
um this bill I I know that there's going
to be a tendency for this bill to try to
get caught up in the vaccine not vaccine
debate so let me start off with I am
vaccinated my child is vac ated my wife
is vaccinated I'm not antiva I have what
you do with your body is in fact your
choice um but what happens is is you
guys the state has turned Child Care
Centers into this kind of faux Reporting
Agency on vacines the irony being is we
have a religious exemption waiver so any
health argument that might be made is
kind of moot because I could have all 65
of my children that are under my care
sign a religious exemption waiver and
that would be perfectly compliant so
what happens is is child care centers
have to maintain these immunization
records we get asked for them it's a
recurring thing that we constantly have
to update um and we're already you know
that's not why anybody got in the
childcare industry was to track these
medical records uh one of the things
that I wanted to flag is there has been
kind of quiet concerns about Hippa
violations because while Hippa doesn't
cover Child Care Centers specifically
you look at kind of like what's covered
it we do have medical um procedures that
are performed in a child care center um
DCF might come in and perform a mental
exam um from a child they're
investigating all of my teachers are you
know we can give epipens we things the
claim has never been made but I am
terrified that one day it will be made
and it could be extended to us um and a
problem with that be is we are in no way
hippoc compliant you are forcing parents
to turn over private medical information
to us that we do not have to hold in a
standard that another Med a medical
center would hold so I I do worry about
kind of the liability of that in the
long run if that claim is ever made um
because while it wouldn't be a direct
jump to that I do think that a um a a
sleuthing person using the law could
actually connect the two given the other
services that get provided at Child Care
Centers outside of kind of what you
would normally think of um but we do I
do believe that this would reduce the
burden uh it would reduce paperwork
violations what happens is when DHHS
issues a violation we have to post it
prominently in our Center um most
parents don't e either don't look at it
or really look at it there's kind of two
parents the ones that are really like oh
my God what is this and the ones who
don't notice it's there um and then we
have to start explaining about you know
if you miss one child right you can get
written up for that by DHHS and then you
have to post it publicly until they
inspect you again um so these sort of
things they do add up it's one of the
deals of kind of it was one of those
things and you can kind of see it
happening right it's like all right well
we're just going to add this and we're
going to add this and we're going to add
this so one of the things we're trying
to do in the child care committee
special committee on childcare is remove
those things that have been added over
time um so I'm happy to to answer any
questions about this um I will say uh
DHHS came up here and said there be a
fiscal impact on Child Care Centers if
we took away this requirement my
personal belief in dealing with parents
and children is that the overwhelming
vast majority of parents are going to
get their children immunized because
they believe it is the right thing to do
I don't think the state requiring it to
attend well the state doesn't even
require it because you can sign the
waiver um but I don't think the state
having it on there I don't think that's
a valid um I I don't think that's a
valid um uh a valid argument um just to
be blunt you know the there's sick
there's illnesses go through child care
centers on a regular basis um it's not
because a child care center is dirty
like at my at my child care center we
disinfect every night and then we do a
deep clean every Thursday um and we
still have stuff gets through there
because kids are kids like you know they
have um they have um you know they get
dirty and they they have weaker immune
they have newer immune systems that
don't have everything yet um so you know
we're kind of used to dealing with that
on on that front um so I wouldn't put a
whole lot of weight to that um I haven't
met a single Cher Cent our owner that
has said we have to have these
immunization records otherwise we'll be
shutting down because there's going to
be a measles outbreak it just it just
bluntly sounds a little far-fetched to
me but anyways I'm happy to answer any
questions like I said I I own a child
care center over in epom New Hampshire
it's where I just came from it's why I
look like this um but Happ to answer any
questions from the business side of
Representative par you had a question or
yeah well my question is really and and
uh representative Philip sort of said
and we threw in public I mean private
schools and I'm sort of I've got two
questions about the private school thing
is one you know well why I mean there
are small private schools and I actually
my kids actually went to a little one
and I was one of the people who helped
collect the data because there wasn't a
staff member to do that so that would
fall into sort of the same boat that
you're talking about about lack of
resources but I doubt St Paul's has that
problem and um and the second part of my
question is so people send their kids to
St Paul's from all over the place and
there are a bunch of other big private
schools in New Hampshire that have kids
from everywhere and I would imagine
those the parents of a lot of those kids
are sort of expecting that the school is
keeping track of that because there's no
way the state could keep track of
somebody who's coming from California to
go to school there so I guess I'm a
little bit Leary about putting the
public the private schools into this
boat along with the daycare centers I
mean I I don't know what the the
question is there I don't I don't work
in the CH in the private school space I
can't say dealing with parents they're
usually more generally surprised that we
ask for that um but you know it's it's
uh I I can't speak for private schools I
don't I don't work inside of a private
school setting working inside of a
childcare setting I guess maybe I'll put
the question the other way then would
you mind having this bill amended to
take private schools out of it um I mean
if that makes it more likely to pass
that would be that that would be my
statement if it makes more likely for
the bill to be successful then sure my
my philosophical answer would be leave
them in but if it makes it uh you know
politics is not a dictatorship so um
trust me I have to make deals all the
time in election law that I don't always
love
so other
questions see oh representative kachman
thank you Mr chairman thank you
representative um being that you uh run
a child care center is it your
understanding of the law that the law
says that children have to have um is it
your understanding that you have to
honor exemptions if you receive them as
a part of that law you have to honor
either an exemption or a vaccination and
that you can't discriminate you can't
keep kids out uh uh correct and there
was I believe in the written test the
answer question is yes I believe in one
of the written testimonies you received
from one of the other child care centers
we don't check into whether or not there
is a I don't care a legitimate religious
exemption right we don't put them up to
some sort of religious louth test uh nor
would we by the way um it would be
grossly inappropriate to do that um we
just take them on their word um I would
be stunned if there weren't parents just
signed that form just to avoid having to
either turn that information over or go
get it from their child's PCP um it's it
is definitely a catchall um and I don't
see a way in which you could
legitimately enforce it because how are
you to determine what somebody's true
religious beliefs are especially a
Childcare Center
employee my representative Shapiro thank
you Mr chairman so if you share my
assumption which maybe you don't that
tracking vaccinations through Public
Schools private schools dayc carees
overall improves compliance and the
numbers of people who get vaccines if
you share that
assumption but it's such a problem with
Workforce and um you know tedious
bureaucratic work that you that daycare
centers have to do can you think of
another alternative to kind of track
vaccinations in a way that would
encourage people getting them and and
and and encouraging Public Health
basically you know I I think you need to
let people be people and make the
decisions that are best for them right
I'll give you an example for myself um I
every single year I go to the doctor and
every single year I get a flu shot every
single year I go to the doctor and every
single year I get a pneumonia shot why
because I've had pneumonia three times
been in the hospital for it um people
should be able I I believe that most
people believe that vaccines keep them
healthy that's their business um I am
not a doctor I'm not here to tell them
it is or is not I personally believe
that it is and that's why I put them in
my body um there are certain vaccines I
haven't put in my body because I
question that um you know I I don't
think that using Child Care Centers as
an arm of the government to encourage
people to get vaccines is appropriate um
I think what would be more appropriate
would be a public health campaign or
going to the doctors directly um and
maybe having Anonymous aggregated data
from the doctors who are the ones
actually administering the shots um I
think that would be more appropriate
than using Child Care Centers as a
reporting agency of
DHHS other
questions seeing done okay thank
you also signed up to speak is Henry
Henry veu from the representing the YMCA
Alliance of Northern New
England you are you sitting in for Mr B
no he was unable to uh make the hearing
uh due to a conflict but he wanted to
just share some written testimony so I'm
just going to pass that out sure thank
you you won't be speaking for him then I
take it you just passing out the test
okay thank you also signed up to speak
is Jesse Davis representing the
Department of Health and Human
Services
sorry I am Jesse Davis and I am the
bureau chief of Child Development and
Head Start collaboration and I am the
child care Development Fund
administrator for the State of New
Hampshire yeah you indicated five
minutes on your card if you can keep it
closer to three I'd appreciate it that's
fine so we have federal reporting
requirements um for the scholarship
program and we currently have 603 Child
Care programs out of roughly 700 who
receive
scholarship um
dollars for their programs and this
would put us out of federal um
regulation requirements for those
families who need these
Services well that's it yes well that
was quick any
questions representative kushman thank
you Mr chairman and thank you for being
here um can you explain what the
requirement is is it something that you
could um give to participants who wish
to um obtain those
funds um on a voluntary basis so if you
receive scholarship dollars as a child
care provider you do have to maintain
records of either being immun immunized
or having an exemption on file when you
become licensed we go out and we um
review to ensure that you are in
compliance with that Federal
requirement does that answer your
question I'm
sorry um it sounds like they could do it
voluntarily from what you just said is
that
correct yes absolutely as long as this
bill is written in a way that doesn't
exclude these programs from having to
meet that Federal
requirement representative on um thank
you Mr chairman and thank you for being
here um reading this it says that um it
doesn't have anything that prohibits the
child care agencies or the private
schools from keeping those records it
simply removes the shell the requirement
that they keep them and the requirement
that they keep them available for the
for inspection without any language
prohibiting them from keeping these
records if they're able to access
federal funds would that resolve your
objection um I'm neutral I'm sharing
information so um I'm not opposed or for
this bill I'm just simply sharing what
the federal requirements are for this
for these programs sorry and then as the
followup so you don't see anything that
would prohibit them from keeping these
records in this bill as
written correct thank
you representative Shapero thank you Mr
chairman I'm I'm a little confused so
you
administer scholarships which includes
Federal money and comes under federal
regulations to
individuals or to Child Care Centers
families are eligible for scholarship
dollars in order for a Child Care
Program to receive those monies for
those families to subsidize their care
they have to meet Federal requirements
which requires them to have immunization
records or exemptions on file followup
followup so we're not talking about the
individuals who apply for the
scholarships were were were really
referring to any child care setting that
accepts those Federal scholarships to
keep track of all their students
vaccination records absolutely yes thank
you other
questions okay I'm seeing none thank you
thank
you also signed up to speak is Kate Frey
from new
futures
again ma'am you indicated five minutes
if you can keep it closer to three
that'd be great thank you I can probably
do it even less than that good afternoon
chair and members of the committee my
name is Kate fry I'm vice president of
advocacy from new Futures a lot of my
points were said before but we do oppose
HB 1213 both from a public health point
of view and the impact it could have to
um Child Care programs um we really view
this as a way to weaken the New
Hampshire childhood um immunization
program we have a very strong program
that offers uh access to all New
Hampshire um children free of charge
through a very um collaborative effort
with federal funds General funds and the
um uh insurance companies we've in the
past have very high rates we've being
rates drop because of the pandemic like
many states have and this Con the
concern about this bill is it's just one
more way to um have less uh see those
vaccination uh rates drop more um if we
see more of those rates drop we will
open the door to um uh previously
eradicated diseases uh I won't I have a
lot more detail in my testimony um but
we are especially concerned about the
peace about um child care and the um
adherence to Federal block grant
requirements we understanded that it
would require the programs to collect
the vaccination Pro uh data if the
program stops collecting the data um how
will they know you know how will they be
able to warport it they will not be
eligible to participate in these Child
Care scholarships um and I just want to
make a note that the child care crisis
in New Hampshire as we know has worsened
since covid in 2023 new features
Champion the child care for New
Hampshire Working Families act which
modernized the New Hampshire Child Care
scholarship programs got $6.5 million in
the budget to ensure that families
qualify for scholarships so if hwe 1213
passes we would be concerned to be
taking a step back from the progress
achieved in really improving Child Care
access in the state um with that said we
would oppose um House Bill 1213 we ask
you to vote and expedient to
legislate thank you questions
representative Lon um thank you Mr
chairman and thank you it's good to see
you again here nice uh I may have missed
this when I was trying to listen to your
testimony did you just say that we're
spending $60 million so that we can
receive federal grants for child care or
did I miss one of the details in that so
we have additional General funds so we
can leverage for their federal funds to
expand Child Care scholarship programs
to reduce the rates for families for
child care so this is what uh one of the
accomplishments we were able to make in
the budget to really improve access to
child care in the state so our concern
with this bill is um one of the
requirements is to collect um
vaccination rates if we're not
collecting vaccination rates that will
put the federal funds at Jeopardy um
thank you sir and as a follow up um I
sorry as um could you provide the other
Federal requirements that are coming
from that money because I just want to
make sure that we're balancing these
needs and do you see anywhere in here
that prohibits the child care agencies
from still collecting these records I
guess my concern is while I explicitly
don't see it I don't see anything that I
mean how will they know what their rates
are if they don't collect this
information and how will we know that's
accurate information if there's nothing
in the statute that dictates they do so
I guess they can collect it voluntarily
but um the concern would be you know
whether that information is accurate and
then we also lose the public health um
reasons why that information is
important to collect as the department
had said earlier regarding
outbreaks representative Shapero thank
you Mr chairman and thank you for taking
this question I really missed my
opportunity when the person from the
Department was testifying but you're
smart so maybe you know um do you know
what percentage of daycare centers um
accept accept these scholarships I don't
off the top of my head cuz I'm not the
Child Care Agency or Child Care expert
at new Futures but I can get that
information to you and and follow up
follow up and do home daycares take
these as well I believe home dayc carees
but I would defer to the department on
that I will say that many of the child
care providers we work with are in
opposition to this bill because they are
concerned how it will impact their
scholarships okay thank you other
questions representative Nagel thank you
Mr chairman thank you for taking my
question and again as representative
Shapiro had just said you're sitting in
the wrong place at the wrong time so
I'll address this to you um I'm a boots
on the ground doctor but I've also been
involved in policy development at the
local Regional National levels and
what's driving me crazy in looking at
bills over and over and over again is
everything is just another form it's
just one more form and I I understand
the need for data but the problem is is
that data adversely affects our ability
to do our job and I think that's what's
driving this bill and we deal with a
thing that used to be called meaningful
list um use in medicine that's now
called some um managing interoperability
or something it's really adversing
affecting our ability to do our job and
and we need to find better strategies on
how to satisfy your needs to collect
data and our needs to do our job for the
people we care for and I'm just curious
if you have any thought if number one do
you understand that and number two is do
you have any creative strategies that
can help solve that dilemma especially
for small providers and small schools so
again I'm not uh thank you for the
question um I'm not a child care expert
but I will say that this information has
been collected for some time we have not
I think through our circle of providers
have heard concerns about it it's what's
been
collected um I do think the idea behind
expanding um the scholarship programs
and the money going to child care
agencies hopefully can offer to um
offset some of those costs in some way
if there's an easier way to do it but I
do at the end of the day really believe
that that public health information is
really important to run a child care
business other
questions oh representative Missour
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question uh so we've heard it before
but I I again I'm just clarifying in
your opinion does this bill prevent
child care in um agencies from
collecting this data does it prevent
them I mean I would it says here that it
such records um public schools and child
care AG you shall make an it it
prohibits them from making an annual
report I guess if they're not making an
annual report are they collecting that
information I think it just makes it
unclear I would have concerns about that
and how can they report to um regarding
the federal dollars if they don't have
that um accurate information followup
followup thank you you also um we also
talked before you said about you know
skewing the data if they don't if it's
not collected but there could be a lot
of medical exemptions existing with all
of these different childcare industries
that are currently collecting this
information that are actually skewing
the data so how would how would this
change yeah my understanding about
exemption rates are that they pretty low
in this state I deferred to the
department on that so I'm not sure how
much that would scale yeah I would like
I would like actual data on that as well
so thank you thank you other
questions I'm seeing none thank you uh
ma'am did you submit some WR testimony
earlier have we already gotten that or
yeah oh okay all right
great there we saw it on the pink card
but I couldn't remember if we had gotten
it already or
not okay also signed up to speak is
laowa Condon from
Bedford and I know you have some written
testimony also
right
no you turned it
off yes you want the red okay you need
the red light you can hear me now okay
thank you good afternoon my name is
Laura Condon um for those wondering
where we live I'm from Bedford New
Hampshire um yes I'm New Hampshire
resident um a volunteer New Hampshire
director of advocacy with the national
vaccine information center I'm here to
testify in support of House Bill
1213 please take note that the analysis
statement for this bill is not correct
this bill makes no vaccination
requirements for public school children
nor does it change any of the
vaccination requirements nor does it
remove any requirements what this bill
actually does is remove certain
reporting burdens on private schools and
daycares and it also provides important
privacy protections that align with
privacy protections relative to
vaccination elsewhere in State Statute
and
rules I wish to point out the separate
immunization requirement provision the
enforcement provision and the exemption
Provisions in State Statute and you
touched on it representative Nagel
earlier you are correct there is the
immunization requirement provision
that's RSA 141 c20a Roman numeral 1 and
let me read that one for you it requires
that and I quote all parents or legal
Guardians shall have their children who
are residing in the State immunized
against against certain diseases these
diseases shall include but not be
limited to diptheria Ms protestas
politis rebell robiola and tetanus the
commissioner shall adopt rules under RSA
541a relative to other diseases which
shall require immunization period that's
the end then there is the enforcement
provision in State Statute which is RSA
141 c22a Roman numo 2 and that's in this
bill so I won't read it for
you but I want you to note that this
provision enforcement provision is using
schools and daycare agencies as the
enforcement mechanism for the very broad
immunization requirement I just read
please do not confuse the broad
requirement with the limited enforcement
mechanism then there is the separate
provision the exemption provision that's
RSA 141
c20c exemptions and that provides two
exemptions one is a medical exemption I
will not read um you can refer to that
and the other one Roman num a parent or
legal guardian objects to immunization
because because of religious beliefs the
parent or legal Guardians shall sign a
form stating that the child has not been
immunized because of religious beliefs
period I want you to note this exemption
provision is a separate section of RSA
141 C20 and is broadly stated there is
nothing in this provision that ties it
to schools or dayc carees it applies to
all children in the state whether
they're in a public school a private
school a daycare and no school or
daycare wherever there is an attempt at
the immunization enforcement provision
it is a very broad protection some
additional considerations in this bill
is that there's concern if a daycare
school is not an enforcer that they
won't accept all exemptions provided in
statute and may deny entry again these
exemptions apply to all children in the
state regardless of where they are
situated it would be unwise for any
private business to deny access based on
a parent use of a statutory vaccination
exemption is it would put the school or
business at Great risk of civil rights
action against the organization parents
in the state of Mississippi won a
religious exemption this past year when
a Federal Court ruled that the state
cannot afford a secular exemption which
is the medical without affording a
religious exemption because doing so
violated the First Amendment finally
there are other good Provisions in this
bill it will protect individual students
from the prying eyes of state government
this provision protects individuals from
having their private individual
immunization records viewed and perhaps
copied by DHHS this aligns with the
privacy protections relative to the
vaccination registry the government is
not authorized to view or obtain medical
maintain individual vaccination records
without specific individual written
consent I dare say that any parent who
submits a vaccination records to the
daycare is under no impression that DHHS
will be Marching In and looking at those
records I hope this bill will have your
full support I'm happy to take any
questions thank you representative Nagel
thank you Mr chairman thanks for taking
my question I just have a question that
you may or may not know the answer to
when the data is reported and I know
there's rules that had to be developed
is the data reported electronically by
paper is there a requirement of any kind
on how it has to be reported I don't
know how it's reported If It's Paper
electronic but the the bill is and the
Privacy protection it's removing is um
the provision um it's on line 10 of the
bill such records shall be available for
inspection during reasonable hours upon
request by the commissioner's design
which certainly indicates that they
could go in there and look at individual
records you all set representative Nagel
or okay okay thank you for the question
any other
questions seeing none he thank you thank
you no one else has uh signed up to
testify on hb1 1213
FN yes no just before the
gabble thank you representative
pzo okay representative Kelly penzer is
recognized sorry about that I was
holding on to
it so representative Kelly Patza
straford District 19 uh just speaking in
support of this bill I don't have too
too much to say except for I want to
speak on the private school aspect to
kind of answer representative um palmo
Chan
so my my kids have attended private
school for gosh 10 years now so
um at least that right uh so in all the
schools that they've attended you have
to provide you know an updated physical
and so my children were of course uh um
patients for Dartmouth Hitchcock and so
automatically on their physical form it
it automatically attaches the
immunization records the school that
they're currently at um this just re
kind of speaks to the Privacy issue and
my daughter was able to log in to see
all her you know her medical records
right there but it it wasn't really
locked down because they have a you know
they have an electronic portal so that
was a little concerning to me um more so
it's automatically the the immunization
records are attached to her current
physical so that's usually happening and
I don't I can't see that being different
for pretty most most of the parents that
are submitting information so and I also
believe that this this bill like it says
it's not um it's not uh stopping it
prohibiting it as well so it's making it
an option um in private businesses need
to be I think private businesses it's
different than the public and then in
regards with this the scholarship piece
which was interesting if they need that
information to be able to get um a
scholarship why wouldn't they just be
able to get that from the from the
families that are applying for those
scholarship funds directly why would
that have to be provided to by a daycare
center or another entity like that um
and then in regards to a question that
was asked asked by representative Paula
it it it talks about DHS and and they
that they don't purchase vaccines so
let's just be clear DHHS purchases
vaccines from the CDC so this year alone
DHHS will ask for uh over $25 million to
be paid to them through the vaccine
Association to pay for these vaccines so
I just wanted to be clear about that but
I fully support this bill and um I hope
you will
too any questions
seeing done thank
you okay I don't I know of no one else
I'm planning to testify I have no other
pink cards no one else has signed up uh
the blue sheet in the back where you can
sign up just to uh indicate your opinion
one way or the other if you're not
speaking has seven in favor two opposed
and one neutral party and on line uh
what did we have online um online we had
74 supporting and 69 opposing when I
pulled it up
earlier okay thank you okay it is now a
little past 2:45 so I'm going to close
the public hearing on hb1 1213 FN and
open the public hearing on HB 1661 FN
and recognize the prime sponsor
representative
Gearhart there he
is and we need a PIN card representative
oh you've got one okay good all
set
sure sure
sure is that Mr Bodwin or representative
Gart representative gead is you talking
about John Bodwin senior yeah okay great
thank
you good afternoon
committee
I'm being joined with John Bodwin J I'm
Jason Gard Northfield Franklin marac
25 John Bowman is a knowledgeable
individual on this bill he helped write
most of it this is relative to
immunization reporting requirements and
this bill requires death certificates to
record certain information regarding
immunizations received by The Descendant
the bill also establishes certain
reporting requirements for the
Department of Health and Human Services
regarding death records and immunization
I'd like to hand it off to John for the
time being and we'll just switch back
and forth but he has a handout that was
passed around that if you'd like to
address and take it on thank you thank
you very
much thanks for having me guys
appreciate being here um
so this bill is is unique in the entire
country uh what it's doing is allowing
the people access to the data that
belongs to the people which is the
health of the state so I'm just going to
start going through the handout a little
bit because it'll it'll lend some
structure to uh how you perceive the
data there was a an estimate of
$160,000 that was done by New Hampshire
with regard to this bill uh it doesn't
seem as though they looked at the other
column where it would save probably more
than a million dollars a year for the
state can't really talk about that in a
in a short time here so anybody is
welcome to contact me and I can go
through any financial analysis and also
point out the flaws in the 160k so uh
hb1 1661 would be a net budget reduction
for the Department of Public Health um
it would save lives that's the most
important thing save New Hampshire lives
and provide a better functioning
Department of Public Health and keep
them on Mission which is to uh for the
health and safety of New Hampshire
citizens without the bill the truth
remains hidden from the
people public confidence in dph will wne
as more people die which which has been
happening and uh people prescribed
medicines that were um recommended by
the government and I don't mean New
Hampshire not necessarily people who
rely on the CDC and FDA for uh what is
safe and effective they've been let down
uh many have been let down so let's talk
about one specific cause it's it's it's
the code is D68 but these are other
clotting defects
what you have here on this page these
are New Hampshire residents who died in
Massachusetts I have all the
Massachusetts death records it would be
illegal for me to have New Hampshire
records of the same type but I have
these legally from Massachusetts and of
ketris parabis all other things being
equal you see the bar of 2021 being very
high when it comes to clot
defects and uh one gentleman Martin from
summersworth he was 47 years old died
with multiorgan failure stroke
hypercoagulability that's hyper clotting
all of a sudden the guy started hyper
clotting all in days he did not have a
history of
this cardiac
amiloidosis which is a known condition
from covid gene therapy injections it's
known to happen so I I don't know when
he got his vaccine this could be
correlated and we don't have to let
private information out what this bill
does is
it makes sure that the public knows the
correlation of the immunizations to the
health outcomes which the people should
should know and have a right to know uh
with anemias there's thomy toena
inability to clot there uh lucenia
neutropenia um the example here is FBR
neutropenia in
hours acute myoid leukemia AML that's
also a signal that's been growing very
strong since Co
immunizations and you see that 21 and 22
are Al very high for New Hampshire
residents who died in Massachusetts
hospitals only again 21 and
22 uh this is sudden kidney
failure it's also called acute renal
failure this is probably the biggest
epidemic of single deaths since 1918
1919 and nobody's talking about it the
CDC knows this they have to know this
100,000 excess Americans died involving
acute renal failure in 21 and 22 and
very many in 2023 and the exact time
that it started happening was 2 weeks
after November 2nd which is cms.gov
where the
nctap which is the incentive 20% of the
entire hospital bill gets paid from the
federal government they get a bonus the
hospitals get a bonus the doctors get a
bonus for using REM Desir baricitinib
and other
medicines that's that's a big one so
Joseph was 30 years old multi-stem organ
failure in days pneumonia flu stafilic
cacus orius and sudden kidney failure he
was from Franklin New
Hampshire clots in the brain that cause
Strokes you see that 2022 is almost
double actually it's almost triple some
of the other
years Jeffrey was 53 years old died from
a stroke in days hypercoagulable in
months
again very hyper
clotting intraventricular Hemorrhage and
then El was 61 years old she died from a
cerebral herniation another kind of
stroke multifocal cerebral infarcts and
a bonus of an aortic dissection her
aorta blew apart those are also very
high since the vaccine if you want to
call it a
vaccine and lastly for these uh this set
is clots in lungs in Massachusetts
there's more than 500 excess pulmonary
embolism deaths in 21 and 22 alone
500 and I've correlated many them with
knowledge of their vaccination dates now
in New Hampshire you see that 2021 is
very
high Lindsay was only 27 years old from
Newton New Hampshire died August 4th
pulmonary thrombo Emile and deep bin
thrombosis those are usually in the calf
and they they call it throwing a clot
right it breaks off it travels to your
lung and then you can die and she did I
don't know our vaccination date but this
bill would force that analysis to be
done and that analysis is not being done
by any government at this time why it's
it's uh you know purposeful inaction
omission of conduct where there's a
legal duty to act and they should be
doing this so this this public oversight
in this bill would be the best in the
nation also Jeffrey was 30 years old
from eping New Hampshire cardiogenic
shock it says massive pulmonary embolism
in 6 hours he also had brain cancer in 8
months another signal known from the VAC
and um Amy was 40 years old disseminated
intravascular
coagulation all through her body coagula
and cloths all through her body and a
pulmonary embolism and
DBT now I I do write U on I write a
substack u probably two or three times a
month so I a journalist as a journalist
and a member of the press people
approach me with information from
official sources and I won't divulge it
if I don't don't think it's real but if
I check it out yeah I will so I'm going
to share some here
today this information regarding the
health of the people of New Hampshire
should not have to have been acquired as
I've done the data belongs to the people
not the government the government is of
the people here are some facts people
would have known if Bill 1661 was in
place years
ago at least 87 people when I say at
least it's because the data I have is
only a subset of people from New
Hampshire a small subset
87 people died in New Hampshire within 3
days of Co
immunization at least 50 died within two
days of immunization New Hampshire 24
died on the day of or the day after
immunization the next 11 people died on
the same day New Hampshire of
immunization Rodney Lucas was 62 Barbara
Jenkins 68 Amy Thomas 72 Daniel Cheney
was
76 an kazak 76 7 Louise Fontaine 81
margarit timage 83 Roger pinchard 83
Katherine DS 84 Sheila green 85 may you
just give the ages and not the names
since you have last names there for
privacy okay sorry I I finished
actually um and that is that is the
problem in that do we want to keep
secret from the people things that are
killing the
people I mean the point is the the
health and safety of the public and so
you know they all died on the same day
of immunization and I'll I'll skip the
last name for the the others but so Anna
Tucker was 26 years
old Anna died one day after
immunization her obituary says passed
away peacefully in her
sleep first name is going to give this
guy away stu um it's a unique name 35
years old died on Christmas Eve 2 days
after immunization unexpectedly
ly Robert died March 19 2022 4 days
after immunization of matching V's
report
report mentions
cardiomyopathy because they gave an
immunization to a guy with a heart
transplant in
2017 why would you give somebody a
medicine for a heart he had a heart
transplant he also had a bone marrow
transplant in
20121 and if you remember I mentioned
AML earlier he also had acute myoblastic
leukemia
now I know from the Massachusetts data
and the Minnesota data I have a million
death certificates
unredacted probably the only one in the
world outside government and if you
haven't seen my analysis I I can send
you a copy I have uh two books coming
out uh within three
weeks so because the government refuses
to look at this data and hides the data
from the people very few of us know that
AML is Common from this vaccine so is
lymphoma and all the blood causes on the
trifold that I went through a moment
moment ago all pretty common from the
covid vaccines it's it's not down party
lines you shouldn't have an Orthodoxy
one way or the other I don't care the
reason I looked into this is because I
lost my son and I wasn't doing anything
else and I'm depressed and so I just
want to save kids the adults can take
take it because do your homework if you
haven't looked into what this actually
is and the defects in manufacturing that
Kevin mckernan found and if you don't
know what I'm talking about you should
really look into that so I don't know
how many lawyers are here but
manufacturing defect is a strict
liability standard very easy to to
determine they didn't meet their own
specifications and they shipped the
product anyway so the product has DNA
contamination in the form of plasmas and
I'm not a scientist so I won't go into
that in detail but the point is they're
shipping contaminated product to the
public and nobody's saying anything the
government's just saying take it take it
so this bill 166 you want I'm just going
to close by
saying it just gives transparency to the
people and it doesn't matter what side
you're on if you believe vaccines are
safe and effective great this will prove
it this will prove it it'll prove them
safe and effective or it'll prove them
not safe and effective and when I say
them some of them are going to be good
some of them are going to be bad because
it's it also has to do with all
medicaments not just vaccines so if if
rames is good or bad we'll find out if
it's a combination of why aren't they
looking at rames in combination with
Bank of
meon that's that's a very strong
antibiotic given kind of in the end as
people go septic but I guess I'll just
thank you very much for your time I hope
this impressed something on you and if
you have any questions please please ask
me because this is so important
representative Gad do you have any thing
to add or are you just uh just going for
the right no um I would just I was
hoping John would talk briefly about the
last part the audits I think that's key
transparency is the mission here because
there's been I don't I don't know what
the right word would be but there's been
a drop in people getting vaccinations
because of fear and concern and so forth
so the best way to bring back trust is
to show the truth and this is part of it
so if you want to speak briefly about
that just explain independent nature of
it uh the the section one um it requires
that the vaccine dates im or
immunization any immunizations given
within the last two years prior to dying
be put on the D ific it's a nominal less
than 5 minute thing that any medical
examiner doctor can do um the analysis
of
$16,000 was was grossly exaggerated
because all you really have to do is
look for the number of unique names in
the death certificate database in New
Hampshire and only those people would
have to be
trained um let me skip to the LA it also
forces the Department of Public Health
to do quarterly reports which would take
maybe I don't know 15 minutes to 30
minutes you know and they put put out a
quarterly report it's just you write
some scripts and you correlate two
databases the immunization database and
the death certificate or or Medicare if
you want to get complicated um the last
one though is really uh interesting I I
like it of course I wrote it but
um it allows the people to come in State
offices and audit the data not just
everybody but people have to submit
reports and of those reports four are
drawn by
Lottery and the people doing the the uh
the work cannot have been in Pharma
industry uh any Eco Pharma ecosystem
company or government so it allows four
entities it could be four groups or four
individuals or mix to come in and look
at the data under NDA the data exists
for a reason it's to be studied and the
studying of that data would provide
invaluable information to the people
with regard to Public Health the reason
the public health department exists is
for the safety of the the public and yet
they're not doing anything with it
nobody is so the the last part is is
pretty key um it allows the people to
have access to the data with reports and
no one's names all privacy laws are
adhered to there's absolutely no problem
the only reason to be against this is if
somebody's trying to hide something and
no people on both sides should be for
this right Thank You representative
barma you had a
question yes thank you Mr chair and
thank you for taking my question so one
clarification I never got a bonus for
taking for uh prescribing remes of here
so I missed out on something um but my
concern is um and and my question will
follow is um I was a hospice medical
director for about 30 years so I filled
out a lot of death certificates and I
rarely would have had the information on
vaccinations because a lot of the times
a patient will have shown up at our
hospital I won't have the Rec Rec
records for that and obtaining them
would be very difficult and I and I
still would probably not know for
example if they got a CO vaccination at
a pharmacy it it wouldn't be there so it
would be very hard to collect this data
I wonder if you um did any research on
that and how that might be made easier
because it would be really I mean it
would have it would take me hours to
find that I can explain that yeah so in
fact in that analysis of the $160,000
what they're doing is they're talking
about how long it would take to train
doctors to have access to the New
Hampshire immunization information
system which exists and that that's a
registry of all the vaccinations people
have gotten if they didn't want it you
know uh there is a box you can check for
it to be redacted and in the case where
it's not there it's not there but in
case where it is there it would require
a doctor to look it up and that that
would be like less than a five minute
thing you just go into the nhi
IIs you log in and you'd probably
already be logged in if you're doing
death certificates if you're a medical
examiner but if it's a doctor you're
probably talking you know if somebody
dies in the in the presence of a doctor
attending uh that's when a doctor fills
out the Des certificate and in that case
it depends you know if they work in a
care home they're going to be doing a
lot of them if they're just you know
regular family practice and somebody
dies it's probably like once a year
right so you know it might take them 10
minutes instead of five minutes it's
really no big deal it's pretty easy to
do representative King and then
representative palazov thank you Mr
chair thank you for taking questions I'm
a little
confused what is it about Massachusetts
that is different than New Hampshire um
you've got some case individuals here
and their cause of death um I guess they
put that on their vital their Vital
Records they they put that on their
death certificate does New Hampshire not
do that does New Hampshire not put a
cause of death or New Hampshire has a
state law that doesn't allow me to have
those records it's privacy there are
certain so it's it's governed by state
law um it's not a privacy and death
HIPPA violation that's federal law and
there's the Hippa doesn't apply to dead
people so each state has privacy and
many of the states have 50 years some
have 70 years privacy and death where
they wouldn't allow me to have a
database a full database of all the
deant um Massachusetts apparently does
allow me to have it and Minnesota as
well um and Vermont we have also but
Vermont does not have the icd10 codes
from the CDC so it's a little different
follow up follow up follow up so it's
not on their death certificates but the
information is available or it is on
their death certificates
New Hampshire has the same death
certificates as everybody else there's
part one and part two part one has cause
a BCD part two has conditions
contributing the causes are in part one
and you should not have anything on
there that's not causal in the causal
chain of events that cause death however
many of them do it wrong um you a very
large number of doctors uh no no offense
fill out the uh death certificates
improperly medical examiners do a better
job it's supposed to be in a reverse
time order where cause a is the
immediate cause and the last one listed
in ABC or d whether it sometimes is only
one filled out a sometimes it goes to D
but the last one is supposed to be the
underlying cause of death or root cause
which is the thing that started the
causal chain of events that caused the
death but a lot of them do it in reverse
time order backwards so I hope I
answered your question yes um may I have
one more followup one more followup okay
um would it would it not be beneficial
for us to more or less copy what
Massachusetts does and at least allowing
that information to be accessible like
you currently have with Massachusetts
um I mean that would be good but that's
only the death death certificate
database if if I were if I had the
Massachusetts data and access to the
immunization information registry system
they call it it's the misis you have the
NH in Indiana they call it chirp and
California it's cares it's different
acronyms but they're all the same thing
anybody who does that I will end the
entire debate in a week Ron DeSantis and
Joe lpo have a proposal for me from a
year and a half ago and a year ago and I
told him the invitation is open he's
been told by six very well-known
International people just just have them
come in for a week or two you know just
give me access all you got to do is
correlate the two databases and debate
ends I'll find over 10,000 people in
Florida pretty easily thanks
representative
palazov thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question uh I I like the idea
of trans parency and you and and and you
put here 10 days of close of each fiscal
quarter so my understanding is uh uh
some uh
manufacturers uh they don't oppose to
transparency they only ask for 70 years
to be transparent about what's going on
and my understanding is that new ham is
also is not opposed to
transparency we have DHHS uh uh visit
portal but it shows mostly data going up
to
2019 so my understanding is that all
those deaths and all those uh spikes
like an acute kidney failes and such
wouldn't be accessible to public if we
are looking only up to
2019 so my point is like so it usually
takes time sometimes it's for good
reason uh to release
data so what what what's what's a good
time like let's say they say it's
impossible to do it within 10 days like
would be like 6 months be a reasonable
the time or 5 years or 70 years like
what's reasonable yeah no I can comment
so there's there's provisional data
that's not been verified and that's
usually like a year year and a half
depending on the the jurisdiction so
that the federal government um I can't
remember but it's about six months when
they say these death U the data that
they're providing is provisional saying
you you can't rely on it they it's
really legal and deification the data is
pretty good uh but what if your if your
Public Health Department is indeed a a
vigilance a sentinel uh standing you
know on the wall looking out for the
public health they should be looking at
it weekly you know pathogens come into
um our society all the time I found
things in 2018 nobody ever knew about
there are anomalies in various causes of
death such a system that I've created
could potentially if you put all the
data in there and I do all the the uh
put all the parameters in I could tell
you well 39 years ago in these two zip
codes there was an increase in B cell
lymphocytic leukemia let's go look at
their water supply from then we have the
water reports from then was the there
too much nickel or cadmium this is the
type of intelligence that's so easy to
do the system I've created doesn't exist
anywhere in the world and yet the data
is available to the government so um you
know representative Paul of I can't
answer like a definitive date but if you
have a Department of Public Health whose
mission is the health and safety of the
public they should be looking at it
weekly I mean the the the reports are
rolling in and okay if it's provisional
that means somebody outside the
government looking at it you're just
it's legal indemnification where you're
saying don't you can't rely on it we're
not responsible if there's a mistake all
right that that's just
semantics representative Lon um thank
you Mr chairman and thank you for all
the research that you've done and for
coming to um share some of your findings
um my first question is around the data
that you're looking to get from the IIs
my question would be um just so that we
can have good solid data and be able to
show which events have no relationship
to a vac vaccination event and to be
able to appropriately case match them
between those with a vaccination event
and those without would you be amenable
to having um it indicate whether a
person um has no IIs record because they
have not enrolled in the IIs or if they
have a record with with no vaccination
events because those two it could
confound the data if you have somebody
who has not chosen to participate in the
registry versus those with no vaccine
offense yeah absolutely if if uh if they
chose not to participate the record's
not there it's not there you know you
you can't blame um so if there needs to
be wording I can't remember what the
exact wording is I thought I I counted
for that because if there's no record
you can't blame a guy for not putting it
on the death certificate I that's what
you're saying right
yeah and then as my followup um I think
that this idea of these audits are
incredibly helpful but I do know that
Academia or Pharma may also be
interested in this in order to improve
outcomes my question would be that if
those four audit roles are not filled
with um private individuals or with the
public um if opening up those to
Academia or to um or to Pharma companies
or anybody who's Associated who want to
get those data and perhaps improve life
would be beneficial yeah I I don't think
it needs to be statutorily included um I
believe that the Department of Public
Health could probably have them just
sign a contractor agreement and invite
them in to look at the data under NDA I
don't I don't know that what this does
is it compels that the work be done for
the people but if you want to add Pharma
that would be up to you know your uh HHS
Department thank you thanks other
questions representative Nagel thank you
for taking my question um or Mr chairman
sorry it's late thank you for taking my
question I I have actually two questions
one has to do with the data that you're
collect cting that you want reported
within such and such a time frame I mean
one of the things we know in medicine is
that Association doesn't necessarily
imply cause and what I'm looking at is
the data that you want on a on a Rel on
a regular basis implies a number of Co
morbility a vaccine type things like
that I don't see type of cause of death
listed in that data that's being asked
for is that something that you would
want um whoever did the audit of the
Public Health Data I didn't you know I
would hope that it was the immunization
registry all Medicare and Medicaid what
are they being treated for so if
somebody dies on the same day as
vaccination and about half of the ones
that I found were actually fentanyl
overdoses yeah okay not not these but I
so would you blame the vaccine for that
I mean I would because I think it
affected their brains to cause him Comm
suicide but that's a stretch right so
what what you're
saying yeah correlation doesn't equal
causation it's a catchphrase we all now
know um it's been drilled out there in
the public uh domain but when you see
that everybody and this is how I found
this stuff when when Cassidy a
seven-year-old girl in Massachusetts
died they said she died from covid and I
was like no way and and I went and got
the half a million death certificates
and I found that it does say she died of
that but then I found a Bears record for
a seven-year-old girl the only girl in
that time frame who was vaccinated five
days before Cassidy died and she reacted
in 5 minutes vomited for 8 to 10 hours
they gave her a second vaccine a couple
weeks later and then that one is the
date of January 13 2022 she had
immediately stomach uh stomach pain she
had 103 degree fever didn't have a
bottle movement for three days and
Cassidy baraca was dead on um January 18
sorry I I'm not sure if I ask the
question well when I'm looking at the
data that you want there's nothing
listed in there as cause of death I mean
you have the age when they the
vaccination the the death certificates
have cause of death H what's that death
certificates have cause of death on I
know but this is the data that where
you're asking the state to
report so in section um new section two
public immunization death reports um
you're asking for aggregate data to be
sent I didn't see anywhere where the
actual causes of death were going to be
included in that data it seems to me
that would be
important so the section two that you're
there's there's multiple twos on here
can you reference page number line
number 25 on page one and it goes all
the way to line 13 on page two or 10 oh
yeah so um correct I didn't have cause
there just how many people died within
um one day of vaccination three days one
week three weeks 10 weeks 25 weeks and
the numbers are what they are just
report them to the public just Cur I'm
sorry I want to get to my other question
to my other question
follow why does that help you how does
it help you because you understand cetch
catch's parabis and what it means right
yeah so all other things being equal if
there's all of a sudden a spike and a
jump yeah then you have to investigate
they the public would say darn it you uh
HHS of New Hampshire we want you to
investigate and if you investigate and
find their all pulmonary embolism deaths
well you have a problem you figure out
the cause but if it's fenel and some guy
fell off a cliff and a school bus got in
an accident and all of a sudden a bunch
of kids died you'll find out almost
immediately and you'll report it to the
public but those anomalies that occur as
a matter of of con quence of accidents
people are going to know about but all
of a sudden pulmonary umm deaths you're
going to know this this reports it to
the public it won't create fear or panic
it'll just create the the public to
demand of the department tell us what
happened please that's
all can I ask a second question second
one You' asked about four no they were
follow-ups on the first this is totally
different is it a quick one yeah I think
so I um in terms of the um the uh audit
how you select that I'm con I I'm a
little concerned about who can apply to
be an auditor for example if I wanted to
just put in a my name into the lottery
with no ability to analyze data am I
allowed to be one of the people no it it
says in there they have to has to have a
level of competence so each proposal
that is that is submitted so you submit
a proposal the proposal has to have
certain um metrics like you're going to
do like I I don't like uh statistical
methods with regard to epidemiology but
most of you guys do um I I'm an engineer
I like waveforms and and calculus and
other stuff one of them but if somebody
wants to submit a proposal it has to
have a level of competence not anybody
can submit one but you're going to
choose the ones that get to be chosen
the four that get to be chosen from the
lottery it has to meet certain standards
absolutely he other questions
representative question thank you Mr
chairman thank you for being here uh can
you explain why the dates of reporting
are contingent upon the dates of uh
presidential and midterm elections yeah
absolutely um everything is political
these days and that is the greatest
amount of avoidance you could possibly
have from any political uh election and
if the information were to get out to
one candidate not the other some people
would rely upon it better um it would
probably not be good it wouldn't be fair
so this is the fairest way it could be
they would have a year to know about it
before any election that's why
other
questions I'm saying no other questions
thank you gentlemen thank you thank
you I really do thank you very much okay
thank
you also signed up to speak are Ryan
tanan and chawi chawa from the
Department of Health and Human
Services
all right good afternoon again I'm uh Dr
Ryan tanion uh bureau chief of the
Bureau of Infectious Disease Control I'm
joined by chawe chaa who is our bureau
chief for the Bureau of public health
statistics and informatics and we are
here today to uh speak in opposition to
House Bill
1661 um as you know House Bill 661 if
enacted would amend RSA 5 C 64a to
require death certificates issued in New
Hampshire to include immunization
records um but sourced solely from
individuals uh who are participating in
the New Hampshire immunization
information system the proposed
legislation also has specific
immunization data elements reporting
requirements and as others have spoken
already uh some independent audit
reports so first house bill 1661
conflicts with RSA 141 c2f Roman numeral
5 which outlines the allowable use for
nhis information under current law
allowable uses include ensuring
participants receive recommended
immunizations in a timely manner
facilitating reminders or notices to
participants when due for recommended
immunizations and assisting in indent
identifying individuals who may require
immunizations during disease outbreaks
so limitations on the use of participant
information were established for the par
protection of privacy and expanding this
use as outlined in House Bill 1661 it
would not be considered
allowable House Bill 1661 also conflicts
with RSA 141 C20 F Roman numeral uh VI
subsection F and administrative rule HP
30704 which is related to authorized
access to
nhis so authorized access is limited to
administering current and former
Healthcare Providers the the division of
Public Health Services with limited
access provided to schools child care
agencies and local Health departments
under the current statute and Rule not
all persons who may medically certify a
death record such as the medical
examiner are authorized unrestricted
access to the
nhis so the department believes that
broadly granting unrestricted access to
nhis to any person who can certify a
death certificate could be costly and
present privacy and security concern s
uh if enacted we would require
additional safeguards to protect
participant information from potential
unauthorized
access additionally house bill 16006
from the 2022 session amended nhis to be
an opin in voluntary registry so as a
result immunizations immunization
records of persons who did not
voluntarily choose to participate in the
registry could not be included as part
of their death certificate so other imun
ization records that are not contained
in the
IIs U may be omitted or would be
unavailable and those include medical
records Med uh records of persons who
have opted out or withdrawn their
information from the registry or those
who have SE received immunizations
outside of New Hampshire so because the
legislation does not require other
sources of immunization records to be
included as part of a death certificate
this legislation is establishing a
biased standard for nhis particip an
when compared to non-participants of the
registry so functionally information in
the IIs may be incomplete or potentially
incompatible to align with death
certificates processed by the division
of Vital Records
Administration data in the
nhis would be considered incomplete for
the purpose of vital record standards as
it may be self-reported it could and
also be changed by the participant so
unlike for Vital Records nhis does not
require the use of a participant's legal
name permanent address or contain other
identifiers such as a driver's license
or Social Security number so the
department is concerned that the
information between the two two systems
could not correspond to the exact death
certificate placing a burden and
liability on the person certifying the
death
certificate and then lastly the
department we use a robust contract and
procurement process to facilitate audits
uh selecting an auditor through a random
Lottery would bypass wellestablished uh
competitively bid and thorough vetting
process so the department uses a minimum
necessary approach when granting access
to data sets containing personally
identifiable
information or information technology
platforms and we believe that house bill
1661 would weaken measures currently in
place to protect and maintain the
Integrity of these data and patient
information and this language does not
set forth clear standards certifications
or qualifications of the persons or
organizations conducting such audits so
in summary the department is opposed to
House Bill 1661 due to the data
limitations potential incompatibilities
of the data sets uh as it relates to
death certificates and we believe that
there's also a undue burden placed on
the uh persons who are medically
certifying death certificates and we
would be happy to answer any questions
thank you representative Weber
thank you Mr chair and thank you very
much for taking my question I just had a
question on your written testimony was
that submitted through the system or was
it because I haven't seen it and maybe I
just missed it because I wasn't here at
the very beginning thank you for the
question it was submitted
electronic could you very kindly in the
future also submit it in print copy for
those of us who keep our
records in print it would be really
helpful and I didn't catch any of those
citations and I'm the I'm the person who
likes citations so that would be helpful
absolutely thank you and there have been
issues with the submission system in the
past representative Missour thank you Mr
chair thank you for taking my questions
my question I might have one more um is
DHHS as alarmed as a a lot many other
people um regarding the amount of sudden
deaths turbo cancers Etc that have been
happening ever since the covid vaccine
has been released is is that on your
radar are you alarmed At All by it is it
anything you're going to be looking into
or think you should be thank you for the
question so DHHS where we are
specifically in the division of Public
Health Services we um when we look at
death data it is based on what is
reported through the vital record system
and the death certificates uh we
wouldn't necessarily look at anything
beyond that unless there was a concern
and as far as uh deaths reported related
to vaccines that is uh reported through
the v's vaccine adverse event reporting
system which can can be done by medical
professionals but it can also be done by
anyone and it's also um
self-reported yeah follow up y so um the
amount of sudden deaths and also the
ages of the people as to where this is
happening that you're saying that this
isn't hasn't just spiked an alarm that
hey maybe this is something we should
look at because this person is 27 year
old 27 years old this person's a
teenager myocard artist all of that like
this is all just I mean anyone right now
can look around and see what's happening
so
so it the fact that is DHS are are you
at
all forming any kind of committee or
anything to look into this in to what's
happening is that on your radar did you
yeah I um for the record my name is joa
Chola C A Hui CH a WLA I'm the bureau
chief of Public Health statistic
informatic so on the division of Public
Health Services we do publish uh
aggregate that data on our data system
uh right now the most current one I
believe is
202022 we are waiting for the final um
confirmation from the most recent year
data from those data portal as well as
the statistic reported that we um
release based on the program needs we do
focus on certain indicators uh just
before this um this hearing uh I have my
staff to look into the most current
death certificate data to see if there's
any uh vaccine uh causing adverse effect
um this type of Records using icd1 Code
uh so wh does have um icd10 code for
covid-19 vaccine which is U1 12.9 I we
look at that data uh uh this coding
excuse me the ICD codes against the
deide record data we found no record
that um has the
we found no record that um you know
related to those icd10 codes that we
looking into that related to the vaccine
um adverse uh effect so we do look into
uh different kind of topic um for the uh
reporting
purpose and I'm sorry just I just want
to um emphasize that uh this bill will
amended the RSA 5c
64a this is under uh division of Vital
Records Administration which is under
secretary of state so New Hampshire is
the only state that the vital records
statistic reporting system over B record
statistic data system not under Health
Department in the nation so to amend
this part we will need to uh work with
the division of vital record
Administration uh if the if the B is in
act and I believe that the division of B
record Administration also me a written
testimony uh as far as we were
told y representative Leon and then
representative Weber I think you have
your
hand okay representative Leon sorry can
I ask one follow-up question to
representative Missour and then ask my
questions the first question would was
about the icd10 codes for the co
vaccination are those only for people
who have been vaccinated in a do
doctor's office or would that also
capture those who are going to a drug
store or some other location that's not
a doctor's office for that
Administration the icd1 codes that I
just mentioned is uh based on the bu
certificate uh on the um cause of death
description and also the ICD code that
transferred uh from the birth
certificate uh this ICD code so uh this
will be certified uh by the either
medical examiner or their CER uh
certifiers to fill out this form so uh
this part of information
um I'm not in the best position to
answer how this is a certified how that
certificate is a certified but the icd1
code is based on our uh search through
all the icd10 mortality codes uh that
related or has vaccine as a keyword we
use that uh as our um very roughly um
just have a fresh look and to search
those codes in the v death certificate
uh database and we found um no record um
redated to vaccine adver effort based on
our current database that we have access
to okay is that another followup
followup um my my next my my actual
question that I was initially trying to
ask um I know that we've seen the v's
data and there's been a lot of
skepticism about the applicability of
the vers data um I'd like to know how
you view self-reported information such
as the vs database as opposed to more
pop populationbased um recordkeeping how
in Sweden we're able to look with they
have a lot of information on their
population and their health and there's
a lot of population-based data would
having this information including a
recognition for those patients who have
no IIs record and therefore it's not a
zero entrance it's a null entry give us
something that is more meaningful than
Bears even if we aren't able to reach
the Swedish registry model to look at
look at case matched p people and see if
there is a signal of risk here in New
Hampshire or a signal of no risk quite
frankly practically this could be done
however we w we are worried about the
data limitation and data quality
particularly in our uh New Hampshire in
immunization information system excuse
me um like Dr tenan addressed that NH is
um uping and self report voluntary
system so uh some identifiers such as
names uh and address we we don't
validate that um so in order to link
back to our um in order to link back to
the V record that certificate data it
probably won't have the one-on-one match
it would be very fuzzy match in that
sense to
identify how many you know to to make
some connection between those two system
would be a little bit risky and the
result may not be really meaningful in a
a statistic standpoint but so we uh are
happy to look into and maybe do some Pro
of concept however this will have a
further discussion
um all right one more followup follow up
um so I recognize that there are some
that are not going to be able to me
match to the registry if out of a 100
deaths um 10 let's say only 25% of them
had have valid entries with which to
compare with the IIs in which you either
have records of vaccination or no
records of vaccination is there value to
be able to case match those individuals
to look and see if there is either a
signal of risk to the people of New
Hampshire or to say that we have case
matched and we are not seeing any
indication of higher mortality after
these vaccinations and to start
rebuilding that trust that's so
desperately
needed again um based on the data system
quality and limitation we don't
recommend to do so uh until we have
really comprehensive is system
established and the uh data points are
all validated then we can perform that
right now we can look into the V records
uh that certificated data set and using
the um cause of that description and
also ICD code to identify how many
people are you know certified with this
typ were certified on under this type of
cause of debt and produce that result
and in fact um division ofal record they
do have neverin and HB r n uh statistic
um Reporting System query system
available for all the public you know um
users to be able to query uh for the
underlying cause of death um that part
does not really connect it to any is uh
system or vaccine data but to understand
the overall cause of death that would be
the entry point for us to use as well I
don't think I uh I don't think I answer
all your question and sorry if I missed
uh part of the question however maybe
you can describe on the I limitation
again yeah if I may you know sharing an
example of you know some of the
limitations as you know we spoken to
earlier uh for example with the IIs
system um there's no requirement to have
say a legal name so someone named
William could be in there as Bill or
Susan is in there as Sue so it it places
a tremendous burden on the certifier of
the death certificate to have to go
through all the you know you know
hundreds or thousands of Records in IIs
to ensure that the person they're
associating an immunization record to
matches someone's Legal Information
that's contained in the death
certificate I respectfully I think
you're overthinking that part but I know
that's your job so thank you
representative Shapiro
thank you Mr chair
so I might have this all wrong but um
when the medical examiner is determining
the cause of death and writing a report
do
they do they take into consideration
available medical records or interviews
with families that
might shed some light on whether there's
a correlation with a recent
vaccination I thank you for the question
but I don't believe we're in a position
to speak for the Office of the uh chief
medical examiner and their processes
okay thank you other questions
representative kushman thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for taking my
question um so even if we can't
crossmatch every death certificate to
every record in the vs uh I'm sorry IIs
um we would still be able to if there
were a significant climb in a certain
say it was a cyto storm was a cause of
death that all of a sudden had increased
fourfold um in this system and then
those there might be people who aren't
in the system or who um or who you
couldn't cross reference with but you'd
still have the signal there with the
data that you had
correct theoretically yes however
practically in you know is has some
specific use and um access restricted by
the law so for myself I don't have
access to I I have access to vital
record because I'm the data Steward but
I don't have access to uh I so in order
for us to do so like what Dr tenan
address we will need to look into the
statue on how who can access to um both
B records and I in order to do uh
performance that kind of work but back
to the data analysis and statistical um
one of the missions that the division um
of Public Health Services has is really
to provide meaningful uh data uh to the
public we try to be uh transparent as
much as possible without violating any
privacy and protecting the
confidentiality uh that is our mission
and goal to provide this kind of
meaningful data so um you know if the
data set is not really comparable
comparable or is not really has has lots
of limitation we really don't um want to
uh perform that kind of analysis and
deliver the report that may not be
validate follow up so it sounds like the
department admits that there are faults
with the uh V system and that it's not
adequate to perhaps make make
determinations on these things um and so
it sounds like we could have an
amendment to bolster our ability to
surveil these things in New Hampshire
would the department be willing to help
us write an amendment to Grant those
permissions yeah so thank you for the
question
um we would say that there's limitations
with the V system um you know just as
there are limitations here we would be
open to looking at any proposed uh
amendments represent
McLean thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question and sorry I came
in late I was testifying on another bill
but just does the does the medical
examiner who is writing up the death
certificate I know that the IIs is an
opt-in but do they have access to look
at the
I thank you for the question so
currently the medical examiner does not
have access to the IIs so at a minimum
I'm sorry Mr chair quick followup follow
so at a minimum we would need to grant
them access in order to go
anywhere as we interpret the bill it
looks like we would have to Grant anyone
who can medically certify a death
certificate access to the I thank you
representative palazov thank you Mr
chair and thank you for taking my
question for me it looks like age 22 so
uh we have uh people who write this
certificates they wonder why this
occurred and then you you use their code
to look if something happened for
example last year Dr Benjamin Chan
testified through DHHS that covid-19
vaccines indeed cause increase my
carditis in certain
G uh in certain
populations uh so so but
before that like for a
while uh uh it was pushed on public it
pushed on medical examiners that uh my
vaccine related my carditis is medical
misinformation people were losing their
licenses for even mentioning it so of
course they were not putting those
quotes uh ICD 10 codes uh because they
didn't want to say that it cost for
vacine I didn't they didn't know better
what what stopped the heart of a young
boy so so you wouldn't look in that Des
because it's not on the code and the
code wouldn't be there because they were
said it's not happening so my
understanding is that we need something
like this bill uh like to try to came
out from this Catch 22 situation could
you
comment I'm I'm sorry could could you
actually State what the question
was uh so besides this uh enacting this
Bill how are we fix this situation when
you only
look in uh vaccine
related this if it's already listed as
vaccine related death and don't
investigate for example if boys are
dying from my carditis in 2021 nobody
would put it as vaccine related death so
you would never look into it so how do
we fix this
situation um thank you for the question
but I think it goes back to a comment uh
I had spoken to
earlier the office of the chief medical
examiner and those processes are
separate from the department and the
department isn't necessarily in a place
to validate or verify uh the information
that
um persons who are certified or persons
who are eligible to certify a death
certificate place on
there other
questions okay I think we're all set
thank you thank you thank
you also signed up to speak is Ben
Bradley from the New Hampshire Hospital
Association
good afternoon Mr chairman and members
of the committee my name is Ben Bradley
vice president state government
relations for the New Hampshire Hospital
Association representing all the state's
Community Hospitals and all specialty
hospitals in New Hampshire um the
hospital Association is opposed to HB
1661 and has several concerns with the
bill which would require additional
steps for providers to comply with RSA
5-c 64 medical certification of the
death
record this would include emergency room
doctors physician assistants advanced
practice registered nurses and long-term
care providers among others who may
certifi death certificate so not just
the medical examiner of the
State current statute States quote the
medical certification on the death
record shall be completed by the
attending physician APRN or physician
assistant or certifying physician APRN
or physician assistant and made
available to the funeral director next
of kin or designated agent as soon as
possible but no later than 36 hours
after the time of
death we're concerned the language in HB
1661 would create delays to Medical
certification of death records given the
requirements in this bill to include
additional data elements from the New
Hampshire immunization information
system this bill would also require
access to and training on the use of the
nhis which is not currently afforded to
all providers who may certify death
certificates additionally providers
would be responsible and likely liable
for positively identifying a New
Hampshire IIs participant is the same
individual they are certifying in a
death record this could be particularly
challenging as the does not include
identifiers that would be needed to
confirm the patient's
identity thank you for the opportunity
to provide feedback on this bill we
remain opposed and respectfully request
the committee itl the bill I'm happy to
answer your questions thank you any
questions seeing none okay thank you
thank
you should probably get aink card
okay again thank you Mr
Broadley um before I close this public
hearing I have no one else signed up to
testify on hb1
uh I I do want to just read the uh those
who signed in expressing support and
ouros um see one
two nine people signed up to indicate
support for this bill uh two signed up
to oppose this
bill that is uh for those who were not
going to be testifying today uh and I
have the online okay okay and what's the
online and online there were 155 in
support and 37 against and one
neutral okay uh having nobody no one
else signed up to speak today I'm going
to close the public hearing on HB 1661
FN and open the public hearing on uh hb1
1669 FN which we had continued to this
afternoon it was originally scheduled
for 11:15 a.m. and I'll recognize the
prime sponsor who is U the vice chairman
of this committee representative Erica
Leon from d
s
um thank you Mr chairman and members of
the committee and thank you everybody
for moving this later in the day because
in person this one had a lot less
interest than the other bills and those
of us involved were already here for the
day um I do want to say that online
there's a little bit more interest in
the bill than we're seeing here there
were 154 in support 44 opposed and one
neutral uh so as far as the New
Hampshire U immunization information
system it was first AU ized a long time
ago but it never really got up and
running until Co and when it was
necessary in order to record the vaccine
administrations that happened during
covid at the National Guard site and
others that happened outside of the
normal course um this has been a program
that's been discussed as a very big
interoperative um interoperative program
so that between states it'll be possible
to share information um we are a state
that takes our privacy very very
seriously and in 2018 we passed um
Amendment we passed Amendment 2B to our
constitution about that right to privacy
it's one of those things that we need to
make sure that all of our laws are
sweared up and trude with that privacy
and that is in the light that I brought
this bill this is simply designed to say
that we cannot share our IIs data with
any other organization or any other body
unless they are equipped to honor our
law for our withdrawal to treat our
privacy the same way that we treat our
people's privacy if they're not able to
do so then we shouldn't share that
information you know um there's some of
us that are more sensitive to vaccine
information there's other people who are
more sensitive to abortion information
but we should be treating all of our
medical information with equal care and
equal diligence um I had included a
section in the bill to say that upon
specific notorized requests by a patient
or the patient's parent or Guardian if
the patient's a minor immunization
records may be shared with a
non-compliant entity um I believe that's
why we have the massive fiscal note um
because this is a newer program I I
didn't quite recognize that the IIs
would not be pushing out one
individual's information this is looking
at the covid vaccine passport system
that was happening um I know people that
in order to attend conferences they
needed to be able to present their their
vaccine certification on their CA kind
of like the one um that the biotech
executive had been working on as well so
this this was something where somebody
would voluntarily share a vaccination
event in order to be um authorized into
a system I wanted to make it so that it
was easy for people to share their IIs
data but I think it's a a costly and
unnecessary one because that they can
ask their provider to share that
immunization so I would actually look
for us to limit this to only that first
sentence and to strike the second one
that says upon specific notorized
request because I believe that what is
what gives the $3 million price tag
because if we wait to share our data
with those who can honor our requests to
keep our our people's privacy um in
violate and to make sure that if we
withdraw from our registry any other
state will also withdraw that
information I think it's quite important
um I've been working with the Department
on some administrative rules that would
include language that is similar to this
but I think that it's important not just
to have an administrative rules but also
have to have it in the statutes because
we want to make sure that if it's some
point they decide to wash information
back and forth between different states
that those who have chosen to leave the
registry here in the state are not
involuntarily brought back in when their
information is shared with another state
and as this becomes a more fluid more
interoperative system you know we cross
state lines for all sorts of things you
know partly for some bills and other
committees but also to get health care
because we have people that go between
Vermont and New Hampshire
to Massachusetts and New Hampshire
especially for a lot of the Specialized
Care and to Maine so if if you're pulled
into that system and then your
information comes back and you've
withdrawn here I just want to make sure
that we're protecting people's privacy
so I know that the department has had
some concerns about the cost and I would
be helpful to know from them whether
removing that specific um that ability
to share with a non-compliant entity
would resolve the fiscal note and with
that I'm happy to take any questions
representative King thank you Mr chair
and thank you Madame Vice chair um I
know you weren't a co-sponsor of these
other bills we had just been discussing
but on the one hand you know it's like
we're talking about the IAS records are
quote unquote it's been referred to as
the people's records and we have a right
to know you know what who was vaccinated
for what and to tie that into cause the
death and stuff but then here it's like
well we need to make sure that stuff is
secret
so do you see any conflict between these
two ideas where on the one hand the IAS
you know information should be kind of
kept under lock and key and then another
way where it's like well we need this
information for public health benefits
what what are your thoughts on this um
so I was somebody who would have been
very very happy to enroll in a control
group registry when covid was first
hitting because I figured it'd be good
to be able to give my information um and
if we were doing Public Health efforts
to see how that compared to the natural
course and in others um I believe that
the data in the previous bill um sorry
I'll back up for just a second I've
dealt with a lot of data I've dealt with
a lot of information um when I was a
medical device analyst sometimes we'd
look to the populationbased records in
Sweden or in other areas and sometimes
in order to get good data from a
registry type scenario you're going to
have to look at a lot of Records to find
records that can actually be case
matched and that you can look at to see
if you can find good data I don't expect
that the prior bill will be able to look
at every individual because if if in my
mind it's properly drafted you have an
opportunity to say these are the records
who that are within that are in IIs or
they have an IIs but there were no
events during this time period or no
record found because no record found
doesn't say that they're not vaccinated
and it doesn't say that they are and
therefore to try to look at any
correlation or possible causality um you
would need to remove anybody who has
chosen not to participate in the IIs
system uh the big argument for the IIs
is for public health benefit so should
somebody choose to participate in it and
choose to be able to have their
information in there there is an
argument that it makes sense to then
correlate that so that they may be able
to work as an early warning signal to
others um when I was a device analyst I
actually got to know a pathologist Dr
Renu verman she um had noticed that as
she was doing some as she doing
pathology on patients who had had a drug
alluding stent um she was finding that
the drug that the coating the antibotic
coating had started flaking off and by
having that flake off they were having
late stent thrombosis events where it
was throwing it to another section of
the vasculature and then it was causing
other clotting issues both in the heart
in the brain and in the lungs had she
not been paying attention to this and
looking at that signal this wouldn't
have really become an issue this would
have been a discussion about are we
doing enough anti-coagulation and should
we extend anti-coagulation longer
because Dr verman spoke about this and
had limited data but data that gave an
indication work was done those codings
were changed and actually some people
some people changed their Clin iCal
course so you don't need to have the
information for everybody but if you're
able to find the information from those
people who are willing to be a part of
this data collection there's a high
value to it but because it's not a
prospective double blinded randomized
control study there's always going to be
limitations to the data but if this is
something our people are experiencing
does it make sense to as skydivers do
learn from the blood of others instead
of having to do it ourselves uh or does
it make sense to say just because
there's some challenges we don't want to
find any any signals and any messages
that people's people are leaving for us
so I know that's nuanced but I think
that I think that both of those are
valuable okay representative and then
representative farmer just a question I
mean I'm still putting in my mind as to
what the IIs is used for is it is it
used you know uh in in to look back at
specific cases for transference of
specific data or is it used just
anonymously for population studies um or
both um I'm just trying to understand
the scope of how data is used so we are
the last state thank you for the
question we're the last state to have an
active IIs system this is something
that's been building over the years and
quite frankly I don't think that all the
use cases and everything that it is
going to be used for is known at this
point because when you have a data
source there are lots of different
things that you can do and depending on
what limitations you have on the data
there's a lot that can be done um at the
departmental level because it's
something that's done through um an
executive branch agency and they have a
lot of authority to work within that
data which they have which is
appropriate because they should be able
to find signals and look and see if
after after a certain product is
released to the market if there's a
signal and death rates that's worth
looking into so we need to give them
some latitude and flexibility but it's
also important to make sure we have
guard rails and I think the fact that we
don't understand how the IIs will be
used now that 50 states are on board
especially how the IIs will be used once
all 50 states are freely communicating
with each other I think that it's
important to wait to put our information
into that free exchange with other
states until we know that the privacy of
our people can be respected and also at
this point the information is not being
shared with other states so this would
not be retracting anything that's
already happened it's simply putting a
condition on that expansion that unless
they can honor our privacy and our
constitutional provision for privacy
we're not going to share that
information followup just a quick
followup because I know a lot of the
discussion about the database for
example for abortion you know there was
discussion oh you know we're going to
anonymize that data things of that
nature and is that the ultimate
intention with the IIs along that same
lines or
um or is it no you can still go in and
get Erica Leon for example's data uh so
thank you for that question so some of
the federal grants that we accepted
during covid um were designed to look at
different Health Equity looking at the
vaccination rates looking at and looking
at it being a Health Equity issue for
undervaccinated populations by the
census block there are over 600 census
blocks in my town of Derry so looking at
that at that granular level and looking
to see that this neighborhood is
undervaccinated could in a different in
a different Administration and in a
different um makeup of people in the
government it could lead to a very
intensive very invasive door-to-door
offering of vaccination or and and I
recognize that this is this doesn't
concern everybody but the idea of going
by and saying I'd like to see I'd like
to see your papers have you been
immunized in this house
house is a very very dangerous thing
that is something that it was enabled
and was um I believe was worked towards
in some other states however the push
back against that very invasive level
did happen and so we did not violate
people's rights to that extent however
the words of that grant grant language
that was accepted by the executive
Council would have allowed that and it
would have in fact encouraged that
fortunately serer heads
prevailed
all saw all the hands up over here
um okay representative kushman thank you
Mr chairman and thank you um Madame Vice
chair I are you would you believe that
um administrative rules for the registry
do allow for deidentified data from the
registry to be released by the
department for research purposes um I
wasn't aware of that but I actually
think that that's good I love data but I
also like it with a good dose of privacy
and I think we need to balance the
two other
questions seeing none okay thank you
thank
you also signed up to speak are Ryan
tanan and Sherry chaer from the
Department of Health and Human
Services
thank you again Mr chairman uh Ryan
tanion I'm actually joined today by
anarie Mercury sorry actually the other
name is on the card though I didn't made
it wrong okay thank you thank you yeah
so I'm joined by Amar merer who's the um
administrator for the New Hampshire
immunizations program um so we are here
today just to provide informational
testimony for anyone on the committee
that they may have in relation to this
bill um as representative Leon had
mentioned we've been working closely
with with her um you know through the
administrative rules process which we
had a hearing on back on October 3rd uh
we collected that feedback that was uh
from that hearing as well as the
submitted uh feedback online we've
looked at the proposed rule again we've
gone back through with the bill
sponsor and we have made some you know
adjustments and we're you know just here
to say that um you know should you know
at this time we do not share our
information from the IAS with other
states or other ities um if we were to
that you know there is a robust process
that we would have to enter into a
memorandum of understanding and through
that memorandum of understanding process
we have looked in our rule as well as
through this uh legislation that we
would require that privacy provision
where individuals would be able to
withdraw their information as well um
again and uh if the bill sponsor chooses
to do an amendment then the department
would be happy to take a look at that
and update the fiscal note as well so
happy to answer any
questions any questions representative
Paz off uh thank you for taking thank
you Mr chair and thank you for taking my
question I'm still trying to figure out
your status in terms of vaccines like I
I understood that you don't sell
vaccines to individuals but is it also
correct that your PR uring vaccine on
direction of CDC through vaccine
Association sure I'd love to answer that
um good afternoon my name
is could we get the spelling of your
last name it's am m e r c r i c like
Mercury but with an i okay great thank
you s sorry much interrupt go ahead Mr
chair um thank you for the question so
uh there were a couple of questions that
came out earlier about the nhas so if
you don't mind could I explain a little
bit about the
nhas okay so thank you um so the NH is a
new system we launched it in April of
2021 um the primary intention as we were
building the nhas was to um assist and
support the state in maintaining the
accountability of vaccines that are
distributed through the New Hampshire
immunization program so those vaccines
are funded
through a combination of public funds
through the federal government under the
vaccines for children program also
another program that's Federal is the
317 program and that 317 program is for
underinsured and uninsured
adults um so for the adult section we
can only assist for the cost of vaccine
for those underinsured and uninsured
adults but for the children because we
participate in the federal vaccine for
children program and New Hampshire
statute allows us to collect funds
through the New Hampshire vaccine
Association um that would be assessments
from the insurance companies we are able
in New Hampshire to provide vaccine at
no cost to all children regardless of
their insurance
status so the program works to maintain
the accountability of these vaccines
because as you know vaccines are very
expensive very costly we want to do a
good job that we're a good Steward of
the
monies the um nhas also served to
consolidate immunization records for
those individuals who are participating
in the system so for individuals who
voluntarily choose not to give their
information that information is not
transmitted to the state so we don't
have any listings of people who um have
opted out we only really know the
information from the people who have
gone ahead and given that that con cons
send to share their
information um additionally it's only
the providers who receive the the
vaccine supplied through the state who
are required to participate in the nhas
so that means that if there are
providers who privately purchase the
vaccine they don't need to report that
to us it's only those who get the the
vaccine through
us um so that's just a little bit of of
the background there um so I just wanted
to make sure that we answered that
question and I am so sorry could you
please rephrase your original question
so I can make sure I address
that yeah yes so so just so you said
that you do collect funds and uh could
could you expand what uh where those
funds go do they fund uh general fund or
DS directly or split in some way okay
thank you very much because I think that
I did include that the funds for the
vaccines do come through the federal
vaccines for children program and then
the uh Federal 317 program as well as
the New Hampshire vaccine Association to
cover those non-vf C eligible children
so that all children can be
vaccinated other questions so the
department does not have General funds
for the purchase of the vaccine
representative mlan thank you Mr chair
and thank you for taking my question so
just as a point of clarification if I go
down then and I got my covid shot my flu
shot or whatever at Right Aid or
CVS um that's not going into the IIs
then that actually would go into right a
database or CVS's database and they
would retain that separately from the
IIs am I correct under normal
circumstances the vaccine that is not
distributed through us would not go into
the NH covid vaccine was very different
because under executive order
76 all covid vaccine from the federal
government and the state supplied had to
go into our our immunization registry so
covid vaccine was the only vaccine that
was not distributed fully through us
that also was reported to the
nhas follow up yes so all other vaccines
s so covid it's all in there if you opt
it in but everything else is not and
going forward Right Aid has their own
database kind of thing during emergency
order
76 um the ability to opt out was
temporarily suspended so therefore
individuals were not offered the
opportunity to opt out because of
emergency order
76 other
questions seeing done thank you very
much I have no one else signed up to
testify on HB 1669 FN uh the blue sheet
in the back indicated that uh 10 people
did sign in in favor and two against um
do we know what happened online and as
of right now we gained one person in
support since the introduction of the
bill with 155 supporting and 44 opposing
and one
neutral okay uh those are all the bills
we had noticed for today again I have no
one else signed up to testify on hb1
1669 FN uh so I'm going to close the
public hearing on that bill and um we
will be adjourned um we we're hereby
adjourned